by 48 and we are within days of securing
an historic achievement that being a
record number of police officers
nationally
all thanks to this party's commitment to
Law and Order but we must always strive
harder to keep the British people safe
the worst crimes flourish when lower
level crime is tolerated let me be clear
Mr Speaker there is no such thing as
petty crime
public first polling found that people
cited anti-social Behavior as the main
reason why their area was a worse place
to live than 10 years before the decent
hard-working law-abiding majority are
sick and tired of antisocial Behavior
destroying their communities
nobody should have to live in fear of
their neighbors and your disorder and
Drug taking in part see their streets
disfigured by graffiti fly tipping and
litter or feel unsafe walking alone at
night gangs of youths hanging around
getting up to no good intimidating us
all and degrading the places that we
love
personal experience around social
behavior is highest in the police force
areas of the Northeast Midlands and the
southeast
in Derbyshire northumbria and Durham at
least 45 percent of adults have
experienced anti-social Behavior as one
of the research participants in the
polling from Liverpool reported
anti-social Behavior makes you feel
unwelcome like you're not wanted or
loved like you don't feel like you
belong it does affect your emotional
well-being you don't feel safe you don't
know what's going to happen next I felt
like this for three years after since
I've lived here and I've been planning
on leaving for the past year
such sentiments are why my writer will
friend the Prime Minister has made
tackling anti-social Behavior a top
priority for this government
our anti-social Behavior action plan
will give police and crime Commissioners
local authorities and other agencies the
tools to Stamp Out anti-social Behavior
across England and Wales
it targets the callous and careless few
whose actions ruin the public spaces and
amenities that the law-abiding majority
depend upon our plan outlands outlines a
radical new approach to tackling
anti-social Behavior split across four
key areas firstly stronger punishment
for perpetrators we're cracking down on
illegal drugs making offenders repair
the damage they cause increasing
Financial penalties and evicting
anti-social tenants now the benches
opposite Madam Deputy speaker can't seem
to make up their mind on whether they
want to legalize drugs or not while the
leader of the opposition and the mayor
of London argue about cannabis
decriminalization we're getting on we're
delivering for the public
speaker drugs are harmful to health
well-being and security they devastate
lives
that is why I have taken the decision to
ban nitrous oxide
also known as Laughing Gas this is
currently the third most used drugs for
adults and 16 to 24 year olds by doing
so this government will put an end to
hordes of youths loitering in and
littering parks with empty canisters
furthermore under our new plan the
police will be able to drug test
suspected criminals in police custody
for a wider range of drugs including
ecstasy and methamphetamine they will
test offenders linked to crimes like
violence against women and girls serious
violence and anti-social Behavior
and we will ensure that the consequences
of those committing ASB are toughened up
our immediate Justice Pilots will
deliver Swift visible punishment for all
those involved offenders will undertake
manual reparative work that makes good
the damage suffered by victims
communities will be consulted on the
type of work undertaken that work should
start swiftly ideally within 48 Hours of
a notice from the police
and so whether it's cleaning up graffiti
picking up litter washing the police
cars whilst wearing high-vis jumpsuits
or west vests those caught behaving
anti-socially will feel the full force
of the law
the upper limits of on-the-spot fines
will be increased to 1 000 pounds for
fly tipping and 500 pounds for litter
and graffiti we will support councils to
hand out more fines to offenders with
councils keeping the money to reinvest
in cleanup and enforcement
now Mr Speaker nobody should have to
endure persistent anti-social behavior
from their neighbors Madam Deputy
speaker apologies that's why we plan to
halve the delay between a private
landlord serving notice for anti-social
behavior and eviction
will also broaden the harmful activities
that can lead to eviction and make sure
that anti-social offenders are
de-prioritized for social housing
secondly we're making communities safer
by increasing police presence in
anti-social Behavior hot spots and
replacing the outdated vagrancy Act
now the evidence is compelling Madame
Deputy speaker Hot Spot policing where
uniformed police spend regular time in
problem areas reduces crime
that's why we are funding an increased
police presence focused on antisocial
behavior in targeted hot spots where it
is most prevalent
we will support pilots in 10 Trail
Blazer areas before rolling out hotspot
enforcement across all forces in England
and Wales in 2024
and we're replacing the 19th century
vagrancy act which criminalized the
destitute with tools to direct
vulnerable individuals towards
appropriate support such as
accommodation mental health or substance
misuse services
we will criminalize organized begging
which is often facilitated by criminal
gangs to obtain cash for illicit
activity
we will prohibit begging where it causes
blight or public nuisance such as by a
cash point or in a shop doorway or
directly approaching someone in the
street
now rough sleeping can cause distress to
other members of the community for
example by obstructing the entrance of a
local business or leaving behind debris
and Tents so we will give police and
local authorities the tools that they've
asked for to deal with such situations
while ensuring that those who are
genuinely homeless are directed towards
appropriate help
and we'll build local pride in place by
giving councils stronger tools to
revitalize communities bring more empty
High Street shops back into use and
restore local parks
thirdly prevention and intervention
around 80 percent of prolific adult
offenders begin committing crimes as
children
we're funding one million more hours of
provision for young people in
anti-social Behavior hot spots we're
expanding eligibility for the turnaround
program which will support 17
000 children on the cusp of the criminal
justice system and our 500 million pound
National Youth guarantee means that by
2025 every young person will have access
to regular clubs activities and
opportunities to volunteer
and fourth improving accountability to
the public
a new digital tool will mean members of
the public have a simple and clear way
to report anti-social behavior and
receive updates on their case
we're also launching a targeted
consultation on community safety
Partnerships with the aim of making them
more accountable and more effective
Madam Deputy speaker this government is
on the side of the law abiding majority
we will take the fight to the
anti-social minority this government has
set out a clear plan and a clear set of
measures to do just this more police
less crime safer streets and Common
Sense policing I commend the statement
to the house
[Applause]
thank you madam Deputy speaker
my Deputy speaker this plan is too weak
too little and too late
the Home Secretary says people are sick
and tired of anti-social Behavior too
right they are because people have seen
serious problems getting worse and
nothing has been done but who does she
think has been in power for the last 13
years the Tory government that has
decimated neighborhood policing there
are 10 000 fewer neighborhood police and
pcsos on our streets today than there
were seven years ago half the population
rarely ever see the police on the beat
and that proportion has doubled since
2010. this is a conservative government
that has weakened anti-social Behavior
Powers 10 years ago brought in new
powers that were so useless they were
barely even used including the community
trigger and getting rid of powers of
arrest even though they were warned not
to yeah government that abandoned the
major drug Intervention Program that the
last Labor government had in place that
slashed youth service budgets the YMCA
Say by a billion pounds and who has let
charges for criminal damage have
Community penalties have halved and
there is a backlog of millions of hours
of community payback schemes not
completed because they can't even run
the existing system properly far from
punishing perpetrators of antisocial
Behavior they are letting more and more
of them off the result is Criminal
damage affecting our town centers is up
by 30 percent in the last year alone and
it is a total disgrace that too many
people especially women feel they can't
even go into their own town centers
anymore because this government has
failed them they don't see the police on
the beat and they do not feel safe
so what are they proposing now some of
the measures in here we support largely
because we have long called for them on
Hotspot policing we called for on faster
Community payback report called for we
support stronger powers of arrest and a
ban on nitrous oxide but look at the
gaps nothing for anti-social Behavior
victims still excluded from the victims
code and the draft victims law a failing
to community trigger all they're going
to do is rename it and relaunch it
re-announcing plans on youth support
that the leveling up secretary announced
over a year ago I noticed one new thing
in the document an additional 500 young
people will get some one-to-one support
well there were 1.1 million incidents of
anti-social Behavior last year so good
luck with that not introducing neighbors
respect orders and on neighborhood
policing astonishingly neighborhood
policing is not even mentioned once in
this document how on Earth does the
government think it's going to tackle
anti-social Behavior unless they they
bring back neighborhood policing teams
their recent recruitment to try and
reverse their own 20 000 police Cuts is
not going into neighborhood policing
there are 10 000 fewer neighborhood
police officers and pcsos in our teams
today than there were seven years ago
the labor has set out a plan for
thirteen thousand more neighborhood
police on the streets paid for by
savings identified by the police
foundation that the ministers are
refusing to make so will she now agree
to back Labor's plans to get those
neighborhood police back on the beat to
start taking action and I would say to
the Home Secretary Hot Spot policing is
not the same as neighborhood policing we
support Hot Spot policing to Target key
areas but it's not the same as the
neighborhood teams who are there all the
time embedded in the community who know
what is going wrong and why because
there are plenty of things that are
already crimes which are already illegal
whether police already have the powers
to act but they don't and no one comes
because there aren't enough neighborhood
police so will she apologize now to
people across the country for her cuts
of 10 000 neighborhood police and pcsos
for taking the police off the street so
people don't see them anymore because if
she doesn't realize that fewer police in
those neighborhood teams is causing huge
damage and undermining confidence then
she just doesn't get it really after 13
years is this the best they can come up
with
speaker
the more I listen to the right normal
lady the more confused I am about what
Labor's policy is she criticizes our
plan while at the same time claiming
that we've stolen there so I'm not
really sure which it is and given the
shadow policing ministers embarrassing
efforts to explain her own policy on
television last week I'm not sure any of
them really know what their policy is on
anti-social Behavior let me tell you one
big difference between the writable
ladies plan and ours like unlike her we
can tell the public how much ours will
cost and how we'll pay for it a big
question there yet to answer now the
shadow homes actually talks about
policing Cuts but never mind never mind
that we're recruiting 20
000 extra police officers the highest
number in history never mind that we've
increased Frontline policing which leads
to more visible and effective local
policing never mind that by the end of
this month we are on course to have more
officers nationally than we ever had in
2010 or in any year when labor was in
government
the shadow Home Secretary wants to talk
about safer streets Madam Deputy speaker
well let's compare our record since 2019
this conservative government has removed
90 000 knives and weapons from our
streets since 2010 violence is down 38
neighborhood crime is down 48 burglary
down by 56 and overall crime excluding
fraud is down by 50 so what of Labor's
record what can they show well where
labor leads crime follows under labor
pccs it's true I know it hurts but it's
true under labor pcc's residents are
almost twice as likely to be a victim of
robbery and knife crime is over 44
higher in London in London labor City
Khan wants to legalize cannabis in the
West Midlands the labor PCC wants to
close police stations
labor opposed plans to expand stop and
search they voted against tougher
sentences for serious criminals they
voted against our increased powers for
the police in our police crime
sentencing and courts Act
so we shouldn't be surprised Madam
Deputy speaker well this conservative
government is working to get violent
criminals off our streets it's labor
who's campaigning to release them the
leader of the opposition and some 70 odd
labor MP signed letters that's what they
love do they love signing letters so
many letters to stop dangerous foreign
criminals being kicked out of Britain
one of them one of them went on to kill
another man in the UK and we learned
this week that many others many others
went on to commit further appalling
crimes in the UK shameful outrageous
hang their heads in shame the truth
about Labor Madam Deputy speaker the
truth is that they care more about the
rights of criminals than the rights of
the law abiding majority they're soft on
crying they're soft on the causes of
crime conservatives are the party of Law
and Order Our track record all shows it
and the public no yeah
speaker thank you uh very much indeed as
the Home Secretary pointed out crime is
now at half the level it was that labor
left behind at the same time as they
told us there was no money uh left in
the coffers to continue the fight so can
I congratulate her on her bending her
elbow putting so much effort into
driving that number down even further
and Commander particularly on the
publication of this plan today which
Builds on the focus on anti-social
behavior that we published in the
beating crime plan not so very long ago
on nitrous oxide though I wonder if I
could just urge her
um to examine carefully the roots of
supply of this particular intoxicant
because one of the issues that we need
to avoid is that this substance moves
from the legitimate Market into the
illegitimate Market it becomes another
hook for drug dealers to draw young
people into their awful trade how can
she restrict Supply to those who
genuinely need it without it necessarily
becoming an illicit substance the drug
dealers use for their business
well let me put on record my admiration
and gratitude to my right honorable
friend for all he achieved and led not
just when he was uh in this department
but even before that when he worked for
City Hall uh really on the front line of
policing and crime fighting he talks
about our plans to ban nitrous oxide
we're very clear there needs to be an
exception for legitimate use
um it is used in a vast array of
circumstances which are lawful which are
commercial and which are for uh proper
purposes they will not be criminalized
speaker and while most of this statement
does not apply in Scotland because
thankfully uh justice is devolved and we
have a Scottish approach which takes a
public health approach to criminality
takes the violence reduction units
approach which has been emulated uh
which has been emulated by the UK
government treating uh
young people this week and criminalizing
young people this way will not help I
would gently suggest
Madam Deputy speaker of the anti-social
Behavior could start from the benches
opposite that would be quite helpful
thank you
[Applause]
the independent advisory Council on the
misuse of drugs recently concluded that
the evidence shows that the Health and
Social harms of social of nitrous oxide
were not commenced it with a ban so can
I ask the Home Secretary why is she or
has she overruled her advisors the
misuse of drugs that has failed
completely failed to prevent people from
taking heroin from cocaine and cannabis
so can Home Secretary tell us why she
believes it will stop people taking
nitrous oxide
Health secretary well the uh the overall
legislative framework on illicit drugs
continues to strike a balance between
controlling harmful substances and
enabling appropriate access to those
drugs for legitimate medicinal research
and in exceptional cases for industrial
purposes but with respect I'm not going
to take any lectures from someone from
the SMP who has overseen in Scotland a
total collapse in confidence when it
comes to policing and also more
devastatingly a record high in the
number of drug-related deaths in Europe
thank you madam Deputy speak and there's
a lot to welcome in this statement
particularly thinking of some of the
ways increased police resources have
been used such as what we're seeing in
Torquay Town Center with OP blocky being
launched also very much welcome the
reform of the Holy outdated vagrancy act
which was which is a useless tool
against organized gangs but does
actually in theory criminalize the most
destitute but could you outline how will
people see the difference that this plan
will make and how does she envisage a
local community such as Traders and
residents in places like Torquay or
painter Town Center have been able to
see the difference it's making and hold
the local Force to account for that
Home Secretary there are a wide range of
measures in this plan and we're going to
consult on many of them but one example
is where we want to potentially
streamline the availability of public
space protection orders pspos so the
police can access these in really
important orders more quickly more
efficiently and take action to prohibit
nuisance and anti-social behavior in
local areas
so Chris Bryan thank you madam speaker
at my local police
um tell me that in the Ronda which is a
very low crime area in general that the
single biggest issue that we face is
domestic violence and we have probably
higher figures in the Ronda than for
three other constituencies neighboring
added together
um so I
I hope she'll forgive me if if I'm not
very impressed by what she's announcing
today because I want to see the police
really focusing on what might save lives
could she look in particular about the
role that brain injury plays in poorer
communities there's lots of evidence to
suggest that nearly two-thirds of those
going into prison these days both women
and men are people who suffer brain
injuries significant brain injuries that
have not been diagnosed or treated
before they come into the criminal
justice system sometimes that leads to
them truanting falling out of
um school coming into the criminal
justice system isn't it important that
we base everything that we do on
evidence rather than sloganizing
Home Secretary well I think this is
highly evidence-led because we are
focusing heavily on restorative justice
prevention and diversion whether it's
through hotspot policing whether it's
through the investment in youth
facilities and the diversion of people
who uh who have got drug drug using
Behavior onto treatment facilities
that's about prevention rather than cure
Vicky Ford thank you I'd like to put on
the record my thanks to the Prime
Minister for taking time to speak with
constituents impacted by our social
behavior when it came to the Essex Boys
and Girls Clubs in Chelmsford this
morning the hot spot policing will make
a huge impact but can I also
particularly thank the Home Secretary
for the Youth guarantee to make sure
that every young person will have access
to clubs activities or other
opportunities thank you
Home Secretary well I was um I I very
much enjoyed meeting uh police from
Essex police today in chance with the
prime minister in her constituency she
has a lot of which to be proud uh
locally they are fantastic uh police
team there and she's absolutely right to
talk about the investment in uh youth
services and as part of our national
youth guarantee we're investing over 500
million pounds to provide high quality
local youth services so that by 2025
every young person will have access to
regular clubs activities and Adventures
away from home and opportunities to
volunteer
Aleister Carmichael
because the Prime Minister sees the
inconsistency between seeing in one
breath that there's no such thing as
petty crime and then in the next one
boasting that crime has fallen but only
if you exclude fraud from the figures
can I bring her attention though to the
question relating to homelessness it's
of course welcome we're going to be
directing vulnerable individuals towards
appropriate support such as
accommodation mental health or substance
misuse Services can she tell the house
however why it is that something as
basic as that is not already the case
and what does she think these vulnerable
people will find when they get to the
point of accessing these services
broad the data collection changed over
the last 10 years to only start counting
fraud and that's why we refer to the
falling crime in the way that we do
fraud is obviously a big feature of
modern day crime and that's why the
government led by the home office is
setting out and the security minister a
fraud strategy which we'll be announcing
very soon
Lee Anderson
I think it's I think it's laughable that
the labor party come to this change
today talking about being the party of
Law and Order an absolute Scandal but
the unsecure will be aware of a
deportation flight just stayed a couple
of years back going to Jamaica taking
some of the most vile criminals on board
back to their Homeland two two after
they campaigned to stop it two went on
to commit terrible crimes a murder and
attacking two women does the dump
Factory now think it's a good time for
the opposition front bench to apologize
to this house and apologize to the
country
[Music]
[Applause]
makes you quite important that members
ask about the statement and the home
secretary's responsibilities it's
obviously not responsible for the
obviously Home Secretary well my
honorable friend raises a very good
point because in his question highlights
the gross failure of the labor party
they're much more interested in writing
letter campaigns to stop the home office
from deporting serious foreign National
offenders they're much more interested
in the rights of criminals the rights of
criminals rather than the rights
entitlements of the law abiding majority
so yes I agree they really should be
apologizing for the devastating action
speaker any plan for dealing with
anti-social Behavior must include
support for victims of anti-social
behavior and while pccs like Kim
McGinnis and northumbria are working
hard to tackle anti-social Behavior they
are prevented from running dedicated
victim support programs as there is no
Government funding so when will the Home
Secretary provide this important funding
so that victims of antisocial Behavior
can have some help
Home Secretary well I'm very pleased to
say that northumbria is actually going
to be one of the pilot forces both for
Hot Spot patrolling and immediate
Justice and there will be specified
funding going to those 10 police forces
in each pilot rolled out across the uh
the year to ensure that the uh the
measures are there the resources are
there so that we can increase the
response to antisocial Behavior
Maggie through Deputy speaker and his
social behavior in our towns is a major
concern for many people living and
working in across area wash so I welcome
this new Zero Tolerance approach and
also the fact that Derbyshire will be a
Trailblazer area well my writable friend
assured me that not only will erwort
police and Borough Council receive their
fair share of the new funding but also
persistent offenders will now be swiftly
prosecuted using the full force of law
Home Secretary well my honorable friend
is absolutely right that Derbyshire is
also a pilot Force for both hot spot
patrolling and immediate Justice that
will mean when it comes to Hot Spot
policing which we know Works in many
parts of the country the police will be
expected to identify places and times
where antisocial behavior is prevalent
and they will be able to use this extra
funding to lay on additional policing
greater visibility and a more robust
response
Jeff Smith thank you madam Mr Speaker
all the experts
saying the planning nitrous oxide will
cause more harm than good now she just
said her policy is evidence-led and she
points the evidence that suggests her
policy on nitrous oxide is right
I'm very grateful to the acmd for their
very detailed report and for their
advice and their uh their their input is
an essential part of our decision making
and we have complete faith in their the
quality and the rigor of the work of the
acmd however the government is entitled
and expected to take a broader View and
we are entitled to take into account
other relevant factors particularly the
emerging evidence that it does cause
serious uh harm to health and well-being
Mark Garnier thank you um can I
congratulate my uh right on the wall
friend on our incredibly sensible
decision to ban the recreational use of
nitrous oxide
um but as we've already heard a little
bit earlier one of the reasons it has
been so prolific is because it is so
extraordinarily easy to be able to
purchase from uh from small little
canisters up to pallet loads of it
um can I urge my right honorable friend
to do everything she can to continue to
stifle the supply and to clamp down as
hard as you possibly can on those people
who continued to sell this this
dangerous product for recreational
purposes
Home Secretary well I want to thank my
honorable friend for the great campaign
that he has led
has reflected uh the decision that we
have made today to ban nitrous oxide he
has spoken very passionately about the
devastating impacts it's not just having
on individuals but also on communities
and he's absolutely right that we now
need to take this robust approach we
need to curb the supply but importantly
criminalize The Possession so that there
is a deterrent and there is actually a a
meaningful consequence to people who
will break the law by using nitrous
oxide
Jonathan Edwards
the website article supporting the
statement mentions that up to five
million will be made available for CCTV
and Equipment Restoration in vandalized
parks
is that the total budget five million
because the restoration of amforce
children Park in my constituency which
was originally vandalized and the
installation of CCTV will cost 140
000 pounds Alone
um will
um will uh County councils and Tony
Committee councilors in Wales be able to
access the scheme and if so how
secretary well we want to ensure that
there is sufficient and uh resource
available to local authorities and also
police forces so they can take
meaningful steps to sanction those
involved in anti-social behavior and
whether that is through uh the kind of
community payback scheme where we see
the perpetrators actually undertaking
the cleanup job afterwards whether it's
higher fines that we've announced we
want to enable local authorities to
retain much of the revenue so that they
can reinvest it into their resources
at Tom Hunt
thank you very much my invention speaker
yeah what I've heard consistently
throughout the time I've been a member
of parliament is long-term residents who
love their town so if I don't go into a
town center anymore because they don't
feel comfortable because often they see
are groups of young men behaving away
but it deteriorates the quality of
experience going to a town center for it
or by the majority does the Home
Secretary agree with me we need a
permanently higher police presence in
the town center but also they're pleased
to be much more confident to engage
earlier we beat
men groups of men who are blighting our
town center
yeah yeah
I'm a secretary my old friend is
absolutely right we are seeing far too
many instances of bad behavior dangerous
behavior unacceptable Behavior going
unchecked whether that's violent or
disruptive or or a plain nuisance we
need to ensure that visible policing is
becomes a fact of life so that people
are deterred from engaging in this
behavior in the first place but also
that we have a system of immediate
justice so there's a swift sanction and
people feel the full force of their of
the law
uh Rachel mascot thank you madam Deputy
speaker only after my right honorable
friend published her comprehensive
strategy around anti-social Behavior has
the Home Secretary been shamed into
cobbling together today's statement
however within that statement it doesn't
mention the word alcohol alcohol is at
the source of much domestic violence
Community violence and also City Center
anti-social Behavior so how is she going
to get on top of the growth in
alcohol-based violence
education
Home Secretary well I just have to
gently remind her that her party is
royally failed to properly cost their
so-called plan on anti-social Behavior
as evidenced by the shadow policing
Minister's failure to explain how it
would be paid for so once they get the
basics right then we can have a proper
conversation about what Labor's option
The Proposal is but in terms of taking
the action that we're proposing we have
uh we are delivering uh 12 million
pounds of additional funding this year
for to police and crime Commissioners to
support and increase police presence
presence alongside other uniformed
authority figures such as wardens in
problem areas for anti-social Behavior
raising the visibility increasing the
sourcing of policing will be a an
effective way to deter and take the
right action Tracy Crown
over the past year residents across
Chatham and elseford have suffered
repetitive instances of antisocial
Behavior involving noise nuisance from
cars and by rights and unauthorized
access to private Lakes by large groups
of children the local councils have had
to go through lengthy processes to
establish pspos to tackle these issues
which have left residents at their wit
end while the bureaucracy slowly cranks
away can the Home Secretary confirm that
the announcement today will make it a
lot simpler for the authorities to clamp
down on this type of antisocial Behavior
so that it can be dealt with there and
then rather than waiting for months for
consultations and paperwork to be
completed Home Secretary and I want to
thank my uh run on a friend for all of
the work that she and her local team and
councilors have led in challenging and
stopping antisocial Behavior locally but
she's absolutely right what we've
identified is it's become onerous it's
become inefficient it's become too time
consuming to secure these really
effective orders and this is exactly
what the consultation will do it will
aim to streamline and speed up the
acquisition of a pspo which can really
make the difference between an area
black by antisocial behavior and an area
which was free and safe and and pleasant
to frequent
Simon Knight thank you Mr Madam Deputy
speaker the government's own action plan
shows that the amount of anti-social
Behavior being reported to the police is
down yet people's experience of it has
soared people are not reporting
anti-social Behavior because of lost
faith that reporting crimes will lead to
any action let alone an arrest arrests
have halved since the conservatives took
office in 2010 and 10 000 fewer
neighborhood police officers and pcsos
than seven years ago does the Secretary
of State agree with me that the best way
to make our communities safer is to
follow Labor's plans to put an
additional 13
000 police officers and pcsos back on
our streets because after 13 years of
this conservative government the action
plan is all talk
and simply too little too late
well I admire The Honorable gentleman's
cheat because frankly he's absolutely
failed to support any measure that we've
put forward to increase police powers to
increase the sentences on offenders to
roll out at the greater funding for our
police forces to empower them to better
take action for our residents when he
had the chance he voted against every
single measure that we put forward he
really does need to up his game
Simon Hall Mr Speaker anti-social
Behavior affects all of our
constituencies and our constituents but
the Home Secretary will know
the Home Secretary will know that when
it comes to funding allocations very
often it's the urban areas that will
attract the largest proportion of funds
very often in rural areas the
anti-social Behavior will be more thinly
spread
and maybe of a different type but will
still cause huge nuisance to local
residents and communities can she assure
me working with her right humble friend
uh the Secretary of State dealing with
local government the proper rurification
of the rubric of funding is undertaken
to make sure that my constituents in
North Dorset and their concerns are
taken into account as somebody say for
example representing a large Urban
connovation
the disparity between forces and which
which leads to an adverse impact on
those forces which have a particular
rurality that they live with I'm very
glad that Dorset is one of our pilot
Force areas for the immediate Justice uh
scheme that we're putting forward that
will mean more resources for Dorset
police that will mean more resources on
the front line and of course we have a
increased number of police officers
throughout England Wales which will
increase the resource in the response to
antisocial Behavior
Christian wake thank you madam speaker I
thank the Home Secretary for her
statement and I think all colleagues
across the house will recognize the
importance of antisocial behavior and
how it needs to be tackled with stronger
and increased community policing however
I'd like to raise with her the issue
with support for junior and trainee
police officers
annu Abraham was a 21 year old student
police officer on a placement in West
Yorkshire who took his own life
following bullying allegations and a
lack of support
I met Andrew's family on Friday and they
wanted to make clear that they feel the
harm and lack of support a new
experienced at the hands of the police I
killed him
the family no one and who's deaf and the
miscommunication went forward to be
reviewed by the iopc
will the Home Secretary all the policing
Minister meet with myself and nanu's
family to hear their concerns and just
to discuss what can be done to prevent
any further tragedies
place on record my deepest condolences
and sympathies to the family of Anu
Abraham I cannot imagine what they must
be going through right now and I thank
the honorable gentleman for his advocacy
for them at this difficult time every
man woman who puts themselves forward to
serving our police force deserves
support and the credit for their bravery
and the high standards that they uphold
I'm very happy to arrange some kind of
appropriate meeting between an official
or minister at the home office and the
honored should that be the right thing
to do
Brendan Clark Smith
I'd like to commend this plan here today
particularly the part where uh the
people committing these acts will have
to clean up their mess within 48 hours
and my constituents in basketball will
be particularly pleased about this is
actually a better record than my labor
Council has in cleaning up graffiti
which can take to at least five working
days because with nitrous oxide this is
of course note laughing matter and does
the Home Secretary agree with me that
the problem is not just that it is a
gateway to other drugs but it also
causes a significant amount of
anti-social Behavior as well
my honorable my honorable friend is
absolutely right uh the youth uh the
supply and the possession of nitrous
oxide needs to be taken much more
seriously there's been a a practice and
a culture amongst young people
particularly 16 to 24 year olds of
acquiring uh this harmful product far
too easily the decision that I've made
to ban it will ensure that many more
young people are protected from the
devastating effects that it carries
very much welcome the Secretary of
State's step in the day and it's been
encouraging I think everyone in the
house would do so uh underage drinking
and drug use in is very prevalent in the
north now and doesn't seem to be getting
any better so can the city of State
ensure that discussions will be
undertaken with the Department of
Justice at the northern art assembly to
parallel policies alongside this plan
announced here today so at Northern
Ireland can match and meet the
legislation within the anti-social
action plan here today thank you
secretary well of course uh uh as Home
Secretary my responsibility only covers
England and Wales and the police forces
in that territory but of course I have
uh met with senior police officers in
Northern Ireland they do a great job and
within the the Realms of uh what's
appropriate I'm always happy to liaise
with them and support them in whatever
way I can
it's to Desmond Swain
will the plan end the opportunity to
complete community service
orders from by working from home
secretary well it's not my
plan that I envisage working from home
uh to be used as a way to remedy the
damage caused by anti-social Behavior
what I foresee is a building on the very
effective Community payback scheme that
we have rolled out throughout the
country that being people who have been
involved in graffiti or vandalism
criminal damage actually rolling their
sleeves up and paying making amends
making amends in real and direct ways to
the community that they've harmed and I
think the consequence linked to their
actions is about will send them a
powerful message and teach them a very
powerful lesson there's several Roberts
that is criminalization doesn't tackle
problem drug use it simply blights the
lives of young people with criminal
records
why not look in depth of the reasons why
people turn to drugs the Decades of cuts
to Youth Services the Deep poverty in
which many of our communities lapse and
the associated Mental Health crisis
isn't it time therefore that the
minister recognizes that problem drug
use is primarily a health issue and if
it is a health issue will she therefore
review the Devolution of responsibility
for drugs policy to Wales
[Music]
the secretary well I think dealing with
drugs requires a robust policing and law
enforcement response whereby we are
taking a tough line against illicit drug
use and a rehabilitative element that's
why I'm proud that this government has
created 55 000 new drug treatment places
and we're investing 580 million pounds
into drug treatment so there is a real
program of work based on Rehabilitation
and getting people off that devastating
cycle of drug dependency secondary
speaker the home section will be aware
that I've written to her about the
availability of nitrous oxide and I've
spoken the house about enforcement
around fly tipping so I commend her for
the tough action she's taking today but
I wanted to turn to what she said about
the labor police and crime commissioner
closing down police stations in the West
Midlands my constituents are very
concerned that he has no plan to keep a
police station open in the borough of
solihull and the front and no front desk
at chelmsley wood police station does
she agree with me that the labor police
and crime commissioner when it comes to
my constituents of Meriden and also the
people of West Midlands he is
shortchanging them yes
well I'm a right as I said where labor
where labor leads crime follows and I'm
afraid the West Midlands is no exception
the labor PCC is more interested in
closing police stations I can't even
command the support of his own labor
members than actually standing up for
the law abiding majority in the West
Midlands Nikki Aiken thank you madam
deaf speaker I welcome the government's
anti-social Behavior action plan today
and I know that the vast majority of my
constituents will join with me in
welcoming the policies aimed at tackling
the organized begging gangs and the
nuisance Beggars can my vulnerable
friend give me and my constituentive
assurances though that this is not about
bringing back the benziac through the
back door but that there is a a plan to
ensure that those in need who are
begging on the street will be provided
with the services that they need because
the vast majority are suffering from
Mental Health and addiction problems and
that we must remember that not all of
our sleepers are Beggars and that not
all Beggars are rough sleepers
and secretary she's uh my honorable
friend is absolutely right and I know uh
she has uh put in considerable effort uh
both in her role as a member of
parliament but also as a former leader
of Westminster city council in tackling
this issue on the front line and it does
require a nuance and thoughtful approach
we are repealing the vagrancy act but we
are also making clear that we will
prohibit organized and nuisance begging
and we are going to introduce new tools
to direct individuals to the vital
support
so that they can find accommodation they
can find support and there really isn't
there shouldn't be a reason why they
should be living in squalor in such
hardship in this day and age
Matt Warman
Deputy speaker I welcome the focus on
and social behavior from the Home
Secretary today it's long been a focus
of Lincolnshire police as well but as
the Home Secretary knows Lincolnshire
police finds itself in an anomalous
funding position it is the lowest funded
police force in the country it is
remarkable that Lincolnshire remains a
low crime County but they do need
greater support can she reassure me that
we will get to that funding position
that means Lincolnshire gets the uplift
that we've seen in other parts of the
country because that is what will allow
them to deliver on her anti-social
policy today
and secretary modern friend's absolutely
right to raise
the financing of police forces and and I
note and I'm aware of the challenges
that Lincolnshire police are facing in
this regard the policing Minister and I
are looking at the measures and the
proposals on the funding formula and
there'll be announcement very soon in
this regard
at Miriam Cates thank you madam Deputy
speaker and I warmly welcome the
anti-social Behavior action plan and I'm
delighted that South Yorkshire has been
chosen as one of the pilot Trailblazer
areas for Hotspot policing now in my
constituency we're very fortunate that
serious crime rates are low but
anti-social Behavior still blights the
lives of many of my constituents in
stocksbridge deep car High green
penicillin and goddess now there's a
clear link between anti-social behavior
and school absence and Sheffield and
Barnsley have some of the highest rates
of severe School absence of any local
Authority with over two and a half
thousand children mostly missing from
school across the two local authorities
so will my right honorable friends speak
to her colleagues in the department for
education and urge them to set out a
plan to reverse the rising tide of
school absence and all the negative
impacts it has not only on children but
on communities
and secretary my normal friend speaks
with a huge amount of experience from
her days as a a teacher and she knows
more than many of us about how with
vital uh resource in schooling uh
effective teaching and the proper
support in schools and from parents we
can divert children from a life of prime
anti-social behavior and Devastation to
themselves and their communities so yes
there's a very strong theme in this plan
about uh diversion res investment in
youth activities but also the turnaround
scheme so we are expanding the
eligibility criteria and we're working
with professionals to ensure that
children will be taken away from a a
life of prime James Wilde Madame Deputy
speaker when I have assisted
constituents whose lives are being made
a living hell by neighbors using drugs
or blasting out music for all hours it's
taken far too long to solve the problem
so I welcome the proposals my art and
befrienders set out to make it easier to
evict such people and when will those
changes take effect so that courts can
consider any behavior that creates
nuisance and will local authorities be
empowered and indeed required to act
where landlords are unwilling or absent
Home Secretary
well my honorable friend is right to and
uh to mention the uh powers of eviction
and we want to ensure that it's easier
for landlords to take action against
anti-social tenants whether that's in
the social rented sector or the
privately rented sector and our measures
are in in the plan will Empower them to
take that swifter action
James David
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
under the disastrous reign of police and
crime commissioner Andy Burnham greater
Manchester police were put into special
measures with the assistance of my
little friend from Northwest Hampshire
Stephen Watson was appointed as Chief
Constable under the Revolutionary
concept of charging criminals with
offenses
we saw a 42 increase in charge rate up
for the 12 months of September 2022 so
with my normal friend agree with me that
not only is this plan exactly the CR the
correct course to take but Chief
constables another senior police
officers must start arresting people as
this government wants yeah yeah
yeah
well I couldn't put it better but I will
it reiterate uh his sentiment because
Stephen Watson who I've met when I
visited greater Manchester police
recently is a is a real uh success story
uh his approach to policing uh that
being Common Sense policing getting the
basics right high standards getting his
uh men and women to just fight crime and
focus on the priorities that the people
have is a winning formula and Stephen is
a great leader in policing and we need
more leaders in policing just like him
Richard Drex thank you madam speaker
whatever you see when you're traveling
to our great cities and towns for mile
after mile is graffiti the message is
clear abandon hope all you went to hear
come around to my friend tell the house
that as I understand it the perpetrators
so-called graffiti artists will be
tracked down and made to clean up the
mess they make and be seen to do so
publicly
simply put yes that is the aim of uh the
community payback scheme which has been
very successful but also the measures
included in this plan whereby those who
are inflicting uh ugliness and uh chaos
and nuisance on communities need to make
amends themselves directly to the
communities which they've harmed Sarah
I'd like to thank the Home Secretary for
personally listening to the concerns and
ideas that we've had across Lancashire
and for supporting myself and our
fantastic pleasing crime commissioner
Andrew Snowden as we've tried to tackle
this can my right honorable friend
outline how quickly Lancashire will
receive the major two million pound
funding boost for Hot Spot patrols and
how she thinks this will make a
difference in hand done yeah yeah
well let me put on record my my my my
thanks uh to the my honorable friend but
also to Andrew Snowden the excellent PCC
up in Lancashire who has led uh some
great initiatives notably in anti-social
Behavior Uh they've had a lot of success
in uh clamping down on boy races and
other nuisance behavior in some of the
Town centers in the area Lancashire
police is going to be receiving uh
funding as one of the pilots for Hot
Spot policing and uh that will be money
which will be diverted to increasing uh
resources on the front line to improve
visible and responsive policing Smith
thank you madam Deputy speaker I warmly
welcome my right humble friends
statement which comes at a particularly
timely point for my constituents as the
first email I opened in my inbox this
morning reported vandalism to a brand
new twenty thousand pound fence around a
community Sports facility in wings low
and also over the weekend the crew Cafe
in princes risborough saw a break-in and
that Cafe sits in the epicenter of a hot
spot of anti-social Behavior over the
last year seeing intimidation broken
glass another vandalism so can my
writable friend assure me that the power
she's announced tonight give the superb
officers of Thames Valley everything
they need to combat these incidents that
furthermore has broken windows Theory
teaches us it will shut down higher
level crimes too
let me thank my honorable friend for
welcoming me to his constituency over
the weekend to meet uh Thames Valley
police and his excellent police and
crime commissioner Matthew Barber they
are leading brilliant work when it comes
to rural crime but he's absolutely right
I believe in the broken windows theory
of crime prevention it is absolutely
essential to take a zero tolerance
approach to the so-called lower level
crime and as I said there's no such
thing as petty crime it leads on to more
serious crime it leads on to more
criminal Behavior that's why this
antisocial Behavior plan is vital to
stamp it out at the earliest possible
opportunity
Deputy speaker the Home Secretary
already knows that anti-social behavior
and nitrous oxide abuse in particular
wreaked havoc along our beautiful city
front in south end and Leon sea last
summer so I warmly welcome these steps
to ban nitrous oxide and use hot stock
Hot Spot policing and I thank her for
meeting with me and listening to my
concerns and those of other colleagues
across this house South End police
welcome them they've got two quick
questions will the legislation be in
place to avoid Essie from being blighted
this summer and also will our wonderful
ice cream Sellers and ice cream parlors
be excluded as I'm sure they will be
from this ban thank you
let me thank my honorable friend for her
indefatigable campaigning to ban nitrous
oxide and to take a tough approach in
response to this uh devastating drug but
she's absolutely right I will there will
be uh exceptions uh to the prohibition
for legitimate and lawful and proper
uses we don't want to stop the
industrial use the commercial use the
medicinal use of any uh substances But
ultimately what my hope is is that the
site of these canisters on the ground
blighting our communities uh uh you know
making our places ugly must become a
thing of the past Jack brereton you
Madame deaf speakers Stoke-on-Trent has
seen significant issues with antisocial
behavior and drugs crime particularly
the horrific drug monkey dust and so I
very much welcome the announcement that
Staffordshire police is going to be one
of the hot spot areas the power out
hotspot areas so will my right home or
friend outline what this means in terms
of the front line of policing and
ensuring that we see more resources in
fighting crimes on the streets in
Stoke-on-Trent
well my honorable friend is absolutely
right that his police force is going to
be a pilot area for Hot Spot policing
these will start very soon we hope
before the summer and we want to ensure
that these are these areas have been
chosen because they're areas with the
greatest need when it came to tackling
antisocial Behavior we see them as a
priority and we want to ensure that
there is a proper response on the front
line as quickly as possible
Matt Bakers thank you
[Music]
thank you madam Deputy speaker on Friday
I held a crime surgery in thornaby and
heard horrific stories of the misery
crossed by youth crime and antisocial
Behavior so today I am delighted to see
Cleveland benefit from both additional
hotspot policing here and immediate
Justice come our honorable friend
outline what my residents across
Stockton South can expect to see from
this and importantly how quickly they
can expect to see it
yeah yeah
well my honorable friend is a doubty
champion for his residence and for
Public Safety up in Cleveland and I'm
very glad that Cleveland is a pilot both
for immediate Justice and for Hot Spot
policing so what they will be seeing up
there is more funding more funding for
more resource that resource will
hopefully be more police officers who
will be able to respond in a rapid way
to areas of acute challenge when it
comes to anti-social Behavior so we can
bring an end to what he calls the misery
of blighting our communities and
nuisance behavior and fundamentally
damage to the fabric of our way of life
well I thank the Home Secretary for her
statement
and we now move on
to Stephen King
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
on the 13th of December in response to a
question from my honorable friend the
member for the Wirral South regarding
the size of the current Asylum backlog
the Prime Minister stood at that
dispatch box and claimed wrongly that
the backlog is half the size that it was
when labor was in office six days later
the immigration minister went even
further from the same dispatch box
claiming that the backlog of cases was
450 000 when the last Labor government
handed over to us other members opposite
have repeated these claims I suspected
that these claims were Highly
Questionable so on the 19th of December
I wrote to the UK statistics Authority
requesting clarification
and Madam Deputy speaker I'm pleased to
inform the house that the chief
executive of the statistics Authority
responded to my request on Thursday and
his letter to me is crystal clear the
Asylum backlog when labor left office in
2010 was not in the hundreds of
thousands it was 18
954. now under the conservatives it is
now
261 more than eight times larger than it
was in 2010
Madame Deputy speaker the UK statistics
Authority is using the home office's own
statistics so it is somewhat odd that
the ministers didn't know they'd been
playing fast and loose with the facts I
would therefore be grateful for your
advice Madam Deputy speaker on how you
feel that ministers should go about
apologizing to our constituents and to
correct the record at the earliest
possible opportunity in compliance with
their obligations under paragraph 1.3 C
of the ministerial code thank you
anyway
well I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
giving me a notice of his intention to
raise this point of order he is aware
that the contents of ministers
contributions in the house is not a
matter for the chair he's also quite
right to say that the ministerial code
requires ministers to correct any
inadvertent errors in answers to
parliamentary questions at the earliest
opportunity
um as it happens
um he does have
ministers here from the home office who
I'm sure will have heard Excuse excuse
me
okay who will have heard what he has it
to say and I'm sure if they feel there
is anything that needs correcting they
would do that at the earliest
opportunity
um in addition if the honorable
gentleman feels that the the if there
are any further issues that he wishes to
raise I'm sure the table office will
advise him on how he can pursue this
matter further and I think we will leave
it at that thank you thank you
further to that point of order uh Yvette
Cooper Point of order Madam Deputy
speaker given that two of the relevant
ministers were actually sitting in the
chamber at the time has she ever heard
of a situation where it's abundantly
clear with the evidence from the UK
statistics Authority that the ministers
have given incorrect information to
Parliament and they have chosen not to
correct it straight away
uh well I thank the right honorable lady
um for that point of order there is no
obligation on ministers who are in the
chamber to respond they may need they
may wish to could we have a bit of quiet
please
um
they may they may wish to look at what
has been said and come back but that is
up to them as I've said
um it's clear what's in the ministerial
code
um and I am sure as I say that the
points have been heard and I suggest
that we now move on
thank you
presentation of Bill Paul Maynard
yeah
inquests legal representation bill
feeding what day Friday
the 20 the 24th of November
thank you
the clerk will now proceed to read the
orders of the day
illegal migration Bill committee
now
we now have to move to Committee of the
whole house
order order
okay
order
illegal migration Bill committee day one
we will begin with Amendment 133 to
Clause 37 with which it will be
convenient to consider the Amendments
Clauses and new Clauses as listed on the
selection paper I call Sir William cash
to move Amendment
133. thank you very much on the email
and Deputy speaker I voted for this bill
mender to speak on second reading
because it was most emphatically going
in the right direction but emphasized
that we wanted to be sure that it would
actually work in the National interest
by preventing illegal immigration
the bill is getting better with the
Amendments proposed by the government
today
all credit for the Home Secretary the
minister of state and the Prime Minister
the number of backbenchers who are
supporting my own and our constructive
amendments is growing
this bill to stop the boats is both
legally and politically necessary
because illegal migration is out of
control
some parts of which is because there is
a failure to distinguish machine genuine
refugees and others who are illegal in
economic migrants
this is not only a real problem in the
UK but also increasingly a real Global
and European problem as well as can be
seen by the Dreadful tragedies in the
Mediterranean in the last week weeks and
months
this legislation sets out a fair regime
for dealing with people that arrive here
illegally it gives them a reasonable but
limited ability to raise in exceptional
reasons as to why it is unsafe for them
to be center around or another safe
country
these are known as suspensive claims
that clearly defined in section 37
Clause 37
those claims ensure that we are
compliant with our national obligations
so that we would not send somebody
overseas if they're not medically fit to
fly or will face persecution in the
destination country
the success of this scheme depends on it
working predictably and quickly those
who come over on small boots need to
know that they will not be able to stay
here the vast majority of them will be
removed to Rwanda or elsewhere if courts
intervene in unexpected ways this
removes the deterrence and the whole
scheme breaks down along with our
ability to control our own borders
however it is also a procedural legal
and judicial issue because under the
Human Rights Act the UK courts have not
been given suitable guidance by
Parliament by Statute to draw the
appropriate bound Vision which are
needed in the National interest
as I pointed out on second reading for
example the international Refugee
convention itself does not apply between
the UK and France because France is not
a country where Asylum Seekers fear
persecution and yet a European
commission by all accounts is refusing
to make legal changes to EU law and
allow returns of illegal Asylum Seekers
from the UK to France
there are also Provisions which set out
other name save countries and I ought to
remind the house of what happened when
the Dublin regulation was torn up by
Angela Merkel and the 600
000 or so refugees were allowed to pour
into Europe at the time
when the Human Rights Act was passed in
1998 I was po I was in the House of
Commons and human rights lawyers and
activists claimed that the Act was a
constitutional Rubicon
enabling the courts to override
parliamentary sovereignty
this was a massively overstated and
exaggerated claim which is refuted by
the clear statements for which I hope
the labor front bench will take on board
that were made by the Lord Chancellor
Lord Irvin of leg in the House of Lords
on second reading on the 3rd of November
1997 where he said the bill maximizes
the protection of Human Rights without
trespassing on parliamentary sovereignty
and then he stated remedial action were
not retrospectively make unlawful in
that which was lawful lawful since
sanctioned by Statute the question
remained what does statute provide I'll
give way I agree with my honorable
friend the in fact that was demonstrated
when we had the case of prisoner votes
where Jack straw who took through the
new Rights Act supported my motion in
order to give instruction to the
government to get by exactly that issue
I talked to a friend more and as a
matter of fact in the in that context
the words takes into account is what the
courts have to do with respect to the
convention but not necessarily to obey
the court and that is precisely what
happened there
in the house of Collins at the same time
the Home Secretary Jack straw made
similar observations the government
rejected giving the courts the power to
set aside an act of parliament which
they had which was being considered
and this was the labor government
rejected giving the courts apart to set
aside in Acts of Parliament and as he
himself stated quote because of the
importance the government attaches to
parliamentary sovereignty
and the white paper at the time made
that abundantly clear even in respect to
Declarations of incompatibility by the
courts and furthermore that Declarations
of income incompatibility would not
necessarily lead to legislation
I was glad to hear it in principle
Clause 1 5 regarding the application of
Section 3 of this Human Rights Act uh
itself in the context of parliamentary
sovereignty it is clear from the
pre-evidence authorities that in respect
of Section 3 of the human rights act any
suggestion of a limitation of
parliament's sovereign will with only
being permissible to the extent that in
doing so the courts give effect to the
intention quote reasonably to be
attributed to Parliament in enacting
section three of the act itself
it must surely be clear to all of us in
the case of illegal immigration that
Palmer would not intend or ever would
intend to condone illegality or
criminality
this analysis which I put forward as to
interpretation of Human Rights Act is
clearly something which requires further
discussion with the government and
furthermore the preeminence Authority
also states that quote the courts are
thus not empowered to construe
legislation
compatibly with the convention at all
costs and must not cross and must not
cross the Constitutional boundaries
which which would include not endorsing
illegality
okay yes I'm very grateful to him for
giving ways expounding of course a very
anglicentric view of sovereignty but
I'll leave that to one side for the
moment
um isn't there a bit of a flaw in his
argument
in this is the following floor the legal
flaw uh some of the people at least who
come in small boats come to this country
seeking Asylum they don't come as
immigrants they come seeking Asylum and
the United Nation the unhcr has said
that this bill would Mount to a ban on
Asylum because it would just extinguish
the right to seek Refugee production in
the United Kingdom for those who arrive
irregularly no matter how compelling
their claim may be does he not accept
that
as I've just said believe it is very
important properly to protect genuine
refugees the problem that we've been
presented with over the last couple of
years or so is it is bliss at the
obvious that quite a significant number
I can't put a precise figure on it but
it is very substantial and runs into
tens of thousands actually have a
serious case to answer in respect of
their status
yeah
unfortunately for The Honorable
gentleman the facts simply don't support
what he's saying because the majority of
people who arrive who've arrived in
small boats who've had their Asylum
claims dealt with have had them granted
because that's the evidence
in cases that is certainly the case it's
equally the case that we have 160 000
unresolved Asylum cases and it's also
true that what France itself is a place
where there is no persecution on this
account so as the governments have
rightly say attention labor party voted
against the nationality and borders act
recently in the last couple of years
they want to scrap them around the deal
and oppose the government's will to
detain them and remove people swiftly
from the UK this amounts to
demonstrating the labor party are in
favor of open borders
[Applause]
and not on the side of the British
people who want us to deal with this
problem
the leader of the opposition in an
article in what's called Council on the
9th of January 2015
contrary to what was said by the former
Lord Chancellor and Home Secretary says
that the sovereignty of parliament has
nothing to do with the human rights act
at all he clearly doesn't understand
what the sovereignty of parliament is or
the enactments in case law involved
quite clearly the statutes itself was
not intended to lead to circumstances
where illegal migration is not merely
prevented but even one might say gently
almost encourage and to the profound
detriment of practical control over our
borders
I put down an amendment in December 2021
on the what was then the nationality of
water's bill with a clearly expressed
notwithstanding formula which was
strongly supported by our back Ventures
during the passage of that bill which
would have greatly helped to ensure
flights to Miranda
now in this new build we have a further
opportunity to tackle the problem of
illegal migration
this bill is necessary because of the
smuggling and criminality by
unscrupulous gangs exploiting the
migrants and causing death
in addition because of the consequences
of failing to control illegal migration
we have been enduring Monumental
expenditure of up to six million pounds
a day disruption to our local Services
hotels Health Services social housing
and instances of criminality
it is no good it does no good to
perpetuate this situation with such with
such adverse consequences for our
constituents and our voters the
government understands that indeed I am
confident that living acted and with the
bill improved the courts will apply the
legislation and the court procedures
will be adapted to calling me provided
the intention of the words used in the
bill as enacted are clear Express and
unambiguous as I propose
it is not appropriate for the current
situation to continue to the point where
as I have indicated in the past the
number of illegal migrants is growing
exponentially
my amendments I believe and in further
discussion with the government are
conducive to resolving these issues
properly fairly and reasonably with an
appeal system and other measures As I
Shall mention in a minute and in line
with domestic and international law and
to remove the unintended and unexpected
legal consequences of the Human Rights
Acts and the Court's rules reaching our
borders in respective in the illegal
migration with small boats which
together have led to the breaching of
our borders on an unprecedented scale
this is emphasically not in our national
interests and was not anticipated when
the Human Rights Act was originally
passed the point of my amendment is to
make sure that what Parliament intends
actually happens the illegal migration
rule is designed to be both fair and
efficient those who believe that there's
some special fundamental reason why they
should not be sent to Rwanda or another
safe country and put their case before a
judge but that should be a comprehensive
legislative scheme that sets up and this
is Route permitted roots of challenge
these permitted routes have challenged
the suspensive claims are carefully
calibrated and fair they include ample
provision for late claims new evidence
and compelling circumstances and other
judicial review claims are still allowed
in Norway it is just that they cannot
prevent removals that is the right
balance between fairness on the one hand
and the turrets on the other
we do not want or need lawyers and
judges to invent new blocks on removal
with judicial activism the statutory
block on interim relief will prevent
them from doing so it will prevent the
situation we saw last year when courts
unexpectedly issued injunctions
preventing the flight to Rwanda and when
cases are referred back to the Home
Secretary for review
multiple cases have made it clear that
the power to Grant injunctions can
properly be restricted by Statute
we are not in the business of shutting
down access to the courts all we want is
the regime of access to the courts as
provided in this bill to be properly and
securely bounded
the government has already made this
clear in their legislative scheme we
just want to make sure that the decision
is secure and effective in legal terms
the Human Rights Act was not intended as
I've said to protect illegality and in
the specific context of the small boots
problem the bill if amended for the
following discussions with the
government can be improved to achieve
its ultimate objectives in that National
interest
is important also to know that there is
explicit case law from the most
preeminent jurists although there are
many reasons why Parliament would take
into account our obligations in
international law when it legislates the
courts are not empowered to hold an act
of parliament Voyage on the grounds that
it contravenes general principles of
international law
as is made clear in the case of
Mortensen versus Peters Norway the cause
of an act invalid because it conflicts
with the treaty to which the UK is a
party as set out in the case of Cheney
vs Khan
that is what makes it so vital to use
express clearing on an ambiguous wording
in an act of parliament as intended by
the Amendments and by reference back to
what I said earlier on the question of
the construction of an interpretation of
provisions
these words notwithstanding were also
included in the withdrawal agreement act
2020 to guarantee the sovereignty of the
United Kingdom
I would also refer to the magisterial
words
of a great Lord Bingham chapter 12 of
the rule of law that's a nice approaches
the principle of parliamentary
sovereignty has been recognized as
fundamental in this country not because
judges invented it but because it has
for centuries being accepted by such
judges and others officially concerned
in the operation of our constitutional
system
the judges did not by themselves
establish the principle and cannot buy
themselves change it he created
and endorsed
the celebrated Australian constitutional
Authority Jeffrey girls worthy who is
preeminent in this field in his book The
sovereignty of parliament chapter 10. we
must stop people making these hazardous
and lethal Journeys in small boats we
must stop the criminality we must stop
illegal migration and the cost of this
and the impact on our local and national
resources
with my own amendments today along with
those my old friend the member for
devises and the Middlesbrough South in
East Cleveland and others tomorrow such
as my hormone friendly member of silicon
Trent North and and my right honorable
member the member for South Holland
deepings I believe the bill can achieve
that objective with Goodwill
these amendments are also supported more
broadly including by experts such as
Professor Richard eakins and formerly
first parliamentary Council sir Stephen
laws in their policy exchange report
we have also the government to engage
with us constructively on these
amendments and give us firm assurances
today on the floor of the house to
improve the bill in the light of our
amendments and on that on the basis that
they do give such assurances which I
understand they will I will not press my
amendment to a vote
the question is that Amendment
133 be made
colleagues will know that I can't put um
time limits on during committee stage so
I hope that um honorable and right
honorable members will bear that in mind
and I I will prioritize those members
who have got amendments on the order
paper Shadow Minister Stephen killock
very very much Madame Deputy speaker and
I'd like to start by reiterating the
point that I made in closing the second
reading debate which is that we on these
benches are absolutely clear that we
must bring the dangerous Channel
Crossings to an end and that we must
destroy the criminal activity of the
people Smugglers indeed labor has a
five-point plan to do just that a plan
that is based on common sense hard graft
and quiet diplomacy as opposed to the
headline chasing gimmicks that are the
stocking trade of the benches opposite
so our opposition to the legislation
that's before the house today and the
introduction of some of the Amendments
I'm about to speak on is all based on
the fact that it will serve only to make
it harder for the government to achieve
its own stated aims because the central
premise of this bill is that it will act
as a deterrent by Banning the right to
Asylum and replacing it with blanket
detention and removals policies but in
order for a deterrent to be effective it
has to be credible and this bill fails
The credibility test because there is
nowhere near enough capacity to detain
Asylum seekers in the UK there is no
returns agreement with the EU and the
Rwanda agreed and the Rwanda government
Rwandan government sorry is only
agreeing to commit to take thousands at
some unspecified future date so the
boats will keep on coming the backlog
will keep on growing and the hotels will
keep on filling
all of which leaves the house in the
somewhat surreal position of debating a
bill that everyone knows is not really
worth the paper it's written on and yet
we must all go through the motions and
pretend we're participating in a
meaningful process
nevertheless I can ensure you and the
entire house Madam Deputy speaker that
we on these benches will do all that we
can to amend and improve this bill in a
concerted effort to limit the damage
that it will inflict on the
international reputation of our country
on the cohesion of our communities and
on the health and well-being of those
who have come to our country in the hope
of sanctuary from the violence and
persecution that they are fleeing
is what he's just said implied that they
are not going to oppose this bill any
further on these matters because they
want to improve and enact it but no more
it's not working I think I was crystal
clear thanks I thank him for his
intervention I think I was crystal clear
though we opposed this bill because it
is a bill that will be entirely
counterproductive it's only going to
make all of the challenges that we Face
worse we on these benches believe in
supporting legislation that is actually
addressing the substance of an issue
rather than chasing tabloid headlines
Madam Deputy speaker the competition for
the most absurd aspect of this entire
process is pretty stiff but I have to
say that the program motion is a strong
Contender because ministers in their
Infinite Wisdom decided that we should
debate the second half of the bill on
the first day and the first half on the
second day whatever the rationale for
that I suppose there is actually
something strangely appropriate about
the idea that we should consider this
bill back to front given that so many of
its Provisions put the cart before the
horse
the other point that I wanted to make at
the outset is that the refusal of the
home office to publish a full set of
impact assessments ahead of second
reading and they still haven't been
published Madame Deputy speaker is
completely unacceptable surely as a
matter of basic respect for this house
and for our constituents members should
be entitled to expect to be given the
opportunity to have an informed debate
based on comprehensive assessments of
the impact of the government that the
government expects its proposals to have
Madam Deputy speaker the fact is the
government's entire handling of this
shambles of a bill has been utterly
chaotic while the statements of
ministers have generally been incoherent
inconsistent or simply incomprehensible
I spoke earlier in my point of order
about the government Conjuring up
statistics to suit their needs which
have now been rubbished by the
statistics Watchdog but we are where we
are and on that basis I will move on to
consider some of these substantive
issues that we are here to consider
Madam Deputy speaker it's with regret
that given the time available I will
have to limit my remarks to our own
front bench Amendment tabled on behalf
of the opposition
I begin with our new Clause 25 which
sets out how some how some Inlet sorry
how labor would approach these matters
if we were in government in order to
deliver meaningful progress on a range
of issues from border security to
authorize safe fruits as part of a
comprehensive strategy to stop the
crossings and keep people safe in line
with our International commitments in
particular new Clause 25 calls for a
multifaceted overarching strategy for
securing the agreement with
International Partners which our country
urgently needs a strategy for
it's an agreements with International
partners and we're signing more all the
time new deal with the French news of
the albanians we've had 480
um uh Asylum places here granted since
2000 as in 2015. how many hundreds of
thousands of more people would he want
coming to the country
thank him for his intervention it may
have escaped his notice that when the
botched brexit negotiations took place
we left the Dublin convention the Dublin
convention is crucial for returns so we
have to find a deal that replaces that
and that is actually about protecting
our borders because it's about returning
uh people when their Asylum claims are
not successful
now a strategy for securing Britain's
borders must begin with a clear and
honest recognition that we cannot solve
these problems unilaterally this is a
collective International issue that
requires a collective International
solution so closer cooperation with our
nearest friends and neighbors has to be
our starting point and our number one
priority that means urgent action I will
in a second that means urgent action
which will be taken forward from day one
of a labor government to negotiate a
returns agreement with the EU to replace
our previous participation in the Dublin
system but that's just the start we also
need to restore access for our law
enforcement agencies to the Treasure
Trove of information from Biometrics to
travel history that Euro DAC and other
databases provide in support of efforts
to ensure that the removal of Asylum
Seekers from the UK to safe for you
countries is actually possible I will
give one giving way I'm
just they participated cap in terms of
the numbers coming through those routes
and if so how would it prioritize
refugees bearing around there is
hundreds of millions of people across
the world who would like to move here
and could conceivably get Refugee status
I I thank him for his intervention yes
we do support a capped scheme for safe
and legal Roots
um uh it has to be based on
prioritization according to for example
High Grant rate countries and to uh
family reunion so uh The Honorable
gentleman's intervention is is all very
well but the reality is uh the uh bench
is opposite have completely burned every
relationship with our partners and
allies across InterContinental Europe
and as a result of that we have left the
Dublin convention and there's a direct
connection between the massive surge in
numbers coming on small boats and the
government's botched brexit negotiations
now it also means establishing formal
working arrangements to put the UK at
the heart of international efforts to
crack down on our real enemies here the
people Smugglers by relentlessly I will
in a second by relentlessly hunting them
down and ensuring that they are brought
to Justice the labor party has set out a
more targeted approach than the
government is currently undertaking by
recruiting a cross-bit border specialist
unit in the National Crime agency to go
after the criminal gangs Upstream
working with French experts and europol
and finally it means working closely
with our European friends and allies to
develop new safe and authorized routes
from EU countries to the UK for those
who are most in need of our help
I think the honorable gentle has a given
way he's talked about safe and legal
roots and making more available and
suggested that he would be supportive of
a cap but what level would he support
such a cap and what would he do to
manage those people who continue to
arrive once that cap was exceeded well I
don't know how many negotiations The
Honorable lady has been in but you
generally don't go into a negotiation by
putting all of your cards face up on the
table so it is absolutely clear that an
A Deal has to be done with the European
Union you don't do that deal from this
dispatch box you do that deal with hard
graft common sense and quiet diplomacy
none of which I'm afraid the bench is
opposite are capable of and that's why
they need to get out of the way so that
a labor government can actually fix this
problem
as drafted Clause 51 itself stands as
evidence that vague promises for
ministers are not to be taken seriously
on Clause 51. I find it particularly
telling that in drafting this Clause the
government wasn't even able to come up
with a definition of what a safe and
legal route is or how it should work
neither do they appear to have any idea
who such routes should apply to when
these measures might be introduced how
many people would be included or
Exempted from the cap and who other than
local authorities the government may
choose to consult with in a moment the
the opposition's Amendments seek to
address these challenges at second
reading Madame Deputy speaker I said
that under this government ministers had
done little more than pay lip service to
the principle of authorized safe routes
for refugees and others in protection I
stand by that assessment
and I will explain why in a moment but
I'll give way
does the shadow Minister agree when it
comes to obligations and honoring our
statement that we have made I think we
have an obligation to those from
Afghanistan who served alongside the
British soldiers and who are in the
system and are yet to be processed is it
the shuttle Minister's intention in his
information he puts forward today that
he will ensure that those people who you
have come from Afghanistan who are stuck
in Pakistan stuck in Syria will get in
here as Asylum Seekers as very much as
what they are
I Thank The Honorable member for his
intervention he's absolutely right that
the performance on The Afghan citizens
resettlement scheme has been abject
22 Afghans under acrs under pathway two
have come over in the last year they're
being told that they can only come once
they've got accommodation they've been
treated with a total lack of dis of
respect when these are people that we
owe a debt of honor and gratitude to so
The Honorable gentleman is absolutely
right on that pointed by gangs I'm very
grateful
um to my honorable friend will he agree
with me that the um the motion the
opposition uh amendment that he refers
to gives the lie to the argument put
forward by the Prime Minister the Home
Secretary and more recently The
Honorable member for stone
that on these benches we support open
borders in all circumstances yeah
it's one of the many myths that they
Peddle and my original friend is
absolutely right these are myths that
need to be debunked it is absolutely
clear that the Small Boat Crossings have
to be stopped but the key point is that
this bill will not achieve that
objective and our new Clause 25 seeks to
actually put some flesh on the bones of
something that might work rather than
chasing headlines and government by
gimmick I will get one well I'm grateful
to uh the Andre I'm giving away and he
really has to give up on this ridiculous
argument that this government has not
taken safe and legal route seriously as
my honorable friend said since 2015
almost half a million humanitarian visas
have been issued and in Europe we are
second only to
settlement
only to Canada the United States and
others for unhcr sponsored humanitarian
schemes and 45
000 people have come across on family
reunion visas we need no lectures on
playing our part as a generous and
compassionate country no idea well of
course um the Ukraine scheme the b o
scheme uh the Afghan scheme when it used
to work are very welcome there's no
there's no debate about that but I don't
know why the honorable gentleman keeps
making this point that is not the point
of this debate today the point of this
debate today is how to address the
challenge that we currently face and as
many honorable members have pointed out
there are many people fleeing war and
persecution in the world for whom this
government has utterly failed to offer
those safe and legal routes as a result
they are coming on unauthorized routes
it is a simple fact of life and the
other point of course is we are looking
at a government that has allowed the
backlog to get completely out of control
so the idea that they're making life
better and easier for people fleeing
warm persecution in our country is for
the birds I will I will make a bit more
progress now thank you
um I will explain but I first also
wanted to mention some areas where
members on both sides of this house are
broadly in agreement not least because
that's quite a short list Madam Deputy
speaker the opposition supports the
principle of parliament having a say
each year on the quota or cap for safe
and legal routes as envisaged by Clause
51. every country has a responsibility
to do it to do its bit to help those
fleeing persecution and conflict
alongside other countries however we
also believe that the government's
policy on safe routes cannot begin and
end with caps alone this bill presents
us with a rare opportunity to have a
serious debate about how best to live up
to our International commitment to offer
protection to those most in need
especially those fleeing persecution and
War the fact that there are so many
detailed well thought through proposals
put forward by honorable members in
amendments and new Clauses speaks to the
depth of cross-party support for making
safe routes work and providing genuine
alternatives to dangerous Crossings
I'll give away I Thank The Honorable
gentleman for giving way he is
absolutely scathing about the context of
this bill but he will be aware as I am
that as recently as last summer the Tony
Blair Institute was writing about a
solution for the small boat crisis that
involved annual quotas new safe and
legal routes an absolute prohibition on
any arrival via small boat and only out
of country rights of appeal that's
exactly identical to what appears
effectively in this bill and it was
written by somebody called Harvey
Redgrave who I think I can quote because
he cites himself as the labor party's
home Affairs policy advisor from 2011 to
2015.
well as I've just said I don't know if
the honorable lady was listening but we
support Clause 51 we support the idea of
safe and legal routes that are capped
but what she needs to understand is that
when you're looking at people who are
escaping war and conflict
um the idea that being detained in a
deterrent Center that doesn't exist or
being removed to other countries when
there are no removal agreements in place
that is not a deterrent for a deterrent
to be effective it has to be credible
this bill has zero credibility because
it's impossible to operationalize and
that's the key point that she seems to
fail to understand now we've seen I'm
going to make some progress I'm going to
make some progress now we've seen a
range of proposals put forward including
by my honorable friend the member for
Sheffield Hallam who has a record of
huge commitment to addressing these
matters the member for orkney and
Shetland and the member for East
Worthing and Shoreham who have also a
long history of working diligently on
these issues the number of new Clauses
including my own including one of my own
which seek to build upon and expand
access to family reunion visas for
refugees clearly reflects the high level
of support for such schemes among
members on all sides of the house in
moving new Clause 24 on behalf of the
opposition I want to make it clear that
providing better safe routes for
unaccompanied children with family in
the UK isn't just do the right thing to
do from the moral point of view it will
also demonstrate to our European
neighbors who support on issues from
returns to tackling people smuggling is
so fundamentally important to this
country that we are serious about making
progress with negotiations on the range
of issues that I outlined in new cloth
25.
concerned but so far the legislation
contains no children's rights impact
assessment and we are desperately
concerned about the plight of children
makes sense absolutely valid point about
the lack of an impact assessment for
children but there's a broader Point
here about the lack of an impact
assessment full stop it is completely
and utterly unacceptable that we in this
house are debating a bill now which has
had no impact assessment published in
advance and I think it shows a sort of
disrespect to the house which really
does need to be put on the record
Matt I'll just make a little bit more
progress thank you madam Deputy speaker
because I'm having to limit my time to
discuss our front bench his own
Amendment I'll therefore not be able to
raise the many questions and concerns
that I have in relation to some of the
provisions on legal proceedings in
Clauses 137 to 49. some of which do
clearly appear to pose a real threat to
due process and to our respect and for a
country that upholds the rule of law the
entire bill is shot through with
inconsistencies unresolved questions and
bizarre contortions of logic which can
only have the effect of worsening the
very problems the government says it is
trying to solve just one example of this
is raised by Amendment 41 which I tabled
as a means of probing the government's
thinking on a measure which simply does
not appear to have been properly thought
through Clause 45 states that wear an
appeal against a removal notice is
upheld the duty to remove that person no
longer applies so far so sensible the
problem is that nothing in the bill says
that any Asylum claim made by a person
in such a situation would then be
considered those claims would continue
to be inadmissible what this means is
we'll end up with situations where there
are people who cannot be removed because
the court has ruled that to do so would
pose unacceptable risks to their safety
but who cannot also lawfully remain in
the UK because of the government's
refusal to accept their claim for Asylum
the law would effectively be saying that
a person can neither leave nor remain in
this country if the minister has a an
answer to the question of what then
happens to a person in this situation I
would love to hear it
I I'm grateful to my own more friend and
for the points that he's making today I
wanted to return to the point around
detaining children however because under
this government we know that hundreds of
children have gone missing and some of
them in fact hundreds we still don't
know where they are and isn't it right
that children that come to this country
are placed immediately under the care of
local authorities who can then put
proper safeguarding in place to protect
those most vulnerable people
my honorable friend is is absolutely
right and she she points to a broader
failing or and a clear indication of the
the shambles and Chaos that we have
within the broader Asylum sister the bat
system the backlog is out of control
massive safeguarding issues uh and
really it's just uh more grits to the
mill for the people Smugglers and the
traffickers and that's why this has to
be addressed so to sum up Madame Deputy
speaker this is a dog's breakfast of a
bill and this debate feels like
something of a charade because everyone
knows that it's not only unworkable it's
not even intended to work nevertheless
we do hope that colleagues across the
house will support our amendments and
new Clauses in the division Lobby this
evening because let's be clear Madam
Deputy speaker ministers know full well
that this bill is an entirely
counterproductive piece of legislation
but they don't really care in fact
they'll be more than happy to see it
failing because then they can blame our
civil servants or the EU or the lawyers
or the judges or the labor party or the
football pundit or whoever they can
think of and why are they doing this
well the answer is staring Us in the
face it's because they know that come
the general election they can't stand on
their record of 13 years of failure so
instead they'll whip up division Stoke
anxiety and fire up the culture wars our
constituents know where the buck stops
though they want Solutions not sound
bites they want the labor party's common
sense and hard graft and quiet diplomacy
not government by gimmick and when this
bill fails they'll know that only a
labor government's five-point plan for
Asylum will stop the dangerous Crossings
fix our broken Asylum system and get our
trunk country back on track after 13
years of Tory failure
[Applause]
forgive me I should have um reminded
members at the beginning of the debate
that when we're in committee
um it's customary to either call me by
name or Madam chair rather than Deputy
speaker it's a very common mistake don't
worry I should have um reminded members
at the beginning of the debate uh
Lawton thank you very much Dame Rosie
and I'm uh
I stand to propose
six amendments in my name and those of
uh honorable and right honorable
colleagues those are new Clause 13 and
new Clause 19 and Amendment 72 73 74 and
75 and I'm glad to hear the minister
refer to his support for safe and legal
routes because that is the basis of
these uh amendments and I look forward
to some more words from him later on but
this is a very heated subject this is a
very controversial uh bill so can I
start perhaps with what I hope we can
all agree on
coming across the channel in small boats
is the worst possible way to gain entry
to the United Kingdom
we need to be ruthless against the
people
um Smugglers who benefit from this
miserable trade
we want to continue to offer safe haven
for those genuinely escaping danger and
persecution and in a sustainable way and
that's why safe and legal Roots is the
obvious antidote to that problem
and the migration system as it stands is
broken and that whatever we think about
this bill it is only one part of the
solution that we need to bring forward
and the home office needs to beef up the
processing times the removals of those
who don't have a legitimate claim and we
need more return agreements and an
overnight solution as we know would be
for the French to stop the boats leaving
the shores of France in the first place
or intercepting them at Sea and
returning the passengers back to France
so the passengers would have spent three
or four thousand pounds on an expensive
return trip paying people Smugglers to
do that the problem is the French won't
agree to do that despite the latest
encouraging and helpful uh settlement
with them involving a considerable
amount of money so anybody who just says
what we need is to have a more
constructive dialogue with the French
and European partners that is what is
happening and has been going on and we
still do not have a resolution to this
problem so we have got to come up with
practical Solutions I will give way I
thank you for giving away and just uh
talking about the French
um does he know whether the French
authorities actually know who all the
people are in their country who are
coming over here to seek Asylum or are
they just wandering around France
unknown as well as as when they come
here thank you
the reality is is the home of our select
committee found when we were last in
Calais in in January is that the French
authorities do not arrest a lot of the
people trying to cross the channel and
turn a blind eye so therefore they're
not registered they don't have a record
who many of these uh these people are
and they only show an interest in
arresting and recording somebody who has
come from a country with whom they have
a returns agreement with whom there may
be a reasonable chance to return them
otherwise surprise surprise
their problem becomes a problem if they
then get into uh into boats those are
the things I hope
we all agree with across this house
whatever our stance on this bill but
also we need to challenge some
assumptions not all Asylum Seekers
coming across the channel have a
credible claim to claim Asylum
other countries do more we are told but
actually when you look at the totality
of the issue the amount of people that
we offer safe haven and support to
outside of the United Kingdom in refugee
camps for those people who just want to
go back to their own countries is more
generous than virtually any other
country in the world as well and we need
to look at the totality of that coming
to the UK is not always the appropriate
solution for many people and the
resettlement schemes which we have very
generously operated already particularly
with regard to Ukraine and Hong Kong
passport holders it's potentially huge
in the case of Hong Kong it could be up
to 2.9 Million people
and there's also the criticism we've
heard from the French about that we are
too generous they describe us as El
Dorado which is why so many refugees
apparently want to come across to the UK
but the other reality is
that even if we wanted to we cannot take
an unlimited number the fact that almost
10 000 Afghan refugees legally brought
here after the airlift and Kabul in the
summer before last over 18 months ago
are still in hotels pays Testament to
the fact that we have an accommodation
problem and so whatever we come up with
we need a system that is disciplined and
orderly and sustainable so we can make
sure people are processed quickly and
put in the appropriate accommodation
because frankly hotels for young
children for a sustained amount of time
like that built with their families let
alone on their own is just not the most
appropriate place for them to be I will
give way to you on the gentleman
the gentleman whether or not it's
appropriate in his View but uh former
RAF camps are now being used and planned
to be used for our migrants
well none of this is ideal but when
people arrive in their hundreds or on
one day last summer in the thousand
and all of a sudden become the
responsibility of the United Kingdom
government
there is a practical limitation on what
accommodation is available physically to
house them which is why our hotels are
being taken over and are full which is
why various military bases have been
used with mixed uh success and while the
government is having to look at other
Solutions but we have a serious problem
for accommodating our own constituents
as we all know from the shortage of
local Authority accommodation and we
just have to be realistic in terms of
how we can properly look after people
coming across the channel I'll give way
once more to my right on everyone way
and it's not just illegal migration uh
the population of this country is
growing in net terms as a direct result
of illegal and legal Migration by
something like a quarter of a million a
year that cannot in the end be sustained
for long over 10 years it is 2.5 million
people the size of many significant
cities that count can go on as the
housing situation for all of those
people is an insuperable challenge well
I think I made the point that whatever
migration system we run needs to be
effective efficient and sustainable but
at the same time we need people to fill
job vacancies in this country as uh as
well and many of the people who have
come here are self-sustaining I've had a
meeting this afternoon with about 60
Hong Kong British overseas passport uh
holders who've come here uh uh in flight
from Hong Kong who are making a good go
at starting a second life in this in
this country but however we think we
should operate migrant numbers the
numbers are not the important thing is
being able to look after people safely
and sustainably for all of our community
that is the major consideration and
there's one other thing I want to
mention the other the other truth that
is put about that we need to challenge
is that the echr is everything if you
look at the record of the Judgment
issued under the shr by the European
Court in the last 10 years
47 of them
47 almost half have not been complied
with
in certain countries that figure for
example in Spain 61 of judgments against
Spain from the echr have not been
complied with Italy 58 Germany 37 and in
many cases and particularly France which
is a little bit lower they are mostly
for non-compliance with immigration at
laws so let's not try and kid ourselves
that the measures in this bill are some
some way completely absurd and out of
court with what other countries have
been doing
so
having said um all that uh Dame um Rosie
doing nothing is not an option it allows
people Smugglers to continue the human
misery it's condoning bogus Asylum
Seekers and it's allowing those bogus
assigned Seekers to bump the queue for
the genuine Asylum Seekers to whom we do
have a duty of care that the vast
majority of people in this country want
to see
um carry it out so we need to get the
balance right on continuing our generous
tradition of allowing safe haven for
genuine assignment Seekers escaping
danger with much more robust action to
clamp down on those who have no
legitimate claim to be resent in the UK
and who are gaming our system taking
advantage of the UK taxpayer's
generosity and worst of all Hugh jumping
those genuine assignment Seekers who
need help and that is where safe and
legal Roots comes in so the main
Amendment I'm putting forward today and
I do
I will be prepared to move to a vote
unless I have some substantial
reassurances from the government because
this is nothing new this is not rocket
science and it's actually something that
the Prime Minister quite rightly has
committed to in principle and that is
new clause 13.
now that is the basis of the safe and
legal Roots
um Amendment it makes a requirement on
the face of the bill that there will be
safe and legal routes as part of this
legislation uh going uh through
so there must be in the regulations
referred to on the face of the bill
specific safe and legal routes by which
Asylum Seekers can enter the United
Kingdom in an orderly and sustainable
way
and the route specified must include
any country specific schemes which we
have already specifically we have
Afghanistan we have Syria we have
Ukraine and we have Hong Kong
but we need additional ones so
additionality is key to this because as
the bill stands the government could
just say we've got those safe and legal
routes we can just Tinker with those
but to take the example of the 16 year
old orphan boy from East Africa who is
not from Ukraine who is not from
Afghanistan is not from Syria and is not
from Hong Kong who has a single relative
legally settled in the United Kingdom
there are precious few opportunities for
him to be able to come to the UK in a
safe and legal route and it's to those
examples I think we need to often an
opportunity capped with numbers capped
with all sorts of considerations but we
need to offer a realistic opportunity
that they may be able to get safe and
Safe Haven in the United Kingdom I'll
give way to the unrelated
gentle and forgiving way I support very
much what he said indeed I support in
this bill the need for amendments
probing or otherwise to clarify what a
safe and legal route is and how they
will operate because that seems to be at
the heart of whether this legislation
could actually achieve anything that it
claims to set out does he therefore
agree with me that what we need is
Clarity because this bill does set out
where it considers to be safe from by
definition everywhere not listed in
section 88 a a is unsafe and therefore
we need clarity as to what would be a
safe and legal route from those
locations not listed in section 80a
otherwise we end up with safe or unsafe
being ill-defined and that doesn't help
anybody in legislative terms I'm I'm
grateful to vulnerable ladies so I have
drawn up this clause and the
accompanying amendments in a way which
is not overly prescriptive which puts
the owners back on the government to
come up with schemes some of them
schemes that we run before the safe and
legal Roots scheme uh is the the family
reunion scheme is something that we've
run for a long time it needs to be
adapted outside of the doubling
conventions now I've also suggested a
Duds 2 scheme where again that dub
scheme was was very successful in
bringing I think 483 children
unaccompanied single children from
genuine danger zones bringing them
safely to the United Kingdom those are
the sorts of examples they don't need to
create something completely new we need
to adapt what we have already got so
that's why additionality is key these
need to be Roots which people from
outside of the four existing
resettlement schemes I will in a in a
minute or Asylum schemes can come here
they must set out those routes for both
adults and children who I think most of
us would agree need to be dealt with
slightly differently and the means by
which those people can access those
routes it may be from the countries that
are fleeing themselves it may be from
refugee camps and schemes that we've had
before jointly with un HCR and I think
that was what has been mooted in the
newspaper it didn't come from me about
twenty thousand uh people being able to
come here through agreement with you and
HCR that is another possibility it may
be through using reception centers that
we have in other countries including in
France where a limited number could
possibly apply subject to a cap again
that is all down to the government to
decide I don't want to be overly
prescriptive I'll give away 200 from the
other way I think I thank my friend for
giving way and as ever he makes an
incredibly interesting and important
contribution there have been in the last
decade 10 safe and legal routes six of
which are countries specific four of
which are General the six Syria's now
shot two for Afghans two for Ukraine one
for Hong Kong and there are four
non-specific safer legal routes he is if
I understand correctly then arguing for
a fifth safe and legal route can he
explain how that fifth safer non-legal
route would delineate and be different
from the current Force sorry illegal not
non-legal Canadian get her that fifth
safe and legal route would be different
from the other four safe and legal
routes that we already have thank you
well those four existing routes are
countries specific for certain emergency
situations which are arrays for obvious
reasons in Ukraine Syria Afghanistan and
a rather prolonged emergency situation
we're seeing unravel in in Hong Kong
there will be other cases like that
which will come up and the bill as it
stands I believe gives the homes
secretary the power to determine there
is a new emergency in a certain country
where there's a sudden wave of uh
refugees generally fleeing that danger
to which the United Kingdom government
may want to give a commitment for us to
take um some of this I think everybody
would agree with that but in between
that country's specific scheme and the
four existing country-specific scheme
the numbers able to come here
are minimal and actually if you look at
the 500 just under 500 000 who've come
here since 2015 almost 400 000 of those
are accounted for by those from Hong
Kong and from uh Ukraine alone
uh sorry apologies if I thank him for
giving away again apologies if I if I
wasn't making myself clear out of those
10 schemes in the last decade four are
non-country specific safe and legal
routes he is arguing for a fifth an
additional safe and legal route and
whilst I'm not arguing against this case
I'm asking how his fifth safe and legal
generalized route would be different
from the other four that we currently
have which are non-country specific
because we've also got six country
specific schemes one of which Syria has
been shot I think I've given in two
examples the family reunion uh scheme
certainly in the terms in which I put
down in my new Clause at 19 is
non-country specific a dubs two type
scheme is non-country specific at the
moment if you're not country specific
you've had it largely particularly for
uh for young children the numbers I'm
afraid don't don't
um add up there's another consideration
I should have mentioned earlier again we
are told that every thing used to be
great and fine in terms of us being able
to return uh failed Asylum Seekers to
the EU in particular and that it's all
gone pear-shaped since brexit well in
the last year that we were covered by
the Dublin regulations when we are still
within the terms of the EU
the UK tried to return 8 500 failed
assignment Seekers to the EU of those
105 were admitted
so it didn't work before so this is a
long-standing problem which we haven't
had any help frankly from our EU
Partners in solving in the past which is
why we need to take more proactive and
robust action now which is why this bill
controversial though it is is so
necessary I did say that with the last
time the honorable lady the very last
time and then I will finish with my
comments thank my honorable friend
because I thank my honorable friend for
giving away he's making a powerful
argument for uh additional safe and
legal routes but the bill today is
designed to try and prevent illegal
migration whilst that understands that
those few people who are affected by his
new safe and legal route may be deterred
from illegal Migration by the fact that
they are part of that scheme there will
still be many many other people who are
not so how will it creating a few more
safe and legal options for a small
number of people prevent people coming
across the channel who are not affected
by those schemes we are not going to
eradicate people coming in boats across
the channel totally unless the front the
French will agree to intercept and
return
but we can limit it to those people who
do not stand a credible chance for
sailing of claiming asylum in the United
Kingdom and one of the problems in the
courts at the moment with the many
failed Asylum claims which then go
through appeal process is there was no
other way of getting here rather than on
a boat
safe and legal route Amendment and
everything with it goes through that
will not be an excuse because anybody
could have applied through a safe
illegal route and if you were turned
down and then turned to a boat that is
not a defense
I'd be very indulgent but I know many
other people want to speak but I I I'm
very grateful and my honorable friend
makes the
that the churches and tribunals tribunal
chairs are looking for a factual reasons
upon which to refuse applications well I
can't think of a better one than the
availability of in a controlled way more
safe and legal routes at the moment
without further action and without
concurrent action from the government in
passing this legislation and creating
safe and legal routes we are I'm afraid
opening ourselves up to the risk of more
people making those claims are are not
being able to control the situation in
the way that we all want well I'm
grateful with the huge legal expertise
and experience in his former roles of my
right honorable friend that is the that
is the point we need to isolate the
bogus Asylum Seekers who are paying the
people Smugglers and you do that by
making it clear that we are open to
genuine cases of people fleeing danger
there is a legit and practical and
usable route for them and if they don't
qualify for that don't try to get in a
boat because you stand no chance of
having your claims upheld if you make it
across I'm just trying to achieve a
balance so if you want to have
this bill go through then we need to
have safer and legal routes in it to
make it a properly balanced bill
if you don't like this bill but you want
safe and legal routes you need to
support this bill to get those safe and
legal routes this is mutually beneficial
to all of those on either side of this
argument on this bill now quickly Dame
raising finish off with the rest of my
amendments new Clause 19
outlines how a refugee family reunion
scheme will work
it's a wide definition of close family
members and including people who are
adopted and everything again this is
nothing new but it's a generous scheme
which I think would do what it says on
the on the tin
my other
four amendments our Amendment 74 which I
think is a really important
consideration the government has said
that it wants the legislation to go
through to be able to clamp down on the
small boats I have no problem with that
although there are some things here here
which are not quite as moderate that I
would like I think this bill is
necessary to go through so I'm trying to
improve this this bill but the governor
said it will
then consult on safe and legal routes
and we need to consult on safer legal
route to local authorities and others
will be bearing the brunt of how we
accommodate many of these candidates and
then they'll come up with some safe and
legal routes that isn't good enough
the two sides of this bill must be
contemporaneous yes we must not be able
to bring in these tough measures until
those safe and legal routes are
operational so people can have the
option to go down that safe and legal
route rather than rely on the people
Smugglers the government will say well
we need to consult we'll start it now
because we need to be Consulting with
the local authorities surely on how we
get more people out of the hotels now in
sustainable accommodation for the long
term so really the government should be
getting on with the Consulting now so
when this bill eventually goes through
and I suspect it may take some while to
get through the other other place those
safe and legal routes are up and running
and ready to go so Amendment 74 was an
important Amendment Amendment 75 just
add safe and legal routes is one of the
purposes to the bill in Clause one
Clause one is all about clamping down on
illegal migration quite right but it
should also be the balancing of
providing those safe and legal as well
so I want to put it in Clause one right
at the start of the bill and then
Amendment 72 and 73 are contingent on
all of the um above
Dame Rosie lots of people are trying to
misrepresent and cause Mischief about
this bill and in some cases unsafe and
legal routes and I just end on my own
experience when ip'd appeared on BBC
Southeast politics two weeks ago and was
talking about safe and legal routes and
I was challenged why are you supporting
this bill when you were so keen on safe
and legal roots and challenged the home
sector I said because this bill contains
Provisions for safe and legal routes it
does because it talks about safe legal
routes and capping numbers and
everything and everything else
the following week on the same program
with no recourse to me
the presenter read out
an email from the home office having
got in contact with the home office
unbeknownst to me to ask about my claim
on safe and legal routes
and the home office apparently replied
nothing in the bill commits the
government to opening new safe and legal
routes or increasing the numbers
which was used to me news to the
ministers news to the ministers at the
home office
hold on he may not be laughing in a
minute news to the ministers until I was
accused of being misleading
so when I challenge this it turns out
that what the home office communique
actually said
is that the roots to be included as part
of the approach set up for the new bill
will be set out in the regulations uh
which will depend on a number of factors
including safely groups the government
offers at the time the regulations are
prepared and as the Prime Minister has
said we will get a grip on illegal
migration and then bring in more safe
and legal routes so actually it is
provided for in the bill and actually
the BBC completely misrepresented my
comments and I'm glad to say yesterday
issued an apology apology and give me a
right of reply so let's stick to the
facts let's not get hung up on all the
prejudices about this we have a problem
in this country and the problem is that
last year just under 46 000 people came
across in the most inappropriate and
dangerous Manner and we have not got the
capacity to deal with people in those
numbers with many of them with
unsustainable uh claims and we've got to
get to grits with it I think this bill
is a genuine attempt to get to grips
with it it would be much more palatable
and much more workable if it contained a
balance that has safe and legal routes
written in to the bill that come in at
the same stage and I would challenge
them the opposition to say that they've
got a better scheme how we deal with
this Dreadful problem and simply voting
against all the measures in this bill is
not going to help anyone yeah
all right
SNP spokesperson Stuart C McDonald thank
you very much Dean Rosie do we support
international human rights protections
or do we not Abby steadfast in our
adherence to the European convention on
human rights the refugee convention and
other International treaties that we
have signed up to or are we not to me
it's extraordinary that these simple
questions are even apparently subject to
debate but those simple questions are
precisely what this appalling bill is
asking of us including in the closets
that we are debating today United
Nations had commission for refugees has
been clear that this bill breaches the
refugee convention
the Council of Europe commissioner for
human rights is rent to us all today to
warn that it's essential that members of
parliament prevent legislation that is
incompatible with the UK's International
obligations being passed so our view is
that it's because this bill rides
roughshod over international human
rights law that it should be scrapped
entirely but short of that the
amendments in the name of my honorable
Fame for Glasgow Central and colleagues
try at least to restore some level of
respect for international law
this is not only an abstract issue of
international War this is about the
Afghan Lieutenant that we read about in
yesterday's independently flew 30 combat
missions against the Taliban and was
praised by his Coalition supervisor as
being a patriot to his nation and now he
is in a hotel and threatened with
removal to Rwanda and it's about LGBT
people fleeing the outrageous criminal
laws in Uganda whose Parliament last
week voted for further Draconian
legislation imposing endless
imprisonment and even death sentences
and LGBT people as well as those who
don't know what not report them to the
police or even rent a room to them this
is all about tracking victims about
victims of torture and many many more
vulnerable people
the question is are we committed to
meeting our International obligations to
these people for my SNP colleagues and I
the answer must clearly be yes but this
bill says no and so we start by
absolutely opposing Clause 49 and the
government's attempts to undermine the
role of the court of Human Rights here
here close 49 and powers of Home
Secretary ignore and even to compel our
courts to ignore interim measures from
the court it's said to be a placeholder
Clause but here we are debating in this
house with only a select a bunch of
conservative back benches apparently any
of the wiser as to what the government's
intentions are with respect to it so the
Clause as it is drafted is completely
unacceptable but so too is the way that
government is treating Parliament as a
council of Europe commissioner for human
rights States in his letter to his
interim measures issued by the European
Court of human rights under binding
nature are integral to ensuring that
member states fully and effectively
fulfill their human rights obligations
so we believe that Clause should be
taken out or either I remember 119 or
normal friend foreign
122 should be supported to ensure that
that power is used consistently with the
convention the Prime Minister should
stop dancing to the tune of the
anti-echr minority you should have the
guts to put international human rights
before internal party management
next to Safe legal routes which many
amendments and new Clauses
understandably address the lack of them
and in the case of the Afghan citizens
resettlement scheme the poor and slow
implementation is clearly a contributor
to the regular arrivals expanding them
would help tackle this issues and
remember for these dwelling as just
eloquently set out but Clause 51 as it
stands is completely inadequate it
provides for a limit not to be exceeded
rather than providing a Target to aim
for and it allows a home secretary
instead of parliament to set the
definition of safe Legal Group so our
Amendment 179 and related amendments
replaced the cap with a Target and a
longer term Target too and seek to
improve parliament's role in setting
that goal and holding the Home Secretary
account for her efforts to meet it
and we support other new Clauses include
I may have been seeking to achieve at
similar aims we support the various new
Clauses that have been put down
highlighting particular safe legal
routes such as a humanitarian travel
permit safe passage Visa schemes Refugee
family room and Dublin style safe legal
routes for children in the European
Union the key point is as has been said
these routes should be a priority and an
urgent part of the overall response and
not an afterthought to be looked at a
little way down the line
turning them to the remaining causes
relating to legal proceedings
frankly most of the provisions in this
bill essentially dehumanize people who
seek protection here so that no matter
what Horrors they have endured their
individual circumstances are to be
ignored and their ability to access
rates and protection set out in
international treaties is to be
absolutely decimated instead they're to
be detained locked up and either removed
or left in a permanent limbo these
Clauses on legal proceedings buttress
that regime by seeking to Snuff out the
ability of anyone to get to a courtroom
to challenge what is going on before the
removal takes place
what is most fundamental about this
regime is what you cannot use as a
guidance for a suspensive challenge
prior to removal the Afghan who fought
alongside our Pilots against the Taliban
cannot challenge his removal to Rwanda
on the grounds that he is a refugee and
the trafficking victim cannot prevent
his or her lengthy detention and removal
on the basis of being such a victim of
trafficking Third Amendment 76 makes a
fundamental point that if a person makes
a claim to be a refugee or makes a human
rights claim or there are grounds to
think that maybe a victim of modern
slavery or trafficking that should be
considered before any action is taken to
remove here here that is basically how
things used to be that is basically how
things are up until now that is how it
should be and that is generally what is
required to live up to our obligations
under international law and we also
believe it is a requirement of simple
common Humanity yeah but it's a bill
stands not only is none of that possible
but the limited ability to challenge on
ground is that serious and irreversible
harm is risked is also made incredibly
Difficult by the way these Clauses are
drafted
that's made more difficult because of
ludicrously restricted grounds for
Challenge and appeals and high
evidential burdens it happens because of
red tape and deadlines that will simply
be impossible to comply with
these challenges are provided because
there are more oyster Clauses and
restricted appeal rights and this
happens because it gives a secretary of
state in this bill significant and
unwarranted control over these processes
ensure access to Justice in the rule of
law are being absolutely pulverized and
various other amendments are designed to
pick away at that and restore these
appeal rights
so why has the government decided on
real risk of serious and irreversible
harm as a test for suspensive claims yes
I acknowledge that that is the backstop
test for interim measures under the
European Convention of Human Rights but
it's a high and an unusually difficult
taste and obviously risks the removal of
people and circumstances where
significant harm will occur to them why
in particular is a secretary of state
left to define the concept rather than
Parliament including the ability to
lower the standard if she's unhappy with
how courts are interpreting it
we are particularly concerned with Claus
at 40 subclose five and the requirements
to make valid suspensive claims and I'd
be grateful if the minister could
clarify what the implications of a claim
not meeting those requirements are often
if an application isn't in the
prescribed form it means the Home
Secretary simply doesn't look at the
claim at all and that means there won't
even be a refusal that can be appealed
so I'm asking the minister is that the
case in these circumstances
most concerningly listed alongside the
necessity in the prescribed form is a
requirement for the application to
contain compelling evidence so again I
asked the minister does that mean if the
Home Secretary simply decides that there
is no compelling evidence then it's as
if no application has been made at all
and therefore there is no right of
appeal because if that's the case that
means a section of State can simply
close down any possibility of a
challenge by deciding what location has
been made at all so I would genuinely
appreciate Clarity from the minister on
that point
is listening very carefully indeed why
is it a requirement of compelling
evidence more importantly isn't that
totally inconsistent with the taste of
real risk the point of amendment 83. the
danger is that even a probability of
serious will harm wouldn't be enough
because of the type of evidence it can
realistically be provided in the
ludicrously time scales provided for
on time frames we have various
amendments to challenge the time periods
that have been formally set down by the
government the notion that eight days is
enough time for an application is for
the buds as we know from the chaotic
processes used during previous attempts
to remove people to Rwanda when many who
also have noticed barely understood what
was happening to them language barriers
difficulties of access to solicitors and
legal aid the requirements of prescribed
forms and demands for compelling
evidence in the application means eight
days will never happen
these processes give rise to the risk
even those who could in theory make a
challenge will miss out unjustly so on
that point and very important Point can
the minister give clarity as to how he
is going to ensure legal advice is
accessible and importantly what his
government's position is on the
availability of legal aid these are
hugely important issues which are not
really touched upon in the bill at all
given these ludicrously restricted time
frames a restriction of out of time
claims in class 44 is also frightening
and our amendments from 101 onwards seek
to challenge yes this time it's
compelling evidence of a compelling
reason for missing the deadline that is
required what else does that mean is
inability to understand the notice or
language difficulties or the
impossibility of finding a solicitor
sufficient more importantly is the
government saying it's okay to remove
somebody who is certainly going to face
serious Universal harm just because they
were a few hours late with the paperwork
and didn't have a decent excuse for that
it makes absolutely no sense the seven
day time frame for appeals to be lodging
class 47 is equally absurd for all of
these reasons again how will access to
legal advice and legal aid be insured
who has a government consulted with in
putting together this very challenging
time framework why has the government
chosen to pass bypass a first-year
tribunal why is the government now
apparently suggesting using first-tier
employment law judges to assess
difficult issues of removal and serious
harm
some will have an even more difficult
route to challenge a refusal if the home
sector decides a claim is clearly
unfounded and the Clauses don't seem to
make any sense because if it seems to be
the case that to make a valid
application you need to provide
compelling evidence of harm it's
difficult then to see how any valid
application containing such compelling
evidence can then be deemed to be
clearly unfounded but going beyond that
the grounds for appeal to the upper tier
upper tribunal are Again objectionably
difficult just to get permission to
appeal compelling evidence in serious
and irreversible harm and assessed on
the papers with no further rights of
appeal so our amendments to close 43
seek to rectify that
we object to the bill instructing the
tribunal to how how to do its work and
in particular how to make assessments of
fact judges is not the Secretary of
State Should determine what new matters
can be considered and what evidence and
facts are relevant to their decisions so
our amendments to close 46 and cause 47
and various other Clauses seek to
protect the independence of the tribunal
and we object very strongly to those
that clause and Clause 4 to 8 including
in particular restrictions in the
supervisory jurisdiction of the court
session well amendments 100 108 also
seek to challenge restrictions on unborn
rates of appeal these are serious and
significant issues of profound
importance removing the oversight of the
courts is unacceptable and frankly
unconstitutional
we had a well-developed and functioning
system of appeals and judicial oversight
of it the government should stop
dismantling it instead disabilities most
people seeking to assert the rights only
able to do so after they have been
removed the notion that such challenges
can be successfully undertaken from
thousands of miles away is absolutely
absurd
and then that brings us to the
fundamental question what happens if
someone is actually successful when
making a suspensive case all across four
to five states is that they cannot be
removed it does not then allow them to
access Asylum process or for any other
assessment to be made other case they
like tens or thousands of others who
cannot be removed simply because there
is nowhere to remove them to are going
to be left in limbo a limbo that will be
disastrous for the taxpayer but
absolutely life destroying for the
individuals involved A desperate outcome
from a desperate bill
finally Dame Rosie well we support
almost all the other amendments in New
Clothes table by opposition members we
do have concerns about new Clauses 23
and 25. new course 23 requires the
Secretary of State to use a broad
discretion to put in place a fast track
Asylum procedure for so-called low Grant
rate countries it also contains an
amazingly wide definition of low Grant
rate country because that would include
nationalities where 49 of applicants
have successfully sought Asylum new
class 25 has aspects which we think are
fine but crucial to what seems to be
trying to do are cooperation agreements
for removal of people who have had
claims declared inadmissible but there
is no separate definition of
inadmissible separate from the
definition and clauses two and four of
the bill and these are at the heart of
all the problems with this bill
so we will continue to listen to
carefully to what is said about these
new Clauses and but we are concerned
that they need further work Dean Rosie
in short we oppose every aspect of this
bill we object to the outrageous time
frame for consideration of it and we
object to the lack of impact assessment
before we get to debate it our
amendments try to mitigate some of its
worst aspects But ultimately it remains
an unlawful Bill completely not only
Beyond repair
yeah
Simon Clark you were Dame Rosie and I
Rise to speak to amendment number 132
which stands in my name and together
with numbers 131 133 and 134 has been
drawn up with the express purpose of
ensuring that our legislation does what
my right and will friend the Prime
Minister has rightly said should be our
priority namely stopping the small boat
and the evil trade that stays we are
fortunate to live in one of the greatest
countries on Earth but unless you
believe in a literally unlimited right
of immigration in any sane legal order
the United Kingdom must have the ability
to effectively control our borders it is
only by having such control that we can
maintain Democratic concerned both for
legal migration but also for our system
for allowing Asylum to those in needs as
we've done rightly and generously with
those fleeing or oppression of the
Chinese state in Hong Kong the
bestiality of the Taliban in Afghanistan
or the cruelty of Putin's war in Ukraine
and as my right humble friend the
minister said from the dispatch box
almost half a million humanitarian visas
have been granted by this country since
2015 specifically 50 000 of which have
come from existing Global safe and legal
routes
at the moment we do not exercise the
control to which I alluded a moment ago
and contrary to what the venture's
opposite May pretend the reality is
there is no amount of cooperation with
the French or investment in our
infrastructure at the border welcome
though those are which can deter people
except uh attempting this Crossing in
the tens of thousands each year I will
give away my honorable friend makes a
fantastic points about this nation being
hospitable and very generous
particularly over the last few years but
does he agree with the point raised by
The Honorable member for South Holland
in the deepins that it's not just a
problem with legal roots and illegal
immigration but over time we've had more
and more legal migration and I'm afraid
our population is now Rising so quickly
it is fundamental in fundamentally
undermining our ability to provide
Public Services well I think my friend
for his intervention I certainly believe
that it's vital that we will only have
Democratic concern for legal migration
if it is clear that that happens at the
behest of this house with the consent of
this house and critically that we do not
have an illegal immigration situation
which is beyond this house uh in its in
our ability to control it uh
speaker uh the reality is that if we are
going to effectively deter uh the uh the
evil trade in people smoking that we
need to tackle the incentives which
means making it crystal clear that
coming here illegally
will lead to your Swift attention and
removal it is neither compassionate nor
sustainable to allow what is currently
an abuse of our immigration system to
continue and I can testify that having
sat in meeting after meeting with the
home office as the chief secretary to
the treasury the cost to the executor of
putting up millions of pounds each day
are to support hotels uh to house Asylum
Seekers is not something which we should
take lightly that is in part why I've
tabled my amendments today
bitter experience teaches us that Tony
Blair's Human Rights Act will otherwise
act to frustrate the will of parliament
the government has quite rightly
therefore drafted the bill to just apply
Section 3 of the ACT but I believe other
sections of the ACT will be engaged too
and that these should also your life
will be disappointed for the express
purposes of this legislation I say this
not on my own authority but on that of
Professor Richard eakins of Oxford
University answer Stephen laws Casey the
former first parliamentary Council as
they argue in their February policy
exchange paper and I quote new
legislation should expressly to supply
the operative provisions of a 1998 Act
specifically section three
interpretation legislation section four
the Declaration of incompatibility
section six the acts of public
authorities in section 10 the power to
take remedial action they go on to say
without legislative provision to this
effect it is inevitable that claimants
will challenge the home secretary's
understanding of the legislation
inviting the court with either to
interpret the legislation to redown her
duties remove persons from the UK or
reading in new procedural requirements
or to declare the legislation
incompatible with convention rights and
thus authorizing ministers to change it
by executive order and ensuring that
political pressure would be brought to
bear to this end damn Rosie having the
supplied Section 3 on the basis that it
leaves open the possibility of systemic
legal challenge I can see no legal
philosophical or practical argument
against doing the same wear a similar
risk exists
ultimately we know that our best and
probably only chance to avoid this
legislation from being entangled in
human rights law is for this place to be
absolutely clear and unambiguous about
our intentions and it feels to me that
my Amendment flows in that spirit and
that we should show the determination
now not after the fact even when the
fears of many of us in this house have
been realized to make our intentions
clear on the face of the bill then Rosie
I also wish to speak briefly in favor of
amendment number 131 presented by my
honorable friend the member for devises
and this has a comparable aim to my own
amendment in respect of the echr I do so
for the reason set out by the law
Chancellor at the time the convention
was entered into by the United Kingdom
he said the real Vice of the document
therefore consists in its lack of
precision I should be unable to advise
with any certainty as to what result
will be arrived at in any given case
even if the judges were applying the
principles of English law
it completely passes the wit of murder
to guess what results will be arrived at
by tribunal composed of elective persons
who need not even be lawyers drawn from
various European States possessing
completely different systems of Law and
whose deliberation takes place behind
closed doors this in a nutshell is the
risk to which we expose this legislation
if we proceed without that protection
and I very much hope that my right
number friends on the front bench will
take these amendments seriously and work
with us over the course of the crucial
weeks ahead to make sure that the
legislation respects the will of this
house and I believe the will of the
British people
Dame Diana Johnson thank you Dan Rosie
first of all I would like to add my
voice to the concerns that a number of
members have already raised about the
lack of an impact assessment and
equality impact assessment and a
children's rights impact assessment as
we commend this very important committee
stage of the bill
now in the home Affairs select committee
report on small boats and migration we
made clear and I want to read this to
the house there is no magical single
solution to dealing with irregular
migration
detailed evidence driven fully costed
and fully tested policy initiatives are
by far the most likely to achieve
sustainable incremental change that
deters Journeys such as jet dangerous
Channel Crossings
so I think it is
um very um regrettable that we don't
have all that information we don't have
the costings we don't have the impact
assessments when we're debating these
Clauses in the house today particularly
when this bill is being rushed through
the commons I'm happy to give away I
better give them a little freaking
wishes call for a number of Assessments
and rightly so but isn't the real test
of this bill actually the headlines the
newspaper headlines impacts assessment
and that's all it's about
well um I Thank The Honorable gentleman
for that intervention I I think
unfortunately there seems to be a great
deal of confusion in the house actually
about the small boats issue and um I
think it's just worth reflecting on the
fact that currently the largest number
of people coming across in small boats
actually come from Afghanistan
and I think we need to to reflect on
that we also need to reflect on the fact
that the backlog in the home office now
over 166 000 has been growing for some
time and has a knock-on effect then
about how quickly the system can deal
with people arriving in this country and
process them and remove those who should
not be here and I think it's also just
worth reflecting on the home Affairs
select committee report from last summer
where we said there were four things
that needed to the government needed to
do to address the small boats crisis
first of all and number one was clear
the backlog and speed up the processing
of people arriving in small boats
secondly was the issue of safe and legal
routes and I'm going to say a little bit
more about that in a moment we also
stress the need for international
cooperation and the need to deal with
the criminal gangs and have in place
return agreements with uh countries
I do remain worried about the argument
that this legislation will deter people
from getting into small boats and that
goes back to my concern about the lack
of evidence so I am concerned about that
and and um The Honorable member for
um westworthy and Shoreham referred to
the home Affairs select committee trip
to northern France in January and one of
the key things I remember from that trip
was
if someone is in Calais or northern
France and they are standing on the
beach and they can see the British
Coastline just 30 miles away that really
is too late the fact that they're there
is too late they are going to take their
chance and get into a boat
I also just wanted to say before I refer
to my amendment that I worry about the
capacity of the home office to deal with
momentous change which this legislation
will bring in they haven't been very
good at dealing with the applications
for Asylum that have been building for
for many years and I do worry about
their capacity to deal with the
large-scale Detention of people and
families and children which this bill
will bring in now I want to speak to
Amendment 137 which is in my name on
establishing a cap on the number of
migrants using safe and legal routes
now it will of course be a difficult job
for this house to identify what crises
are going to unfold in the year ahead
and then make provision for it in 2010
we could not have known the true extent
of refugees from the first Libyan Civil
War or from South Sudan or in or Syria
in 2011 or Ukraine just one year ago
and we cannot know what Global
challenges we will face in the next year
so setting an arbitrary Target could be
seen to restrain governments being able
to respond dynamically and appropriately
but more importantly I want to look at
exactly who will be included in the cap
and I just want to talk about children
I'm sure all of us can agree that every
child has the right to protection from
persecution discrimination and violence
it's a Cornerstone of international and
domestic law and turning away a child
fleeing a war zone or a genocide because
of a cap decided months earlier in this
house could undermine the key principles
of the international Child Protection
Frameworks that we have signed up to and
includes our own 1989 children's act
which gives a very clear focus on our
International obligations in domestic
legislation now I know the governments
say that this Clause will allow the
government to exceed the number set out
in the cap each year of needs be
in which case it really isn't a cap is
it it might be a Target but it's a
Target that may well have difficulty
actually dealing with the reality of
what's happening on the international
front I also um think we should reflect
on and acknowledge the willingness of
the British people to step up to the
plate when crises appear as thousands
did this year to take in displaced
ukrainians and the wholesale support for
unaccompanied children being given
shelter here when we debated the dubs
Amendment a few years ago
so if the government is determined to
introduce this cap then I would argue
that it is right that children are not
included in the cap number and that
people are set out in the Clause are
defined as those over 18 years of age
setting a cap on the number of children
who can claim Asylum could well mean
turning away one child whilst choosing
another and it's a Sophie's Choice
regulation
and I would ask the minister to think
again and recognize the special position
of children and Our obligation to them
now of course the most obvious and
appropriate way to support Refugee
children is to ensure that they have
access to safe and legal routes and
which are clearly set out and defined
which is why I've added my name to new
Clause 13 and Amendment 72-75 tabled by
The Honorable member and I will get his
constituency right this time East
Worthing and showroom
and I also support my honorable friends
amendments for the admirable friend for
wolfenstow's amendments new clause 17.
now in our home Affairs committee report
last summer we made it explicitly clear
that ensuring that there are accessible
safe and legal routes to the United
Kingdom is a key plank of an asylum
system that is both fair and effective
and also provides a clear disincentive
and deterrent for illegal Roots I just
wanted to say that I agreed with the
comments from The Honorable gentleman
about the need for additionality and
that we cannot just say that the current
schemes that are in place welcome as
they are are sufficient there has to be
a package of measures to deal with the
current situation along with clearing
the backlog as I said earlier on and it
cannot be right that this is left to
some future day when we will discuss and
know about what these safe and legal
routes will mean we need to have this as
part of the bill up front so we've got
both sides of what's needed here the
deterrent and the the option around safe
and legal roots and I also just wanted
to say something about new Clause 8 and
a new clause 10.
and these are around safe passage Visa
schemes now the home Affairs select
committee had an idea in the report that
we produced about using the reception
centers in France to allow people to
make Asylum claims from France now I
know the
um the government rejected that but I
think some imaginative thinking about
how you can assist people to make claims
would be very helpful and I think that's
why new Clause 8 and new Clause 10 are
certainly worth the government
considering
um what that would actually mean we
already we know that we have juxtaposed
checks on passports and customs with the
French and I think there may well be
more room to negotiate with the French
something about making claims in France
directly and I know new Clause 8 is a
little more prescriptive than new Clause
10 and that that might be helpful as
well I've always I did my name to
Amendment one two two tables by The
Honorable and learned member for
Edinburgh South West which clarifies our
legal responsibilities and fulfilling
the recommendations by The Joint
Committee on human rights the home
Affairs select committee report last
year underlined the importance of strong
International cooperation and
relationships in order to deal with
migration issues and these I believe
would be weakened by walking away from
our International legal obligations so
in conclusion the government must ensure
this bill does not undermine our legal
or our moral obligations it should
clearly establish safe and legal routes
in the bill and if the government is
determined to tighten our Refugee
Provisions then we must not turn our
backs on child refugees by arbitrarily
capping or excluding those vulnerable
children who turn to us for support
we're here
Danny Krueger
thank you very much indeed
earner I Rise to speak to
the amendment 131 in my name and that of
colleagues and I want to start by
expressing my gratitude to the minister
and his colleagues for their very
constructive engagement in in recent
days and on the basis of the commitment
I hope we'll hear from him this
afternoon I don't propose to push this
amendment to a vote this evening I also
want to thank my honorable friend friend
the member for stone has just returned
from his cup of tea very glad to hear it
because I'm about to make a great speech
and defense of parliamentary sovereignty
and his honor
but uh Madam chair the fact is we need a
new Asylum system in our country and
indeed the world needs a new framework
for protecting the rights of refugees in
an age of mass migration of the huge
people movements that we are seeing and
part of that is safe and legal roots and
this is the natural corollary of this
bill and I support the principle of my
honorable friend the member for East
Worthington and his amendments to that
end and I particularly want to endorse
the work that's gone on in the home
office and I want to see more of it
around Community sponsorship as one of
the existing Global routes that we have
and we want to see that widened
significantly
but even more fundamentally than that
the new framework we need needs to honor
the founding principle of both the
European conventional and human rights
and the refugees convention the
principle that the primary
responsibility for managing Asylum rests
with the nation-state
this is the purpose of the bill before
us and the amendment in my name
and it's worth stating I think it's part
of why as part of this new framework
that we need we need a law requiring the
removal removal of people who arrive
here illegally because the fact is that
even if we had the best safe legal route
in the world we would still have
thousands of people tens maybe hundreds
of thousands a year seeking to come here
by unsafe illegal routes and we simply
cannot accommodate all of those people
and that is why it is absolutely right
that this bill creates a limit a cap on
the total number of refugees that we
will receive what that capture be is Up
For Debate but with the needs the need
for one is clear
and so unless we want open borders and
members officers deny that they want
this then we have to do something about
the many many people who will still try
to come once the cap has been reached
and the answer the only logical answer
is to deny people who enter illegally
the leave to stay to detain them and to
remove them somewhere safe and free
are they back to their own country or to
a third country that's willing to have
them and this process has to be Swift
and unquestioned nothing else than the
certainty of detention and Speedy
removal will deter illegal migrants and
break the business model of the
Smugglers
now this power of removal was
established with the nationality and
borders Act but then as we know a
Georgian Strasbourg was woken in the
middle of the night by a lawyer acting
for an assortment of campaign groups and
sitting in his pajamas for all we know
he issued an interim order
that caused the home office to stop the
policy before the first plane took off
and there are two things happy to give
away
what the honorable gentleman has just
described is the process of getting
an injunction in England and the process
of getting an interim interdiction
Scotland so you're not aware that this
happens just about every day of the week
in our domestic legal systems yeah
the difference is that our domestic
legal system should not be subject to
the findings of a foreign court and and
moreover the pro and moreover the
process should be transparent able to
appeal and the government should have
been able to to be involved in the
process action taking place in that way
is profoundly undemocratic let me
explain let me explain myself more
clearly there are two things profoundly
wrong with what happened last June the
first is the explicit tolerance of
illegality the claim by activists backed
by opposition politicians and by judges
that people who break into our country
should be allowed to stay and settle
here and second the idea the laws of the
British Parliament can effectively be
struck down by the courts claiming a
greater sovereignty a deference to a
higher power than parliamentary statute
the power of international law and we
need I'm happy to give away
I thank the under budget for giving away
but we as United Kingdom have signed up
to many International treaties why do we
sign up to treaties if we're not going
to allow them to be implemented or
follow them you're here you're right the
Lord is absolutely right this is a
treaty that we are signed up to and
under a treaty we have certain
obligations one of those obligations
does not include the obeying these
interim orders there's no legal basis
for there's no legal basis for the legal
for us to obey the legal order that's a
recent convention and it's not on it's
not in statute that we should obey it
yeah moreover we didn't even if it was a
substantive judgment it doesn't give
direct effect to to uh to the British
government
so we need to change these things this
is why this bill is necessary it will
mandate not merely permit the government
to remove illegal migrants so there can
be no doubt in the minds of ministers or
officials or contractors what the law
requires them to do but what about the
courts now I know that the government
hopes and expects that the new mandate
to remove will be enough that plain
primary legislation passed in this place
will persuade judges whether in
Strasbourg or the UK not to stand in the
way of Parliament I hope they're right
but I don't think we can rely on hope I
don't think we can rely on assurances
that the government may have received
from Strasbourg the judges there will
respect this law in a way that they
didn't respect the last one we need to
go further not just permit removals as
per the nationality and borders act not
just mandate removals as per this bill
but we must also actively block the
frustration of the removals policy and
the primary means by which this policy
will be frustrated is the European Court
of Human Rights now my Amendment ensures
that the policy of removal can
go ahead notwithstanding any decision of
the European Court no more pajama
injunctions in the middle of the night
so-called rule 39 orders
I thank the only gentleman for giving
away one of the reasons why Winston
Churchill helped set up the European
Court of Human Rights was to protect
citizens across Europe including here in
the UK from overbearing governments who
didn't have respect for the role of
courts in keeping them honest
with his Amendment let us see some
honesty is he saying that he wants in
contrast to the Prime Minister for us to
leave the European Court of Human Rights
because this amendment if it were passed
would mean that we would have to and be
in the same court as Belarus so we'll be
honest does he want us to be Belarus
I'm very grateful to The Honorable lady
she mentions Winston Churchill who of
course had no intention of the UK
signing up to the European convention
it's true he sent some lawyers over
there but in Pratt but actually the
original intention was for the UK not
there was no need for the for the UK to
sign up to it we did so and at that time
there was no rule 39 orders there was no
opportunity for court for judges in the
middle of the night to issue these
interim orders and stop UK policy and
that's that should not have been the
case and it should not be the case now
and even substantive judgments which I
also uh I said we need to comply with
honorable members officers are quite
right about that even they should not
have the direct effect of halting
removals a substantive judgment against
the UK would simply start a process of
negotiation as we had after the Court
ruled against us on prisoner voting my
Amendment would put Strasbourg and the
echr in its proper place as a treaty
partner not a higher power not a
superior lawmaker to the parliament of
the United Kingdom
seem to think that the echr has Superior
power to the sovereignty of this house
which I I invite them to invite them to
stand and find a stand on that platform
at the next election by all means go
ahead and suggest that suggest that this
house is not sovereign
[Music]
I come
not to bury the echo but to praise it it
is a Noble document as we know it was
written with the help of British
conservative lawyers but really it just
codifies the Liberties enjoyed under
English common law and statute we did
not we we did not we should not have and
we sadly have put ourselves under the
supervisory jurisdiction of the European
court and we should not be dictated to
when it comes to control of our borders
and I challenge any member who thinks
that the judges in Strasbourg have a
superior jurisdiction to this Parliament
so this amendment will restore the
proper balance of power now Madam chair
before in in conclusion I want to go to
what I think is the heart of the matter
and why passions run so high about this
bill the heart of the matter is what
kind of country the UK is or what we
think it is members opposite that think
that this country is cruel Petty a
small-minded small island that ignores
its responsibility to the most
vulnerable people in the in the world
that's what they think that this country
is but our side doesn't think that we
know that we have obligations the world
world's refugees and we are determined
to fulfill them but we think that the
first and foundational principle that
defines the UK the source and the basis
of all our generosity and our engagement
with the problems of the world is that
we are a law-governed nation and that
the laws which govern us are made here
in this building by the representatives
of the people that is the principle that
holds everything together that is why
Britain is respected abroad that is the
basis of our peace and prosperity and
our extraordinary history it is why
directly or indirectly so many people
from other countries want to come and
live here whether they come legally or
illegally because we are a safe
prosperous law governed and Sovereign
Nation no human rights framework no
International Convention can dictate to
us that we should tolerate illegality
let alone illegal entry to our country
and all the Privileges of residents here
we need with this bill to remember the
people who sent us to this place and
what they expect of us to send interest
in the values of the law-abiding
citizens of this country to put the laws
we make here ahead of the interpretation
of a foreign Court
statute of sovereign Parliament is
Sovereign the public expects us to have
the courage to discharge our duty and
Take Back Control of our borders as we
promised we would do when we left the EU
I believe this bill will do that there's
some strengthenings and I know the
government shares this for you and I
look forward to working with them the
head of the report stage to make the
bill water tight
Tim fahren
you Dame Eleanor and it's a pleasure to
follow my my friend's speech with whom I
I agree on the issue of uh the source of
Human Rights and sometimes we need to
have an Arbiter a human one who will
prevent us from being our worst selves I
fear that this government is being its
worst self here I think this bill uh
with its Flagship title no pun intended
to stop the boats I want to stop the
votes every person who gets in a rickety
boat on the French side of the channel
and takes the risk of Crossing it is a
potential tragedy we should want those
Boat Crossings to stop I am convinced
this bill will do nothing of the sort
this bill is dozy and it is dangerous it
is dozy because it won't work and it
will be counterproductive it is
dangerous dangerous for genuine refugees
we won't know who they are unless we
seek to assess them in the first place
and dangers for Britain's reputation and
therefore our power soft and otherwise
overseas therefore undermining our
sovereignty it fails the moral test not
just because of the impact on those who
seek Sanctuary on our Shores but because
it's based on a hysterical and bogus
pretext the the context is important
here and so is the language that the
Home Secretary and others refer to the
UK being swamped by refugees it's an
outrage as much as it is totally and
utterly inaccurate the United Kingdom
ranks in a league table of European
countries 20th when it comes to those
per capita taking refugees and 20th
as many as France takes a quarter as
many as Germany takes now
the fact that the bogus premise on which
this bill is based
um is set out and obvious something that
you know intelligent members opposite of
which they all are I'm sure understand
and yet still keep promulgating this
nonsense nevertheless the language has
consequences do you remember the
opposite not realize that the far-right
protesters stood out on the pavement
screaming abuse as some terrified person
fleeing persecution waiting simply an
assessment is and it is caused in no
small part by the fact that the
incendiary language that is used by
politicians and people in the media that
is outrageous exactly and I am delighted
to give way
delighted that The Honorable gentleman
has given away as well does he not
realize that perhaps we are in this
situation because the left-wing
supporting lawyers who have taken us
this point where where when I knock on
the door of my constituent they say who
is running this country the government
us who voted you in or the left wing
supporting lawyers and actually this is
why we've got here because we have
left-win extremists who are trying to
stop Lo our democracy from happening
okay well I mean thank you for
articulating the case very clearly
um and yeah when all said and done so
why have we got a problem given that
I've set out irrefutable numbers really
in terms of where we are in the world in
Europe in terms of the number of Asylum
Seekers we receive on our Shores much
less than most European countries much
less than many smaller European
countries and absolute blinking Frank
action compared to the likes of Lebanon
for instance but nevertheless we have a
problem why have we got a problem
because the home office is dysfunctional
that's why we have a problem what is
outraged the reason why there are people
sat in hotels and hostels being jeered
up from the outside by right-wing
protesters wound up by people who've
used intemperate language if I'm being
generous on the other side why are there
so many people in there because the
system is broken we are not swamped by
refugees we have a system an asylum
system run by an incompetent government
and therefore and what is the most maybe
the most morally outrageous thing about
this whole debate is that these people
whether they are genuine Asylum Seekers
or not we won't know unless we Bloom and
well assess them whether they are as
genuine as I'm Seekers or not
they are being blamed for the
government's incompetence what a moral
outrage there is of course a case for
making changes in the law and all the
rest of it I don't believe in open
borders what the government is proposing
is uncontrollable borders and I will
come to that in a moment so languages
have language has consequences and we
should be careful how we use it but I'm
happy to give way
I'm The Honorable gentleman for giving
away one of the things that we heard as
members of the home Affairs select
committee from Dan Omani the clandestine
Channel threat Commander was that almost
zero of the arrivals via small boats
have any identifying documents and they
do that on the direction of the people's
Smugglers because they're encouraged to
dispense with all as he termed IT pocket
litter meaning passports phones SIM
cards on the basis that it will confuse
the home office and make it impossible
to for them to tell who were the genuine
Asylum Seekers from those who were not
do you not agree that one of the
problems the home office has is that it
is confronted with people who cannot
prove who they are and is it not that
and the direction of the people
Smugglers that rather than government
incompetence so there's the root of this
issue
in which case you would propose a bill
that tried to actually stop the boats
and undermine undermine and undermine
and undermine well I'm trying to answer
her first point I'll hand her a first
point then
Roger
you know to shutting her out if you
actually want if she actually wanted to
deal with the issue that she articulated
just now then she would do something
that undermined the the business case
the people Smugglers she's not doing so
of course these people are doing what
they're guided to do but yeah I'm happy
to take other interventions Iris
The Honorable gentleman is challenging
the government to pass legislation that
requires I think the arrivals to produce
documents something that the last Labor
Government tried in 2004 with the Asylum
and immigration treatment of claimants
act which made a claim of Asylum
contingent upon providing adequate
documents I don't know what's happened
to that legislation perhaps the front
bench Can illuminate us when they close
tonight but the truth is that successive
governments have tried to require the
provision of identification documents
but we find ourselves in a position 20
years later where we still have people
arriving without them and they get given
asylum on the basis of what the home
office can't prove if Tuesday
appreciate her intervention and if she
really wanted to achieve that she'd
support safe and legal Roots which I'll
come to in a moment because that's the
way you tackle that's the way you tackle
that but the simple the simple fact is
we all dealing with this this is a
political issue why because the
government failed to keep control of the
Asylum process it doesn't trust its own
process I I believe in assessing people
to see whether they are genuine Asylum
Seekers or not and then returning them
if they're not I want a system that is
fair and tough we have a government
proposing a system which is unfair and
weak what an outrage that those people
um yeah happy to give away I'm very
grateful to the right honorable
gentleman it's making a really important
point but we also need to have a system
that is timely and doesn't leave people
hanging on for years and years and years
and yet we have a government that says
it's cut the Battle of by 50 when the UK
statistics Authority then say it's
actually increased on this government's
watch by
777 we can't have an honest debate when
the statistics are skewed so
incorrectly and and you know is it very
easy to make the kind of case the
government's making when it's all
faceless people I'm at a um uh an Afghan
citizen uh in my friend and neighbor the
member for Barrows constituency
um just a couple of months ago this man
have been waiting 13 months to have his
case heard we'd left this guy behind
this guy been an interpreter for the
British forces in the in Afghanistan and
we left it behind 13 months a wife and
two children here in hiding back in
Afghanistan waiting and rotting that is
not the fact that we don't have this
bill that is the fact down to the fact
we have a government that is incompetent
and and uncaring about those people who
have served our country served our
country who we have let down badly I
will take one more uh intervention yeah
it isn't um an obvious fail a sign of
the government's failure that only 22
Afghan citizens have now been resettled
after the UK and re uh resettlement
scheme when there are thousands of
getting in danger 22 out of thousands
yeah well yes and thank you I think my
honorable friend for making that really
important and Powerful point I'm gonna
try and make some progress here because
I know other people want to to intervene
but let's just deal with another of the
dozy charges that we get back those of
us who think that this bill is at best
mistaken and it's the idea that well why
would we want to come here escaping from
war-torn France why don't they saying
say France France isn't a dangerous
country I can make some quips about the
current state of play over there at the
moment but I but I won't and but let's
just remember this at 86 of people
fleeing their homes uh go to the
neighboring country and they stay there
they stay there so we took about 14 of
the world refugees go beyond the
neighboring country a fraction come to
Europe and in place uh honorable members
opposite need a geography lesson we are
the end of the line right we're on the
other side of the channel we're far west
of Europe so we are the people they get
to the last we've already established
that France takes three times more
refugees than we do this is the last one
please make it gone yes I thank the
honorable
on the question about figures this is
part of the bogus nonsense of being
sprouted by the government when the
Secretary of State goes on television
saying that a hundred million people are
making their way to the United Kingdom
and then somebody else went on the
television saying is about billion
people making their way to the United
Kingdom yes I mean and so there are
Arguments for you know stricter or less
strict
measures when it comes to dealing with
migration and Asylum uh and those things
are important to discuss but it doesn't
help when we have bogus and nonsense
figures you know spouted from in this
place sometimes which just uh creates
more heat and no light but let's just
deal with the charge that of course
France is a safe place they shouldn't be
allowed to come here and they should
just stay there France could say that to
Italy and spay I'm not going to now
sorry I'm taking loads of interventions
and I'm testing everyone's patience it's
11 minutes in and so France could say
the same to Italy or to Spain and then
Italy and Spain could say stay in the
sea what we're seeing now is an attempt
to undermine Britain's part in the globe
I we were told by some people opposite
that we're leaving the European Union
not Europe we would be part of a Glo
will be a global Britain now but
ignoring for a moment the moral uh
obligations that we have to people
seeking Sanctuary let's remember what
message this gives to our neighbors our
friends our allies around Europe and
elsewhere if we unilaterally decide that
we're no longer going to play that game
it undermines our soft power it
undermines our sovereignty significantly
which is why news Force 3 is important
and I would wish to support that because
that is about setting the Target and
giving a clear sense of Britain stepping
up the plate and being part of the
global operation I think the whole bill
fails to understand the horrors that
people have been through when we talk
about deterrence if people have left
Sudan or Eritrea they have gone through
Libya I would ask a member's opposite
just to spend a moment or two
researching what it is like for a
refugee passing from the Hall of Africa
for example example through Libya what
are their experiences and then crossing
the Mediterranean and then you tell them
that it's scary and unpleasant and we're
not going to treat you very nicely
across the channel it is nothing
compared to their experiences Crossing
through Libya so I would ask members to
inform themselves of that in particular
this is clearly not a bill aimed to
tackle at tackling the criminal gangs
Dame Eleanor because the SIM
the criminal gangs business model will
still be alive and well why because you
can arrive on these Shores and then not
claim Asylum you go under the radar and
what that does is it fuels modern
slavery it means more people exploited
especially women and girls and it also
it also fuels criminality so there's no
question whatsoever that this bill will
do anything to tackle the business model
of those gangs Italy isn't intended to
which is another outrage this is indeed
a traffickers charter it will therefore
lead to more deaths in the channel it is
a recipe for uncontrollable borders
because there will be nobody applying
for Asylum they will just slip under the
radar and if they've done an impact
assessment they would know that maybe
they have and haven't shared it with us
it's simple fact that we need safe and
legal routes if you're from Ukraine
Afghanistan Syria Hong Kong you stand a
chance of one kind or another of being
able to have a safe route to the United
Kingdom but if you are a young Christian
man seeking to avoid being conscripted
in Eritrea if you are a woman seeking
Sanctuary from Iran if you are a person
of a religious minority from Sudan then
you have no chance of getting here
whatsoever that is morally outrageous
and it is turning our backs and our
International and long held and
long-held
principles and obligations and that is
why new Clause 6 is so important because
what it does you call say twitch with
your permission we would formally wish
to push to a vote tonight new Clause 6
Ring fences Asylum Seekers from those
countries which already have an 80 plus
grant rate places like Sudan Eritrea and
Iran as a pilot scheme for 12 months
measured small not all that ambitious
just to give the government the
opportunity to not be duplicit about
that duplicitous about this to be able
to say that yes we are providing at
least an experimental and evidence base
um a safe route so I would urge the
government to accept that and otherwise
we would seek to divide the house you
Clause four uh talked about humanitarian
travel permit nuclear 7 Refugee family
reunion because if this government wants
to seriously make the case that it is
going to undermine the business case of
the people traffickers evil though they
absolutely are they will fail to do so
unless they provide meaningful tangible
credible uh safe and legal Roots which
currently don't exist and these
amendments allow them the opportunity to
do that and if the government will not
accept these amendments then they will
prove that they don't actually have a
plan to stop the boats just to get into
the gutter and Grub for votes and let's
be fair I think they have if I'm being
fair they have misjudged those who seek
Sanctuary here you see I've met many of
them been to Calais and other places and
you interrogate why people would choose
to come to the United Kingdom and The
Honorable member my friend from devises
that set out many of those reasons what
I've never discussed covered is any of
those people who've ever heard of the
National Health Service or of our
benefit system so the lie that somehow
they're coming over here to sponge
offers or to threaten us is just that it
is simply untrue but they have heard of
something they've heard of a Britain
where it is safe where you can raise
your children where you can be who you
are or have whatever Faith you may be
whatever political views you may have
and to be able to raise your family feed
your family and to do so in safety and
I'll tell you what I cannot imagine
something that makes me more proud than
that being the reputation of this
country and no matter as small-minded
attempts to change the law by this here
today gone tomorrow Tory government will
Dent that long held and proud reputation
because I think they have also not just
misjudged the Asylum Seekers they've
misjudged Britain too let me tell you a
story about my constituency and then I
will shut up because let's be honest the
late district is not the most diverse
part of the United Kingdom and yet and
yet in August 1945 half of the children
who survived the death camps including
Auschwitz came to Windermere to be
rehabilitated to start their life afresh
because that is who we really are that
is who Britain really is and we should
be proud of that so let us absolutely
stop the boats the lenders do so in a
way which actually makes sense which is
neither dozy nor dangerous thank you
so John Hayes
sorry thank you
all right I'm not used to to addressing
you in committee uh uh David now
um now it is conventional this place to
uh say that it's a delight a joy to
follow a speaker before you uh and uh
generally one does that as a matter of
convention but I am always pleased to
follow the honorable gentleman the
rightful gentleman for uh westmin and
Lonsdale although I disagree with almost
everything he said I know that he speaks
with integrity and I know that he
believes in his heart uh what he said
today if I have to take to tell him
that his Purity if I can put it in those
terms he's absolute Christian dignity
has got the better of his reason in
respect of this issue for his
constituents like mine expect this house
to be where power lies because it is
this house which is answerable to them
we are we owe our political legitimacy
to our relationship with the very people
who described in his constituency as I
do to those in mind and when other
powers
in other places
supersede the authority of this house in
the way that the European uh judges did
when the planes stopped were held up
that held those who were going to be
sent around her
our constituents feel not only
frustrated
but they feel let down let down because
they see the will of this house the will
of our government being impeded
being indeed frustrated by those
overseas Powers so my and I I happily
wait for the honorable lady who is
deeply confused about the difference
between treaty law and statute perhaps
you can explain that
yes
I thank the thank you Damon Melina
I want to perhaps bring your mind to the
fact but in the 1970s in this country a
conservative government had passed
legislation saying that for married
women or even women coming to this
country they had to go through a
virginity test that was challenged and
it was the European court on human
rights which actually overturned that
particular piece of British legislation
are you really telling me that you think
that legislation is correct I think the
audibility means The Honorable gentleman
not you
really telling me that he thinks that
that decision by the European court on
human rights was wrong
well I never I never knowingly defend
the heath government and so I'm not
gonna I'm so so they're not going to
take many any credit or connection with
its measures indeed it was Edward Heath
who uh uh against the interest of the
British people took us into the European
Union in the first place in the very
first she described so so I'm not going
to go down that road and it's not
relevant to the Amendments before us uh
Jane Eleanor in any case so I I want to
address in the spirit that I've just
outlined the significance of the uh
legislation before us and the Amendments
which we're debating in the context the
government's determination to not only
tackle the issue of immigration per se
but in particular to deal with illegal
immigration in the form of boats
arriving in Dover and just as we won the
referendum campaign with a simple slogan
take that control we will it seems to me
when this argument with a similar simple
slope so slogan stop the votes and I
were happening away to my honorable
friend was great Authority in all
matters of this guy I'm very grateful to
my right honorable friend speaking as an
immigrant to this country myself when I
arrived in October 1978 bowled Away by
the hospitality and kindness that I came
across when I came to this country for
the first time will he recognize that in
order to maintain that sense of Welcome
from the British people two Outsiders
coming to the United Kingdom we've got
to deal with the illegal aspects of this
migration and that's why it's so
important to support the city yeah well
my honorable found his righteousness his
comments reflect the remarks of The
Honorable John from Western Lonsdale but
that spirit that character that
reputation which Britain enjoys depends
on both lawfulness and propriety it's
not unreasonable to say that our
generosity should be defined by AI
proper rules proper standards and when
my honorable friend challenged The
Honorable Jennifer and spoke immediately
before me on this issue of people not
bringing documents I was left to wonder
as others may have been why on Earth if
you were a legitimate Asylum Seeker if
you were
uh pleased to come here on the basis The
Honorable judgments said why would you
want
to discard the documents that will prove
your case why would you do that and
that's what my constituents that's the
kind of question my constitutions will
ask me and I have to conclude that many
of the people disguise their identity
discard their documents not because they
want to make it more straightforward for
the home office to deal with their claim
because clearly it wouldn't make it more
straightforward because they have
something to hide and we shouldn't well
before The Honorable lady intervenes
I'll just remind her and the front bench
and my little friend of this that last
year 33 percent of the people arrived on
those small boats were from Albania from
Albania
33 last year that number's now fallen
because the government have done
something about it so much for the
inefficient ministers and in physician
home office they've dealt with the
Albanian issue as they will now deal
with this issue with equal alacrity and
skill I give way I thank you for giving
me Fair he may have misread the
statistics because
it stands who are the 33 percent of
arrivals and in October to December 2022
only nine percent of small boat arrivals
were Albanian but I wanted to follow up
small matter that perhaps perhaps just
as a general principle we shouldn't try
and do processing ourselves in this
parliamentary chamber what we should
look at is the evidence and so I just
wonder if the member could tell us
because many of us who deal with those
people seeking Asylum have had this very
conversation about why papers may be
missing and been told very clearly that
it is the traffickers who tell people to
tear up their papers and remove them
because it makes it easier for the
traffickers so can he tell us when was
the last time he spoke to somebody who
came by an irregular route to the UK and
who didn't have their paperwork and what
he was told by them tell us about the
evidence he has of actually working with
these people and understanding the
pressures they're under and for many
arguments in this place by anecdote but
I prefer and and you know sometimes
sometimes with undue success I have to
say
um uh but I'm not going to be drawn into
an anecdotal debate about this issue
because I want to address the issue in a
rather more serious way and I don't mean
to disparage her uh of course uh Dame
Eleanor so in addressing amendments one
three three one three four in the name
of the member for stone and one three
one of the name member for devises and
indeed 132 the name my right honorable
friend the member of Southeast
Middlesbrough I want to be clear about
the purpose of this bill and why these
amendments make sense
the purpose of the bill is to deal with
this matter as definitively as it can
reasonably be addressed purpose of this
bill is through Titan the arrangements
uh in respect of illegal immigration and
the Amendments strengthen that aim our
job it seems to me is to uh in uh
against the backdrop where people are
arriving in small boats and breaching
our borders within punity to
re-establish the sovereignty of this
country the Integrity of our borders and
to deliver legislation which does just
that these amendments
are designed to do two things
the first to give more power to
government to achieve is objective
and the second is to limit
those opportunities which exist and we
know they will be taken to frustrate the
government's will and by the
government's will I emphasize
parliament's will parliament's will to
do more to deal with this matter now I
commend the uh the minister and the Home
Secretary for their work in bringing
this bill forward but I am absolutely
certain that the expectations that has
created the time that it absorbs the
opposition that it will undoubtedly
generate mean that if it fails and the
government is found wanting those of
them this help on this side of the house
will pay a heavy price
so the minister needs to know that we've
been down this road before with the
borders built of course we were told
that the borders bill would do the job
and I don't think ministers were
deceiving us they genuinely believe that
would be the case
and yet although we did exactly what
I've described you time and political
capital and change expectations raise
them indeed uh and brought about
opposition
we found that we couldn't achieve what
we wanted with the borders Bill and
we've needed additional legislation to
get to where we need to go we will not
be given
a third chance this is our second chance
to deal once and for all with a matter
of the boats arriving in Dover and the
these and I do use the word tired way I
think the Home Secretary described as
swarm of people coming here who know
that they're arriving illegally who know
they're breaking the law
for they know they have no papers and no
right to be here and therefore make a
nonsense of an immigration system which
must have integrity if it's to Garner
and maintain popular support of course
people enter and leave countries but
they need to do so legally it isn't too
much to make that simple statement is it
it isn't too much to expect that a
government maintains lawful control of
our borders and yet I hear constantly
from the other side of the chamber that
somehow that's militant that's
unreasonable that's extreme it's
anything about those things it is modest
it is moderate it is just it is virtuous
to have a system to have a system uh
which which means that people who come
here come here lawfully and the people
who are right here seeking Asylum are
dealt with properly that's a modest
aimed but it will be made more
achievable by the Amendments that I've
described the standard the name my
honorable and writable friends and I say
this to the minister and I say it given
that he is an old and trusted and good
friend
uh I hope when he sums up this debate he
will agree to enter into a dialogue with
those of us who's speaking for the
people
uh as we and we aim we claim no more
than that that we are the spokesman of
the hard-working patriotic lawful
majority of the people of this country
we've claim those no no greater applaud
it than that but in uh speaking for
those people that he will enter into a
dialogue with those of us who have
tables these amendments and supported
them
with the aim of improving the bill
of doing his work with him and for him
and so honoring the pledge that the
Prime Minister the Home Secretary of
Maine to the people of this country
honoring that pledge because it's the
right thing to do it's the just thing to
do it's indeed the veterans thing today
yeah
Cherry
it's a pleasure to see you in the chair
today
um
it is convention to see that it's a
pleasure to follow the previous speaker
um I find it hard to say that because I
cannot really agree with anything that
he said and I find it an extraordinary
proposition that it is and I use his
words virtuous
and just
for the United Kingdom to pass
legislation that is in reach of our
International obligations these are not
obligations that have been imposed upon
us
from above they are obligations to which
we freely signed up and if the
government and the members opposite
don't like these obligations to which
they freely signed up they should have
the coverage of their convictions and
they should join their Chums in Russia
and Belarus as non-signometries to the
European convention human rights
they don't like it but it's true these
are the other two countries in Europe
who cannot live with the obligations in
the European convention on human rights
now another point to preliminary point I
want to make before I go any further the
right honorable gentleman who spoke
before me does not speak for my
constituents he does not speak for the
people of Edinburgh Southwest I can tell
him from my mailbox on my con
conversations with constituents he does
not speak for them and he does not speak
for voters in Scotland either we're
proud of our International obligations
and we would like to remain a signatory
to the European convention on human
rights and indeed Demi underlying
there's very widespread concern about
this bill and it's not just Lefty
lawyers it's the honorable lady said
earlier I've been a lawyer for many many
many years and no I won't at this stage
I want to develop my point I've been a
lawyer for many many years and it pains
me to say because I am a lefty lawyer
but if the honorable lady knew much
about about the legal profession she
would know that most lawyers are
actually not not left yet
however however what most lawyer what
most lawyers have in contrast to the
members opposite who've spoken so far
today yeah is that they have a respect
for the rule of law that's right and
they have a respect for in for legal
obligations freely entered into nobody
took the hand of the United Kingdom and
forced it to sign in the convention we
did it freely of our own volition and I
repeat that if members opposite don't
like the obligations under it any longer
because it occasionally throws up
results that they don't like then they
should have the courage of their
convictions and leave it
and I want to develop my point I will
take some interventions in a minute
because I don't want to take up too much
time and I'm rising mainly to speak to
Amendment
122 which is in my name and also to lend
my support to the Amendments tabled on
behalf of the Scottish national Party by
my honorable friend uh the member for
Glasgow Central and also to add my
support to the excellent and forensic
points made us always by my honorable
friend the member for cumbernauld
Kilsyth and Kirk until the East and I
think it's a great pity uh day Milner
that while he was speaking the
government Minister chose to take no
notes because I think he made some very
good points and it would be really nice
to hear why the government disagree with
the points that he made but I think at
the end of six hours debate it's going
to be difficult for the minister to
answer those points not having paid any
attention to them or made any notes of
them now I've tabled Amendment 122 in my
name in my capacity as chair of the
joint committee on human rights and I'm
very grateful to the honor honorable
members who've lent their support to
that Amendment I'm not going to move it
today because the committee has only
just commenced its legal scrutiny of
this bill not because we're not because
we're dragging our feet but because it's
been bounced on us with such short
notice we've got very little time in
which to do that but we do hope to
report before the bills finished its
passage in the Lords and at that point I
hope we'll be able to recommend some
detailed amendments but I've tabled this
amendment today very much as a probing
Amendment and also to give me the
opportunity to try and explain to the
government benches the legal basis of
our obligations to obey the interim
measures of the European Court of Human
Rights because an awful lot of frankly
what we call mints in Scotland that's a
technical legal term a lot of mints has
been spoken about that so far but but I
also want to just as a preliminary point
to to stress the white spread opposition
to this bill you know from our own
equalities and Human Rights Commission
have severe concerns about this bill's
impact on our International legal
obligations the Scottish Human Rights
Commission have severe concerns about
its impact on our International legal
obligations the Council of Europe have
severe
concerns about its impact on our legal
obligations and the unhcr have severe
concerns about it so do the law
societies of England and Wales and the
Law Society of Scotland so do many other
uh very respectable Civil Society
organizations and so do many of our
constituents and I mentioned my own
constituents in Edinburgh Southwest over
the weekend I received a number of
letters from primary seven pupils at Ox
games primary school in my constituency
and I just want to tell you what the
gist of their letters were and it's this
they said we are a wealthy nation and
The Honorable member for devisers who's
no longer in his place referred to the
United Kingdom as a wealthy country it's
not a country it's a union of Nations
but these young people in my
constituency said we are a wealthy
Nation we need to do more to help
refugees and other honorable members
have made the point that the majority of
displaced people in this world just go
to the country next door it's only a
very tiny fraction who comes to the
United Kingdom looking for our help and
I think what these young people were
trying to say was that we do have a
moral obligation I think these young
people were also making the point that
human rights are Universal and I think
the government need to remember that
this bill seeks to carve out certain
categories of people
for who to whom human rights will not be
applicable in the same way as they are
to me and and my constituents and that
is simply wrong
now Amendment 122 deals with clause 49.
and um purpose of my amendment is to
ensure that we recognize that the United
Kingdom is bound to comply with interim
measures issued by the European Court of
Human Rights and to ensure that any
regulations made under Clause 49 don't
undermine that principle and it's an
amendment which is consistent with
recommendations unanimous
recommendations made by The Joint
Committee on human rights when we
reported on a similar provision in the
Bill of Rights bill and I want to set
out day my owner because I think it's
very important the legal basis upon
which the United Kingdom is bound to
comply with these interim measures
and I'm going to just take a couple of
minutes to do that
um
under rule 39 of the rules of the
European court and human rights the
court May indicate interim measures to
any state party so not just the United
Kingdom any state that's freely signed
up to the convention now they're usually
sought in connection with immigration
removal or extradition cases and they
amount to a requirement that the removal
or extradition be suspended not stopped
but just suspended until the case has
been fully examined and case law from
the court has established that requests
for interim measures are granted only
exceptionally where applicants would
otherwise face a real risk of serious
and reverse and irreversible harm
they are granted from time to time
against the United Kingdom but in fact
it very rarely and if you look at the
year 2021 the European Court of Human
Rights received 1020 requests for
interim measures and granted 625 of
those that was across the Council of
Europe but in respect of the United
Kingdom between 2019 and 2021
rule 39 interim measures were applied
for in 880 cases against the UK but
granted in just seven of those cases
just seven out of 180 applications so
writing a coach in horses through our in
are freely entered into International
legal obligations and respective interim
measures is really taking a hammer to
crack a knot now interim measures appear
in the rules of the Court rather than in
the convention itself which has led some
commentators including some members
opposite to argue that the UK is not
bound to comply with them particularly
because article 46 of the convention
which concerns The Binding force and
execution of judgments only commits the
UK to abide by final judgments of the
court and doesn't mention interim
measures
however
the the grand chamber of the court has
held that a failure to comply with
interim measures amounts to a violation
of article 34 of the convention under
which the high Contracting parties
Undertake and I quote not to hinder in
any way the effective exercise of the
right of applicants to bring their
claims before the court so the court
itself has said that a failure to comply
with interim measures is a breach of of
article 34 of the convention now we all
know that the reason why the
government's so exercised about this
issue is because interim measures were
indicated by the European Court in
relation to the government's attempts to
remove Asylum Seekers to Rwanda despite
the domestic courts not granting an
injunction and clearly this has caused
severe concern in
um the government because the interim
measures were issued without the United
Kingdom having made submit missions uh
having a chance to be heard and without
a reasoned judgment
and I do think if there if there are
good faith and meaningful negotiations
going on between the United Kingdom and
the council at the moment uh I hope it
would be discussed that in future there
might be an opportunity for the UK to be
heard before an interim measure is
granted those who are lawyers in the
chamber will know that frequently
governments and other big bodies who are
often sued Lodge with the courts and the
English and Welsh system or the Scottish
system what we call a caveat so that if
anyone applies for an interim order
against them they get the right to be
heard and I think that would be a
reasonable reform of the Strasbourg
system but the mere absence of that
provision at the moment would not
justify us ignoring the obligations that
we've signed up to and the convention
we've signed up to as interpreted by the
court and anyone who in the chamber
who's used to dealing with litigation
will know the interim measures both
interim injunctions in England and
instrumental dicks in Scotland are
frequently granted without the other
party being heard because they are
interim measures to preserve the status
quo while a lasting a decision is made
and
if you are looking at being removed from
this country having come here seeking
Sanctuary being removed to Rwanda
then an interim measure painting the
full determination of the impact it
might have upon you is actually rather
important
for example
LGBT LGBT people were mentioned earlier
by my honorable friend there are no
anti-discrimination laws
in Rwanda protecting same-sex Attractive
people or transgender people you can be
discriminated against refused
accommodation refused a job etc etc etc
on the basis of your sexuality or your
gender identity in Rwandan I think we
are all agreed something we can all
agree across the United Kingdom is that
is not acceptable and as my honorable
friend said imagine the position of
somebody fleeing the regime in Uganda
where even to State your sexuality or
your gender identity is now unlawful
coming here
seeking sanctuary and then facing being
deported to Rwanda I think they might be
very grateful for interim measures to be
granted while their human rights were
fully explored so I'm not actually going
to to move this amendment today but I
think it's really important that we have
we conduct ourselves in this Parliament
on the basis of a proper understanding
of the legal position rather than
populist slogans
and I want to just say something about
uh sovereignty because
um some tempts to call them my honorable
friend who is an expert on the
sovereignty of a this Parliament is of
course when he talks about sovereignty
he talks about what is a very
distinctively English concept
um the notion uh that Parliament has
unlimited sovereignty is a distinctively
English principle that really has no
counterpart
in Scottish constitutional law I will
give way in a moment just want to
develop my I just want to develop my
point and then I'll give waiting because
I know we've been arguing about this for
years but I think it's a it's an
important point to make because it's
sometimes assumed that this Parliament
just took on the character of the
English Constitution when it unified
with the Scottish Parliament and perhaps
it's worth just considering that there
are other Notions of sovereignty in my
country the people are sovereign not the
Parliament and they can choose to share
their sovereignty with for example the
Edinburgh Parliament with for example
this Parliament and for example with
other International
institutions so this endless obsessing
about the sovereignty of parliament I
don't think is particularly helpful and
where I really disagree with the right
honorable gentleman isn't this I think
the Human Rights Act was in fact a very
elegant solution
to to fulfilling our rights under the
convention while also respecting the
sovereignty of this Parliament and I'll
give away to him on that point
is The Honorable Lady by saying that the
sovereignty of the United Kingdom
Parliament is in the United Kingdom part
I know she'd really quite like to leave
it but on the other hand she is bound by
it and the withdrawal agreement act 2020
specifies quite clearly that the
sovereignty is guaranteed
Joanna Jerry it was our the union
between Scotland and England was freely
entered into I know that some people are
under the misapprehension that now it's
some sort of Hotel California situation
where you can check out but you can't
leave but I think you know freely that
is really a fundamental misunderstanding
of the nature of uh the union and uh my
the views I'm expounding about
sovereignty are not just my eccentric
views the reviews that have been
expounded by many very well respected
Scottish jurists as the writer honorable
a gentleman knows so I just think it's
worth sometimes taking a step back I
think sometimes with all due respect to
my some of my English friends they get a
bit hysterical about parliamentary
sovereignty part sovereignty can can be
shared
and ultimately I believe that
sovereignty lies with the people and I
think I'll just leave it at that point
thank you
Laura Faris
thank you very much Dave Eleanor um
it is actually genuinely a pleasure to
follow the member for Edinburgh South
West and I'm going to try and avoid too
much mints in my own speech but continue
in the respectful tone that she just
struck
I'd like to take the heat a little bit
out of this debate and say I think that
the British people would recognize in
the United Kingdom a country that has
honored its commitment since the uh
since the launch of the 1951 Refugee
convention to offer Sanctuary to those
with a well-founded fear of persecution
and the record of the last seven years
were close to half a million people have
been granted asylum on humanitarian
grounds Bear's testimony to that now I
think they would also recognize that
there are peculiar and unique problems
that have Arisen with the small boats
Crossings five years ago in 2018 300
people made that Journey last year it
was 45
000 of those 80 percent were men aged
between 18 and 40 all of them had paid a
people Smuggler all of them had the
physical strength and the wherewithal to
make a journey across Continental Europe
and in through the small boat and we
know that a third of them arriving last
year were our Albanian and I just want
to read what Don Omani told the home
Affairs select committee I see the chair
is in her place when he appeared before
you last October and I'm quoting
verbaton
he said about the Albanian arrivals the
rise has been exponential and we think
that that is in the main due to the fact
that Albanian criminal gangs have gained
a foothold in the north of France and
have been facilitating very large
numbers of migrants whatever sort of
criminality you can think of there are
Albanian gangs dominating in this
country be it drug smuggling human
trafficking guns prostitution so a lot
of the Albanian migrants are not
actually interested in seeing their
claim through we will typically put them
up in a hotel for a couple of days and
then they disappear into the underworld
now that unique and specific problem
requires a unique and specific answer I
think we all agree on safe and legal
routes I won't improve on the remarks
made by the member for East Worthing and
show them that it was a powerful speech
and I think I heard from the front bench
for the first time tonight actually that
the labor party is also endorsing quotas
which is part of this bill and we agree
with that if my intervention earlier
wasn't wasn't clear enough what I'm
simply saying is that Harvey Redgrave
writing for the Tony Blair Institute in
a really thoughtful piece actually last
July was talking about safe and legal
routes out of country Rites of appeal
quotas but he was also talking about an
absolute prohibition on small boat
arrivals and that really is the issue in
this legislation where we're having a
dispute now actually Dem Elena I Rise to
speak in response to new Clauses 131 and
132 to conservative Clauses and it's
very unusual actually they're both in
this place is very unusual for me to
speak in response to yes I will be way
sorry for the honorable lady moves on
I'm grateful for a giving away of course
what many countries do is have a cat per
se on immigration an Australia
Parliament debates an annual car when
David Cameron and Jules Osborne were
running the conservative party and The
Honorable member at the right one were
made in Heaven's Home Secretary we said
that should be tens of thousands perhaps
that's what we should go back to
well I think it is it is certainly true
that the promise which is inherent in
the refugee invention which is an offer
to the World At Large as but you know
which was conceived in an era pre
EasyJet pre people going on holiday to
any country pre-mass migration certainly
requires a different uh lens to look
through it in the year 2023 and many of
our International partners are now
talking in this way and we may have to
have a debate on that in a different
occasion where we talk about that issue
more broadly but responding to the
I'm just gonna make a tiny bit of
progress because I haven't really
started and there's not that much time
I'm going to respond to new Clauses 131
132 and together they do something
slightly different but they have the
same effect I'll look at you and I hope
that my honorable friend for divisors
won't be offended if he has to look at
my back but one of them excludes the
jurisdiction of the European Court of
Human Rights and the second Clause seeks
to disapply the relevant sections of the
human rights act insofar as they may be
relevant to decisions that are taken in
this bill and I want to say at the
outset I understand the impulse that has
brought vulnerable friend here and that
is the frustration with the exercise of
the rule 39 uh injunctive relief
decision in July which the horrible lady
covered so well uh in Her speech but she
will know as well as I do and she I
think she even said this rule 39 is not
an inherent part of the European
convention on human rights she said in
her speech it is a rule of the Court
uh the decision was taken by a single
judge alone she's quite right to point
out that that is common and standard and
injunctive proceedings but it is
nonetheless true that it is somewhat
surprising to see that matter go through
the eyes of the high court the court of
appeal here finally the Supreme Court
and then be overturned by a decision of
a single judge in Europe and and I
simply just say this we don't even know
who that judge was but we know that Tim
Ike who is our own British judge who
sits on the European court has never
even about I say there's an absolute
deference to his Brilliance and of
course I'm not criticizing him but it is
standard for the European Court of Human
Rights but he has never sat as a high
court judge he's a barrister and
therefore it is odd to see our own
Supreme Court some of the most brilliant
justices in the world being overruled by
somebody as a match just as a Court rule
uh on who is probably not of their
status and I think that is a true
statement
we because I also went on
to uh to see this that in the case of
Palladia against Moldova the grand
chamber held that a failure to comply
with interim measures amounts to a
violation of article 34 of the
convention because the high Contracting
parties have undertaken not to hinder in
any way the effect of exercise with the
right of applicants to bring their
claims for the court so whereas it was
originally in the rules of Court the
grand chamber have now said that failure
to temper that to comply with that would
be a violation of article 34 of the
convention
her Point him and we are obviously
adhering to that but as a rule of the
court if I can just perhaps move on a
bit from this I've been very glad to
read recently
um
whether it was a press release or a
Twist I can't recall but it was it was
from the Home Secretary herself saying
that she was very glad that constructive
talks were now taking place between
representatives of the British
government and members of the European
court on human rights focused on
resolving that issue I say that's good
because it should actually I think be
possible to resolve that issue since it
is a rule of the Court rather than a
principle of human rights and I hope we
can move on from there but if I may say
with great respect I do not accept that
that decision in itself uh justifies
these amendments and I think both of the
the two amendments are weak for both
legal and constitutional reasons and
I'll set out why first of all my
honorable friendly member from
Middlesbrough the samurai Ace Cleveland
Middle for South and East Cleveland
sorry
um said that he relied on a paper that
had been written for policy exchange by
Richard deakins and Sir Stephen law I I
do challenge the expertise of both of
those people I question it and they both
come one of them certainly has contacted
me in the past neither of them are
actual practitioners and I do think it
shows in their writing that they're not
regularly in court and they seem to get
I will in a moment I'm just going to
make my points
so the first uh element of the amendment
which seeks to exclude the operation of
the Human Rights Act the only realistic
basis which an arrival somebody arriving
by a small boat could challenge their
removal to a safe Third Country under
the Human Rights Act would either be
relying on Article 2 or article 3 of the
European convention that is the right to
life or not to have one's life
endangered and the right to freedom from
torture
however it is important to note that
that would not be the starting point for
this kind of claim the starting point in
our domestic courts would be article 33
of the refugee convention the
non-reformant principle it's not just
there in the refugee convention it's a
principle at common law it's a principle
that is part of our customary
international law so even if you abolish
the Human Rights Act in so far as it
applied to these cases you would still
have the same argument being Advanced
that the person could not be sent to a
country because of a fear of persecution
and indeed I thought I'll come come to
you in a moment I'm sorry but the
authors actually the member for
Middlesbrough South the member for
devises the member from Stoke-on-Trent
wrote an article in cornholm today and
they said an endorsed individuals will
not be removed if they're medically
unfit to fly or would face persecution
in their destination destination country
that's the non-reformant principle which
is absolutely at the heart of the
Refugee convention and one of the things
which shows I think that there isn't
expertise in this is it the same
principle ripples through the common law
the refugee convention the European
convention on human rights and it
applies across the board it's even set
out in terms in this legislation so as I
say it would be pointless to derogate
from the human rights act on this
because the principle that protects
people from persecution is so embedded
in any event
The Honorable lady that professor eakins
and Sir Stephen laws respectively just
in case other members of the house don't
know this one is a professor of law in
Oxford University and the other one is
former first parliamentary Council and
I'd rather think that that's rather a
good credential compared to some of the
views of what I've described as ordinary
barristers
my point no disrespect is intended but
it's just clear that they're not
frequently in court arguing these cases
because if they were they would know the
way that the law the law ran and I'm
just going to go a little bit further in
my in my speech the second point is that
yes I know myself and The Honorable lady
don't agree about a lot of things but I
believe she does have an expertise in
this area that's correct isn't it as a
barrister The Honorable lady has an
expertise in this area and has practiced
in this area so I think you know perhaps
I would suggest to her her friends that
her views deserve a degree of respect on
this side of the house the MP who's most
recently been in the immigration
tribunals and so I have an idea but I'm
not it isn't my principal practice area
but I will just take one other point
the other thing that I think is relevant
is that Parliament has in the past
successfully recalibrated the
interpretation of the convention changed
the way it's interpreted and have no
difficulty with that now we know that
this bill already takes a number of
Novel steps which I think are necessary
in relation to established law first of
all it creates an absolute duty of
removal on the Home Secretary and that
applies irrespective of Any Human Rights
claim with the exception of the
non-reform principle
it also expands powers of immigration
detention granting the Secretary of
State a power to determine the period
that is reasonably necessary in some
ways overriding established hardial
Singh principles and thirdly it limits
the rights of appeal the individual has
a right of appeal but that's capped at
one now in my very respectful submission
the government must have the opportunity
to see these Clauses enacted because I
believe that they will be upheld by the
European Court of Human Rights I think
back to 2012 when the coalition
government changed the immigration rules
in relation to the issue of the
deportation of foreign National
offenders and the application of article
8 which is the right to respect for
private and family life
Parliament took the view that that was
being interpreted too often in favor of
the former criminal ex-convict and as a
result it set new rules in the
established immigration rules at section
398 onwards which uh made it clear that
there were very limited circumstances in
which article 8 should be engaged it
made clear Parliament said in terms that
the balance should be struck in favor of
the overwhelming public interest in
deportation above any article eight
claim unless there were very compelling
circumstances to the country that was
upheld in successive Decisions by our
appeal courts beginning with MF Nigeria
in the court of appeal now that decision
by Parliament to basically circumscribe
the Ambit of articulate when it applied
to criminals Wars taken to the European
Court of human rights and for years
actually they wouldn't even hear the
issue at all but then in 2017 they did
in the case of nadidian I reminded
myself about how they approached that
case today and in fact the argument was
being made quite a compelling
um article argument the person had
arrived as a baby in the United Kingdom
had never been anywhere else the
offending was quite low level it was
sort of drug dealing rather than any
harm to the person and the and the
courts here had obviously said that he
must be deported to a country they'd
never been before he challenged the
European Court of Human Rights and the
and the European Court said no the
British government is absolutely
entitled to circumscribe the application
of article a in the way that it has on
his claim was rejected and so my simple
point is that you can do things in the
way the government is seeking to do in
this bill which may well be compatible
with the European Convention of Human
Rights and I have really struggled to
find any example of the Court
overturning primary legislation which is
what this is or constructing it in a way
that is disadvantageous to the member
State and I would just make one for at
one point the fact that so many MPS go
back to the prisoner voting case doesn't
actually enhance their their case that
that case is 20 years old and has been
reversed I accept without reservation
that that was wrongly decided I think it
was overreach but I've heard nothing
from these benches within the last 20
years that suggests that the court is
still making the same mistakes and I
think the absence of any again and we've
talked about the nationality and borders
Bill not being a success but that wasn't
because the European Court of Human
Rights said it was you know unlawful or
overreached it we simply uh we simply
concluded that it didn't work yet so for
those reasons I think the bill already
goes very far and I think it should be
given the chance to work through and I
will give away well this is a
fascinating thing a description of a
three-way deal with this one way is to
leave the conventional together which is
what I would favor and uh but that's not
what we're proposing or debating tonight
the second way is though is to have some
kind of notwithstanding uh claws of the
kind that's been proposed the Third Way
is to assume that through the
interpretation of the core of the will
of Parliament and government we will
have our way now the other really is
making a good case for the third but the
problem with that is placing a great
deal of Faith although she says she does
so on the basis of freshman on the court
to honor the will of this house and I'm
not sure that I've had the same degree
of faith and I recommend to her she
doesn't like Professor Ricans and so on
to look at the the Home Secretary when
she was attorney general's speech on the
interpretative matters she describes she
gave to Cambridge University
The Honorable lady sits down when
someone else is standing up
Laura Faris sorry sorry
um
uh just to come back on that I think it
is dangerous to conflate what I think
has been understood on these benches to
have been caught overreach in the
application of rule 39 with which I
agree with an over-enthusiasm of the
court to involve itself in primary
legislation which is what this is going
to be and I see no precedent for that
concern so I hope I can allay your fear
to some extent and then the final point
that I wanted to make is a yes I will
yes very grateful to my girlfriend for
giving away um is there another fourth
option uh to add to the list of our
right honorable friend from South
Holland and the Deep ends call me
old-fashioned if you will which is just
to make sure that his Majesty's
government ensures that we meet our
International obligations wherever they
are that is option four and there's one
which I think commands quite strong
support across this house
well I
I'd mention and it brings me on to my my
final argument that I think it is a
dangerous path to uh to go down
wrenching change from either the
applicability of the human rights act or
from the jurisdiction of the Court the
European convention on human rights is
fundamental to the Devolution
settlements in Wales and Northern
Ireland and it also plays a distinct
role in The Belfast agreement The Good
Friday agreement and I just wanted to
read out since we're so near to the 25th
anniversary of that agreement how the
European convention on human rights was
framed as an integral Safeguard and I
quote there will be safeguards to ensure
that all sections of the community can
participate and work together
successfully in the operation of these
institutions that all sections of the
community are protected from including
the European convention on human rights
which neither the assembly nor any
public body can infringe so in a climate
where at the time of the conclusion of
that agreement there was a deep
skepticism about British courts
following for example the establishment
of diplop Courts and other things which
were controversial at the time it isn't
just something that is paid lip service
too but it's integral to the proper
functioning of that of that agreement I
would add and I must add the proud
history we have in the formation and
construction of the European Convention
of Human Rights it's well known that
David Maxwell Fife was a conservative MP
and it is also for that reason actually
it's unsurprising that we are one of the
states with the lowest numbers of
adverse findings I think we should be
very wary of quick fixes we said
throughout the brexit debate we'd be
taking back control of our borders but
it's more complex than that and the
point I'm making actually in this speech
tonight is leaving the conventional
derogating from the convention is not
the answer it won't do the job anyway
and I and I think it will um
I think it will undermine the effect of
this bill which I think will be upheld
as lawful by the European Court of human
rights in the event that it's referred
for
Stella Creasy thank you madam chair
Madam chair I wish to reassure you that
I will be speaking only to the
Amendments that have been selected this
evening I know we have other debates uh
scheduled for tomorrow on other
amendments and I have amendments in both
section but if I can beg her leave just
to reflect and respect that whilst this
important debate is taking place a
member of my staff has just won
parliamentary staffer of the Year Jess
England
yeah
Jess is somebody who has first-hand
knowledge of the things that we are
discussing this evening because she has
helped me for years work with people
seeking Asylum refugees from around the
world who've come to the UK and have a
connection to walthamstow and I I want
to put on record my graduate her award
is long overdue and if she were here now
she could bring much light to this
debate as somebody who knows the reality
of when people flee persecution I also
want to say it is a genuine honor to
follow the previous speaker we may in be
in different political parties but I
recognize How brave she has just been to
make that speech and to speak up for
something which increasingly has become
an extreme view in the conservative
movement about the importance of Human
Rights so I want to recognize how
powerful Her speech was and the many
points and her expertise that she put on
the record there and I think the house
benefits again from light not heat in
these debates
the clarity that all of us have to say
that there is not a single member
amongst us who wants to help the
Smugglers there is not a single member
amongst us who thinks that small boats
Crossing the the English Channel isn't
acceptable or reasonable way to proceed
the difference is in how we address the
issue the difference is whether we pour
oil on that fire or whether we seek in
our amendments this legislation to try
to recognize the best of Britain to be
the actual Patriots in this chamber
because so far we've talked so much
about the ways people travel but not
actually who is traveling and there have
been different statistics banded around
we know that the vast majority of people
in those boats are from seven different
countries so let us recognize first and
foremost why it matters that this
legislation meets the test not of the
mode of travel but who is traveling
people fleeing persecution don't form
orderly cues at the border when there is
a war
when they're facing persecution for
their political or their religious
beliefs they can't turn to the state to
ask them to get their paperwork in order
to email it to them so they may cross
the border and have copies with them and
yet the people that we are dealing with
in these instances and I reflect on the
fact that the former member for
Blackburn who was responsible for
incorporating the Human Rights Act into
UK legislation used to say to me there
was left and right in Parliament and
then there are those people who dealt
with the ukba and those people who
didn't
when you are dealing with people who
have fled persecution you know first
hand
that it is not a simple straightforward
linear experience that accommodates well
the kind of bureaucracy and
administrative process that the member
opposite from South Holland wishes
that's indeed why the refugee convention
itself says that refugees should not be
prosecuted for destroying their
documents for issues around immigration
fraud or indeed by their mode of travel
because it is to recognize the reality
that when the decision is life or death
life matters and I see no irony in
suggesting that to him honestly I'll sit
down I I I'm very grateful to my
honorable friend she's making a really
important Point here that's not just
pertinent to the small boats because of
course we witnessed with safe routes
exactly the same issue where people were
fleeing uh in fear of their lives from
Ukraine we opened up safe routes but
many of those people had to leave all
their important documentation behind
I agree with you on gentleman in fact
those of us who are still dealing with
people from Afghanistan people who put
their lives on their line to help the
British forces who have not been able to
come here who listen for the minister
talk about the idea that somehow we have
taken 25 000 people onto those schemes
and I've not because their families are
still stuck their families are still
stuck and if the minister wants the
casework I've raised it on the record
before of a family who were split up
when they could to go to the baron hotel
if the minister would take the casework
I'll take the intervention because that
family needs to be here
The Honorable lady can't trade in
anecdote rather than facts the facts of
the matter are that this scheme has
taken 25
000 individuals over the course of the
period since just before the fall of
Kabul those are the facts as I always
say to The Honorable lady I'm very happy
to look into individual cases but in
this chamber we should deal in fact not
fiction
the minister knows that that isn't the
way in which the scheme has worked he
knows only 22 people have been given
Citrus and he already has the case in
his inbox long overdue its attention
because every single day I think about
that Family who were told that they
should go to the baron Hotel couldn't
get there because there was an explosion
and are now separated with the family in
hiding and the Father Here desperate out
of his mind about what to do who was
promised a safe and legal route by this
government and promised there came no
reality and that is why I cannot support
this legislation its current form
because this legislation first and
foremost does nothing to the Smugglers
themselves if we all agree that the
Smugglers are the people that we want to
stop why is there not a single measure
in this bill that directly affects those
Smugglers the idea that you are going to
cut off their Market by what happens
doesn't recognize that we've seen these
kind of measures before and all that
happens is the prices go up people
disappear modern slavery increases of
course I'll give way to the member from
South Holland I'm looking forward to
what he has to say but when you're
tackling illegal immigration you're
doing several things you're attacking It
On The Source by getting to the
Smugglers you're dealing with the issues
in the channel itself and on the coast
and you're creating a legitive framework
for purpose they are separate parts for
strategy
forward to having a debate with him
tomorrow on Amendment 293 that I've
tabled to remove the word illegal from
the title of this bill because it is not
illegal to seek Asylum
and it is a very simple process that
what he's talking about is not what this
bill will do
this bill and I tried to urge him before
not to process people's claims in the
chamber because it is about what we
actually see the evidence the fact I
have multiple anecdotes of people who
have been failed by our Asylum system
have failed by the processing and failed
by the promises they were given of a
safe and legal route but that is why
this evening I wish to speak to the
Amendments about safe and legal Roots
because if this government thinks this
legislation is about illegal migration
then by default there must be a legal
process so those safe and legal routes
deserve much more scrutiny and attention
that is why the fact that this
government has failed to provide a
children's rights assessment and
equality impact assessment is asking us
to trust them when they cannot set out
how they think people who are entitled
to seek Asylum because they are fleeing
persecution should run is so worrying so
Madam chair when I look at this
legislation I can see it needs drastic
overhaul to even meet its own ambitions
but even meet those pledges in article
31 that somebody destroying their
documents should not be penalized by
somebody suggesting that there must be a
malicious claim in that but looking at
the actual evidence as to why Smugglers
are encouraging that and the member from
South Holland suggests that somehow this
bill will do well frankly what the
immigration nationality Bill failed to
do and what this government's policies
keep failing to do let us learn perhaps
from that most famous Refugee that
indeed this country turned away Isaac
Einstein when he said that the
definition of insanity was doing the
same thing over and over again expecting
a different result
[Music]
new Clause 17 as a probing because on
that basis that actually if the
government talks about safe and legal
routes we should know what safe and
legal routes are intended to do now it's
a very simple Amendment it simply says
the government should set out what a
safe and legal route is and then which
countries are therefore unsafe and
require a legal route after all the bill
does set out those countries it
considers to be safe Ergo there must be
all the countries not on it as unsafe
and to tell us in Parliament how people
should be able to access those routes
and therefore not make these dangerous
Journeys
I also support the amendment by the
member for East Worthing new Clause 13
and also the proposals put forward by my
colleague from Sheffield in new Clause
10. all of whom I think we would all
agree want further work but all get
towards that simple principle of where
what is the role of a safe and legal
route in this legislation in itself if
this legislation is about illegal
migration then go what is the point of
safe illegal roots
and it's also why I've tabled Amendment
138 which will be debated tomorrow about
how that might then play a role in the
actual Asylum processing place in itself
because there's a very simple message
here in all of this work which is what
um I agree with the member for stone I'm
sorry he's not here in his place to say
because that might surprise people but
he said that the processing of a site of
an assessing of claims matters
absolutely
that is why the failures that we've seen
and if we're honest the failures that
we've seen for a number of years have
not been to do with the refugees
themselves but have been to do with the
politicians and their failure to get to
grips that is why it matters that the
government isn't using the correct
figures from the statistics Authority
because it doesn't show us the true
scale of the problem that consistent
legislation has failed to deal with and
why we need to do something different
and something different would be
clarifying what a safe and legal route
is and how it fits into are Refugee
um convention and also how it fits into
our processing because actually because
there aren't simple prices of admin and
bureaucracy in a war that you can push
people towards it matters all the more
that we respect and recognize that in
how we treat those people who still
think life is better than death and so
they still choose to run
and I say to some of the members
opposite one of those top countries on
the people in the boats is Iran and I've
sat in this chamber and I've listened to
people in this chamber call out the
Iranian government and speak of their
concerns for the persecution of people
in Iran and then not half an hour later
talk about how awful anybody in those
boats are when the third most recent
country of people in there is Iranians
there is no safe route from Iran
the people that I am in touch with
tonight the minister says from a
sedentary distance that there is again
if he will tell me I'm in touch with
people right now Brave democracy
Defenders who have no root out and are
at risk I'll happily give way tell me if
I can put those since 2015 the UK has
taken more than 6 000 Iranians into the
UK directly for Asylum purposes so it's
simply not true what the honorable lady
is saying
the minister needs to be clear about how
those people have been identified
because there are people tonight in
Tehran who are at direct risk of harm
who need our help and the challenge with
this legislation is by not setting out a
safe and legal route by refusing to by
saying it will be done in secondary
guidance none of us can be confident of
saying to those people wait hold up wait
for the queue wait for the
administration wait for the bureaucracy
there is somewhere for you to go don't
worry we help is coming and that's why
it matters for the government to
collects with International
organizations and to actually uphold the
international rule of law because the
honest truth is the only way the world
will be able to stand up for its values
and stand up to those dictators and
those people who do persecute and
against war is by collaborating together
now we've seen that in such a powerful
way in Ukraine and yet we do not seem
capable of learning the lessons of that
in setting out those schemes and being
able to say to people look actually
there is a way forward and actually we
will all share the burden of standing up
for those values that is what a sensible
Asylum policy would do because it would
be an effective one you would cut off
the boats at Source by having proper
safe and legal routes for people so they
would not need to get on a boat to be
able to come here to claim in the first
place
and in irregular routes are inevitable
because of the nature of why people are
running in the first place
I also want to speak briefly to
amendments one three one and one three
two which again I pay Testament to the
member who spoke to me previously about
because they're about our role in the
European Court of human rights now I'm
sorry that the member for devises isn't
here because I was hoping he might want
a chance to clarify his earlier remarks
when he genuinely tried to suggest that
Winston Churchill opposed us being part
of the European Court of human rights as
somebody who served on the Council of
Europe and who saw repeatedly pictures
of Winston Churchill well if the older
gentleman will let me finish his
sentence I'm sure he wishes to hear what
I have to say I thought it was worth
hearing from the man himself
because his argument for a European
Court of Human Rights was in the center
of our movement don't tell anybody he
wanted a United Europe stands and the
idea of a charter of Human Rights
guarded by freedom and sustained by law
because what Winston Churchill saw then
we still see now which is overbearing
governments who do not respect the
courts of law who do not want the
scrutiny of Law and what these
amendments speak to is precisely that
fear that actually legislation might be
poorly drafted it might be burdensome it
might indeed be oppressive in this
country and what we all want and indeed
what we would find common cause with
Winston Churchill and that doesn't
happen often is the importance of
keeping politicians Honest by putting
them up to the scrutiny of the courts
now I'll happily give way to see how the
gentleman feels he can be honest if he
wants to support these amendments and
take that away I think the honorable
member for giving way I I will attempt
to answer on behalf of my colleague who
I spoke to earlier about this this point
one of the key points that my honorable
friend has made was actually what um
relates to Winston Churchill signed up
to in in 1950
it didn't involve rule 39 audits the way
you literally situation has evolved
means what we did in today's totally
different to a situation that faced this
country in 1950 so to make that
comparison is crude and it is wrong and
I'm sure my honorable friend when he
comes back and makes a further
intervention at some point even today or
tomorrow will powerfully deal the
critique that you've just put in front
of him
oh sorry the young gentleman I presume
he I hope he's at dinner because after
having made that speech I'm sure he
needs something to eat
um but I but I just simply say that is
not what Winston Churchill did stand up
for and those of us who have served on
the Council of Europe and seen in detail
and read in detail his speeches let
alone subsequent conservative
governments who were part of the
development of the Council of Europe
where indeed we didn't just scrutinize
those judges we helped appoint them and
vote for them so we had a direct role in
choosing them it doesn't Accord with
what he was arguing which is that this
is out of kilter every single step of
the way the United Kingdom has been part
and parcel of developing the European
Court of Human Rights and rightly so
frankly because the libertarian in me
speaks up for the European Court of
Rights because I see governments of all
colors
given the temptation to be overbearing
without that scrutiny without the cause
to keep them honest we'll do things that
none of us think are right I'll happily
give away and then I do want to come to
a conclusion
we're giving way isn't it a unassailable
truism that the fundamental principles
which drove Churchill and the
conservative party and this place
to support these initiatives remain as
true today as they did those years ago
of course it's been a living iterative
organic process but the fundamental
underpinning principles which
established it still remain true and if
Churchill were here today he would be
making precisely that point
I think I think we've all expanded quite
clearly that perhaps the interpretation
of what Churchill thought that the
member from devises sought to set out
may not be an entirely complete advocate
for what a gentleman who who made sure
that we were the first signatories to
the European Court of Human Rights who
continued to campaign for it and Lobby
for it up until his death and its
development and evolution would have
thought I'll create happy giveaway that
I really do want to come to an event I
Thank The Honorable lady for giving way
the thing I'm having difficulty
understanding is we signed the European
convention on human rights we have
signed many other International
conventions if we're not going to obey
by the rules of those conventions then
why do we sign them
well what I think my my colleague sets
out which is the other more pragmatic
points that I would like to make on the
record which is actually it doesn't
matter what Churchill thought if you
want to resolve how people are traveling
around the world to seek uh safety and
Sanctuary because they're fleeing
persecution they're not upholding
international law is not the best way to
make sure you're in the room when
decisions are made about how to share
that burden if we want to be a grown-up
on the world stage and I'm pleased that
the Prime Minister himself has said he
has no plans for us to leave the
European Court of Human Rights because I
think that does reflect that recognition
that you need to uphold international
law and you need to be part of those
conversations so the answer to the
government's concerns is not this
legislation it's to go to the Council of
Europe and be part of those debates and
those discussions about the role of the
court and how the court would operate to
show that we are prepared to fight for
our values not just here but
internationally as well so that we can
then arrange those kind of games that
will be inevitable to make sure that we
as a world can deal with the conflict
and and disruption that means that there
are more people fleeing persecution that
we will not say it's to do with
somebody's nationality or how they
travel but to do with the risk that they
face that is the most simple and frankly
patriotic point so when I hear the
member for South Holland who again I'm
sad is not here say that he speaks for
the British people I know that he does
not because I watch the British people
stand up for the ukrainians stand up and
be frustrated by the lack of bureaucracy
of the government and when it came to
that scheme I've watched the British
people fundraise for the people in
turkey and Syria affected by those
crisis share that compassion that horror
of what happened to Ayan kurdi and
that's why I'm proud to be part of this
country and why I know this legislation
does not speak to the best of the
British people the same British people
who are proud to be part of seeking
peace in Europe and proud today to work
internationally to stand up for those
values who do not turn the other cheek
who see the pictures of people hiding
from the bombs on their televisions and
know that the right thing to do is not
say wait your turn but actually to say
how can we help this legislation will
not do anything to tackle those
challenges this legislation will not
clarify what those safe and legal routes
are this legislation will not stop the
Smugglers the people will still come and
we will be here here for months if not
years to come debating what else could
be done Einstein was right this country
turned Einstein away maybe if we'd had a
modicum more of that dignity that he had
about being a refugee and that
intelligence we might now not be in this
position today certainly it is insanity
to continue doing the same thing and not
seek to make this legislation
actually reflect those values that all
of us in this house say we do care about
refugees I hope that the ministers will
recognize the concern that the safe
routes just simply aren't there in this
legislation and that our experience at
the safe routes to date this government
has set out has been found wanting and
rather than shaking his head or
dismissing those concerns look at why
those people are still at risk because
if we can crack that then maybe we'll be
on to something as it stands this
legislation will make that harder not
easier I fear the people who are now
waiting and being told by the Smugglers
nobody is coming to help you because
look at what the UK is doing now that is
not to be proud of yeah
there are 14 people trying to catch my
eye and the last two speakers went 22
minutes and 19 minutes now that means
not everybody's going to get in if
everybody contributes that far it's up
to you David Jones
for Evans I'm pleased to follow the
honorable member for Waltham stew I've
heard your strictures and I shall try to
be as brief as I possibly can I Rise to
speak in support of the amendments to
which I am a signatory and I would like
to focus in particular on Amendment 131
which has been the subject of so much of
the debate this evening illegal
migration is a severe problem and it's
one that is causing increasing concern
to constituents of most if not all
honorable members speaking from my own
experience as the Member of Parliament
for a semi-rural constituency in North
Wales many hundreds of miles away from
the channeled beaches I can say that I
receive more correspondence about this
issue than virtually any other national
issue now the people of this country
have over the years shown themselves to
be generous and welcoming to those who
are genuinely in peril and that's borne
out by the warmth of the welcome they
have given in recent years to ukrainians
fleeing from Putin's aggression and to
Hong Kong as escaping China's
anti-democratic oppression but equally
they are incensed by the rapidly Rising
influx of illegal migrants who are
themselves the pitiful currency of the
loathsome trade of people smuggling
so the prime minister is quite right to
make plain that stopping the small boats
is at the top of his list of priorities
and this bill is therefore highly
welcome
the government has taken a robust
approach to the problem and that
robustness will also be highly welcomed
by the people of this country whose
patience has been tried to and Beyond
Breaking Point
um there is a concern however that the
government's perfectly proper aim of
breaking the business model of the
people's Smugglers may be frustrated by
the human rights legislation that is
routinely and frankly cynically abused
by those who wish to degrade this
country's ability to defend its own
borders and this territorial integrity
the government in Clause 1-5 of the bill
recognizes that concern and it excludes
the operation of section three of the
Human Rights Act 1998 which provides
that so far as possible legislation must
be read and given an effect in a way
that is compatible with the European
convention on human rights
excluding section three is itself a bold
step for which the government is to be
commended but given the severity of the
problem as Professor Richard eakins and
Sir Stephen laws have pointed out it
remains debatable where the Clause 1-5
alone will be sufficient to safeguard
the Bill's measures against cynical
procedural attacks by via the European
Court of Human Rights and it's for such
purpose that amendments 131 132 and 133
are framed
and anyone doubting the needs for such
amendments should consider the case of
NSK and the United Kingdom which has
been referred to by my honorable friend
a member for devises that to repeat was
a case where on the 13th of June last
year a duty judge of the European Court
of Human Rights made an order granting
an application for a rule 39 measure
preventing the removal of an asylum
Seeker to Rwanda
that order was made ex-party without any
opportunity for the United Kingdom
government to argue against it
furthermore the order was made after
both the high court and the court of
appeal had rejected applications for
inter interim relief the Supreme Court
in fact went on to refuse an application
for leave to appeal
but remarkably the rule 39 order was
made the day before The Supreme Court
announced its refusal apparently
contrary to the rule that domestic
proceedings must be exhausted before
applications to the European Court will
be entertained
the position therefore Mr Evans is that
the most senior judges in the land had
considered the merits of the applicant's
case and found against it yet a European
judge made an order frustrating the
removal of the applicant without
considering the merits of the
government's case and apparently
contrary to the European Court's own
rules
interim measures are not strictly
legally binding
but the European Court's own
jurisprudence as has already been
pointed out asserts that any failure to
comply with them amounts to a
contravention of article 34 that is by
hindering an applicant's right to apply
to the court alleging a breach of the
convention
the possibility arguably the probability
is that domestic British courts will
feel constrained to act in compliance
with interim measures and indeed to
follow other judgments of the European
court and that alone could prove fatal
to the aims of the bill
uh Mr Evans I don't believe that the
government or this house should allow
that to happen
appropriate further safeguards should be
introduced into the bill to ensure its
Effectiveness and it's for that purpose
that Amendment 131 is tabled seeking to
ensure that the legitimate and proper
aim of the government to protect our
national borders is not frustrated
and put simply Mr Evans the people of
this country will not thank us if the
bill does not work
and there is a distinct danger that if
the European court is allowed to do so
that is precisely what will happen I
believe that Amendment 131 is absolutely
necessary and for similar reasons
support the other amendments to which
I've put my name now it's already been
pointed out that these amendments will
not be pressed to a vote but I very much
hope that in his winding up my right
honorable friend will confirm that he
will engage in dialogue with us who are
concerned about the absence of these
amendments and seek to find a way
forward that will ensure that this bill
will work which is what every honorable
member of this house should want
Olivia Blake
um
um it's a pleasure to speak in this
debate
um I would like to just uh make the
house aware and direct them to the house
uh register of interests for members
interests uh for I receive um help from
the refugee Asylum and migration
projects uh for their work in this area
my work in this area I also co-chair the
appg on migration so I've spent a long
time thinking about these issues and
I've actually taken a long look at our
history and it's interesting to hear us
talk about Winston Churchill because I
doubt members offered off budget would
know that he crossed the floor on the
issue in 1904 to oppose the alien act in
1904 and led a rebellion against that
act and he was quoted as saying the old
tolerant and generous practice of free
entry and Asylum which this country has
long adhered to
um at that time so I think
just to add some more spice to the
discussion about the history of this
place and our role within migration
policy I think it's important to
recognize that
um
so I Rise actually to speak specifically
to my Amendment nc10 which I'm pleased
to say enjoyed um why a wide range of
cross-party support and I'd like to
thank all members who have engaged with
me on this amendment nc10 is meant to be
a serious contribution to the debate
about the humanitarian crisis in the
channel
however I worry that the seriousness is
not shared by everyone in this chamber
since arriving in Parliament in 2019 I
try not to become too jaded or too
cynical
um but I must admit at times it has been
difficult today debating this bill is
one of those times because we've been
told repeatedly that these proposals are
about stopping the boats the Prime
Minister even had it printed on his
lectin but to be clear I think it's a
moral outrage that people need to get in
a blow-up boat risking their life and
limb to exercise their rights into the
refugee convention to claim Asylum here
we need a solution and this humanitarian
crisis in the channel but that is not
what this bill offers instead it doubles
down on the same failed hostile
environment framework that has
characterized the government's approach
to Asylum and migration
it's simply not working and since 2018
56 people
have tragically drowned in the channel
brothers sisters uncles aunts cousins
to many many families already in the UK
yet the number of dangerous Crossings
has risen even after the government's
Rwanda policy was announced and that
announcement in itself was deemed to be
a deterrent the nationality and borders
actors become law and people continue to
make these Journeys
and I'm proud that my city Sheffield
calls itself a city of sanctuary the
people I meet who are a support Refugee
Rights often quote the lines of a poem
called home by the Somali British writer
wasen Shire
no one puts their children in a boat
unless the water is safer than the land
and no one leaves home unless home is
the mouth of a shark
these lines are important because they
explain why people attempt these
Crossings and we've heard a lot of talk
about families today I regularly engage
and talk to Asylum Seekers and refugees
in the system whose family members are
being persecuted because of them leaving
the country they've got brothers who
have been arrested by police on spurious
grounds or they've sadly had their
parents murdered as a result of their
identity
I think that we really must shine a
light on the way the government strategy
is doomed to fail
and perhaps more importantly why the
success of that strategy would be a
horror because the only way that
deterrence framework can work is if the
hostile environment it creates is worse
than what people are running from that's
why I feel jaded
because I don't think this is really
about stopping the crossings and saving
lives these proposals aren't about how
people come here to claim Asylum they're
about stopping people from claiming
Asylum at all this isn't about fairness
it's about populist electoral politics
throwing red meat to a section of
Hardline anti-refugee opinion what
better example than the cruelty of
stripping away the modern slavery
provisions of Asylum Seekers who have
survived human trafficking this
legislation as it stands would persecute
the persecuted it would criminalize the
victims of crime to be frank
too I suspect that there is some on the
other side of the house who think it's a
good thing the bill violates the UN
conventions of international human
rights law and the government's
credibility is so shredded that they
believe the only route to Future
electoral success is to wage a culture
War gleefully reciting pre-rehearse
lines about Lefty lawyers while the
situation for some of the most
vulnerable people in the world gets
worse and worse
but the government could perhaps prove
me wrong and I give them that
opportunity a start would be supporting
and looking into the proposals of nc10
the amendment Builds on the proposals of
the PCS Union and care for Cali two
organizations working at the front line
of the crisis it offers a practical
solution to a humanitarian crisis in the
channel by creating a safe passage Visa
the Visa would give entry clearance to
those already in Europe who wish to come
to the UK to make an asylum claim
I think one of the disconnects and the
paradoxes of the government's policy as
it stands is that there is no way for
the many thousands of people who have
already started their journey to get
onto a safe and legal route
that is a paradox you can't reduce the
number of
um boats if the people who are going to
try and make that Journey are already on
their journey and have no alternatives
to come to the UK that's why a safe
passage Visa is so so important because
those Journeys are so dangerous
the proposals also draw inspiration from
the uh you know successful Ukrainian
settlement schemes
um and by no means those Asylum schemes
are perfect and we've held debates on
that but equally no Ukrainian refugees
have needed to make the dangerous
Crossing in the boats to get here I
think we have to ask the question why is
that the case and I think we know the
answer because there was a safe route
that was available to them
they didn't need to make an application
um or or
it could be made online actually the
application that they wanted for safe
passage beforehand they got permission
to travel here
um the safe passage Visa would work in a
very similar way with documents and any
biometric information being uploaded on
an online portal for example as in the
Ukraine scheme or where there needs to
be further checks being done in person
and to be clear this is tightly focused
on people who are granting someone safe
and legal and
legal uh access to the UK from Europe
because they would have a valid Asylum
claim as set out in the current
immigration rules when they arrive once
they've arrived in the UK they would
then go on to a final processing centers
to submit their applications as normal
meaning that they uh most of the
screening and processing would happen as
normal in the UK meaning that we
wouldn't have to look into costly
measures of arrangements with other
countries that we would take ownership
of our responsibilities to these people
who are going to make these Journeys
anyway alone this won't fix the Asylum
system
but it does provide a Humane response to
the issue of small boats it focuses on
that group of people who have already
made that journey and are already making
their way across one that will often get
forgotten in this and one that will
continue to contribute contribute to the
small votes as they have no alternative
and the vast majority of people who come
here irregularly make Asylum claims and
overwhelmingly those applications are
accepted 70 80 90 depending on what
country they come from and they make
that dangerous Crossing not because
they're more likely to be refused or
they're more likely to not have a valid
claim they make that Journey because
there is no other way for them to enter
the UK by providing them with an
alternative we can remove the needs to
risk life and limb ministers have a
choice they can go on demonizing
refugees genuine Asylum Seekers
talking up this threat that billions of
people are coming here when that is just
an absolute falsehood and Darwin stopped
the boats on government lectins but that
might generate headlines for a short
while but it won't help anyone and it
won't stop anyone from making that
Crossing
or there's another option prove you're
serious they're serious about ending the
life-threatening Crossings Drop The
securitized Fortress Britain rhetoric
uphold international law and embrace the
Humane approach that tackles the
underlying causes of the dangerous boat
Journeys in doing that we can save lives
in doing that we can meet the
obligations that we have and doing that
we can be a fairer country one that I
know my hundreds of constituents who
have emailed me in a in against this
bill truly believes that we should
remain and continue to be
Jack brereton thank you Mr Evans I'm
pleased to contribute further to this
debate on the vital illegal migration
bill which promises tangible action to
address the frustrations of my
constituents in Stoke-on-Trent South as
I've said previously I very much support
the actions of this government and the
prime minister in taking tough new
approach to tackling illegal migrate
migration and I wanted to challenge some
of the things that the honorable members
have said opposite particularly The
Honorable member for westmort London
Lonsdale who isn't currently in his
place he said about there not being any
safe and legal routes Beyond those
country specific schemes in fact fifty
thousand people have come since 2015
through routes open to any country this
includes the refugee family reunion
scheme UK resettlement scheme Community
sponsorship scheme and mandate
resettlement scheme in total this means
that there have been 480
000 people have come via safe and legal
routes since 2015
so content has been more generous than
most other places in the country and
many feel that their generosity has been
taken for granted and that their genuine
concerns about irregular migration have
been ignored or even held in contempt
particularly by the party opposite and
the Lefty activists lawyers determined
to frustrate the Democratic will of the
people and because their determination
to frustrate the will of this elected
house is so strong I do think that we
need at this committee stage to close
all potential loopholes
indeed the amendments to which I've
attached my own name are those which I
felt would make the belt this a belt and
braces bill against scrollless actions
the amendments in the name of my
honorable friend and neighbor the member
for stone will ensure that a successful
suspensive claim will be the only way to
prevent removal no ifs no buts no tying
it all up in challenges to circumvent
the intended will of this Parliament we
have been shown time and again that any
lack of Crystal Clarity will be excluded
by activists Lefty lawyers
the danger is that people will lose
faith in the Democratic process and
mainstream parties
if to if Democratic mandates and acts of
parliament are constantly frustrated by
loopholes that we have left
unprecedented pressure necessitates
unprecedented actions and his actions in
this bill that will actually break the
people Smugglers model of taking money
to get people illegally into Britain
with what has been a relatively small
chance of ever being removed under the
overwhelmed Legacy system that this Home
Secretary is having to reform radically
I do hope these actions will be properly
resourced not just financially but in
terms of the available skills and
Workforce professional including some of
those that will be based at the home
office Hub in Stoke on trend
well our job today is to make this bill
unambiguous in its confirming its intent
to enable the removal of illegal
migrants and ensure the Primacy of this
house in delivering on the Democratic
will
small boat people smuggling is a
dangerous and unacceptable trade in
human lives and only by Smashing the
Traders business model can we really
bring an end to this
and that means we must also frustrate
the business model of the activist labor
lawyers who look for any loophole or
ambiguity or for their own political
ends to making borders irrelevant and
impossible to protect
so in addition to supporting the
amendment in the name of my oral friend
the member for stone I support the
Amendments from my honorable friend the
member for devises and my honorable and
the member for Middlesbrough South and
East Cleveland
the Human Rights Act should not be
misused to remove control of our
national or border and the same applies
to the European Court
I welcome that the government itself has
stipulated in Clause one the intention
that this bill will exempt from section
3 of The Human Rights Act in line with
the Belton braces approach that I do
think is necessary as my writing or
friend who's not in his place for Middle
Elizabeth and Southeast Cleveland said
it makes sense also to disapply sections
4 6 and 10 to close the loopholes of any
supposed incompatibility where it is
impossible to use section three
so mystery of Evans
absolutely Mr very grateful tomorrow
friend for giving way and he's doing an
excellent job of standing up for the
people of stoke on Trent as well as
North Staffordshire he is very proudly
put his immense signature to remember
that I've also signed which is about uh
the member for devises is uh echr let's
be crystal clear about what this
amendment will do is about making it
perfectly crystal clear to UK courts
that wrote us all the 39s that come from
the European courtroom rights that are
not based in law are not to be taken
into judgment by UK courts when it comes
to the removal of illegal economic
migrants who have come from safe
Mainland France and therefore we're
simply reconfirming what was in the
original Refuge convention back in 1950s
where these order 39s didn't even exist
or mentioned and we want to ensure
therefore that we deliver for the will
of the people of people like Stoke on
train The Honorable friends serve so
well
I thank my honorable friend for
Stoke-on-Trent North for making that
point and I entirely agree with what he
said the people in soak on Trend
absolutely want us to see robust action
on this and we will not continue to
tolerate the powers of Strasbourg and
the European courts overriding the
decisions of this house and of British
courts so Mr Evans if we don't stop
illegal entry and misuse of the Asylum
system then we will not be able to give
proper attention to those in genuine
need and nor will we enjoy the support
of the general general public this bill
is about fairness and ensuring that
resources are available for those in
genuine needs but it needs to have a
belt and break belt and braces to ensure
it does not end up in a lucrative legal
battle for activist lawyers real change
is needed to tackle the unprecedented
pressures and look to the the
improvements that are needed I look
forward to those constructive
discussions with ministers we must never
again allow our generosity and
compassion as a nation to be abused by
people Smugglers with dangerous small
votes
that was a much shorter contribution so
things are looking brighter to get
everybody in Patrick Grady
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and bills of
major constitutional significance are
usually treated uh about on the floor of
the housing Committee of the whole house
the government refused to send the
elections bill or they retained EU law
Bill to committee the whole house sent
them upstairs uh to public bill
committees and yet it finds time for
this bill which stretches any claim to
reflect what was even in the Tory
Manifesto to have its committee stage
here in the house and I wonder why that
is one effect of course is that there's
no opportunity to hear from stakeholders
to take evidence on the bill and perhaps
that's not a surprise because it doesn't
seem to have been a single briefing or
intervention from anyone with any
interest or experience in the field of
immigration or Asylum policy or law that
is actually in support of what the
government is proposing the only people
cheering this on are the populist hard
right elements of the conservative back
benches under pulls the cabinets and
their friends in equally right-wing
media outlets and even then it seems
that this is a bill that pleases no one
because the range of amendments that
have been tabled from the back benches
from all side of the house shows the
risk that the government is taking and
the Damage that it's doing by pursuing
wedge issue and dog whistle Politics the
brexite years and seemingly with the
task at support of the Home Secretary
are seeking to use their amendments to
expunge any Last Vestige of what they
see is European influence in the United
Kingdom by taking us out of the echr but
meanwhile on the opposition benches
hey many of us including my honorable
friends from Glasgow Central and Company
are proposing a wide range of amendments
that actually seek to reduce or negate
some of the very worst aspects of the
bill Amendment 76 for example which I
hope we'll be able to test the will of
the house on later on would make it much
clearer that the need for protection the
experience of Human Rights abuses or
being a victim of slavery or human
trafficking would be grounds for a claim
to suspend a deportation process well
Amendment 77 puts much stronger
restrictions on the definitions of a
third country to which Asylum Seekers
could be deported and many of the other
SNP Amendments have similar effects
trying to introduce some of the element
of fairness and respect for human rights
whether that's about the time available
for appeals and considerations or the
grounds on which such Claims can be made
but the key issue in this evening's
groupings is that if the government
really wants to stop people arriving
here on small boats it has to provide
safe and legal alternative and the
reality is at the moment for the
majority of people who currently arrive
here and successfully claim Asylum such
Roots don't exist where what are the
safe and legal roots for someone from
Eritrea or from Iran that question has
been asked multiple times and it's not
been properly answered because if they
were safe and legal routes available
people wouldn't be coming incidentally
this bill is supposed to have a
deterrent effect well and it's back
dated to the 7th of March so I wonder
how many people have been deterred
already has there suddenly been an
evaporation of Landings on the south
coast of England I suspect not and that
maybe shows that the bill is not going
to have the effect that the government
wants it to have and even where schemes
for safe and legal uh routes do exist
such as for example such as
for Afghanistan that like the proposals
that are contained in this bill they go
nowhere near far enough the Amendments
that I've tabled at Mr uh Evans
um including amendments 177 and 179
alongside my honorable friends make the
point that it's far better first of all
to think in terms of targets rather than
caps for safe and legal entrants this
country is crying out for people to come
here and help make our Health Service
our social care system our hospitality
industries our agricultural sector work
more effectively and efficiently but too
many people who could be productive who
want to be productive are left sitting
in hotels at the taxpayers expense when
they could be earning a wage that pays
for their own accommodation and
contributes back into the tax system so
the Secretary of State as we see in
Amendment 173 needs to be Consulting
with Scotland's government about any
Target it sets for safe and legal
arrivals and there is clearly
cross-party consensus on this many
constituents Glasgow North support as I
do new Clause 10 table by the honorable
member for Sheffield Hallam which would
establish these kinds of safe passage
schemes and the other amendments uh to
that end tabled from across the house I
think the government needs to pay
attention to not least the The Proposal
from The Honorable member for
eastwardling and showroom but Mr chair
the house would be within its rights to
push every single clause in this bill to
evolve over the next two days if the
Tories really want this spell to become
law they should be made to work for it
staying up late in this place to walk
through lobbies is barely a minor
inconvenience compared to the hardship
and horror that most people seeking
asylum in the UK have already faced and
do continue to face before and after
they reach these Shores people who come
here seeking Asylum are fleeing Wars
where this country has a a manufactured
or sold the weapons from natural
disasters where this government is
refusing to take climate change
seriously and hunger and disease where
this government is slashing the age
budget that could fight those challenges
yeah this bill isn't amended beyond
recognition then it will undermine any
claims that this government has to
uphold the global treaties and
conventions that have made maintained
stability and respected human rights
around the world since the second world
war the vast majority of these people of
people on these islands and certainly
among the Rises to class going on want
to live in an inclusive diverse and
welcoming society and if this government
is going to undermine that then they
will find and build that Society
themselves in an independent Scotland
mooncakes thank you Mr chairman and I
Rise to speak in support of the
principle of amendments 131-134 which
seek to strengthen the illegal migration
bill by preventing spurious claims
whatever they may be from being used to
resist the removal of those arriving in
Britain illegally now these amendments
aim to close any potential loopholes in
the bill that would limit its
Effectiveness and I've listened
carefully to many thoughtful and
technically excellent speeches from
honorable friends and honorable members
across the house for whom I have the
greatest respect and of course I cannot
match their legal expertise and detailed
understanding of the legal complexities
of this bill but I do want to argue for
the principle of strengthening the bill
which I think the government has
accepted to make sure that it is
effective and of course it's essential
that the bill is effective because more
than 4 40 000 people arriving illegally
on small boats in a year is a serious
safety issue it's a national security
issue it's an economic issue with six
million pounds a day being spent on
hotels to house migrants it's a crime
issue with many illegal immigrants
engaging in illegal activity or being
drawn into slavery and exploitation and
it's also a sovereignty issue and many
ask who is really in control of British
borders our elected Parliament or
foreign courts now if this bill does not
work if it does not result in the Swift
deportation of those who arrive here
illegally then it will not have a
deterrent effect and we will not stop
the boats the objective of these
amendments is therefore to strengthen
the legislation to significantly reduce
the likelihood of unjustified legal
challenges using human rights
legislation that was never meant to
provide cover to International gangs now
I thank ministers for their
consideration of the intention of these
amendments
but some who oppose these amendments and
this bill will cite compassion and I
wholeheartedly agree that those who are
genuinely fleeing war and persecution
deserve our compassion and many should
be and are offered a home here in the UK
but our compassion should be directed at
those who are genuinely helpless and
without agency and of course that
includes children but not those who do
have a choice about whether or not they
leave their home country or indeed those
who choose to exploit others through
international human trafficking
and in many ways this debate epitomizes
the great arguments of our time between
those whose understanding of Human
Rights is that anyone should more or
less be able to do whatever and go
wherever they want and those who believe
that strong boundaries and firm rules
and proportionate restrictions are
essential for strong families
communities and Nations it's an argument
between those who think that as a
wealthy country we somehow have
unlimited resources and don't
acknowledge that population growth over
recent years has put serious limits and
stretch on our capacity for example
housing and those who realize that even
though we are in a wealthy unfortunate
position there are serious limits on our
resources
many of those who argue against strong
borders and strong action against
illegal immigration are not themselves
personally affected by illegal
immigration their wages are not
threatened by the black market economy
they don't rely on essential local
resources that are taken up with housing
migrants their children are not sent to
school with young men who are clearly
not children and their sense of agency
and national identity does not rest on
the Integrity of our Borders or the
sovereignty of our Parliament
for those whose lives and culture are
not negatively impacted by thousands of
people arriving here on small boats it
makes sense to argue for open borders in
the name of compassion
but for many people for many of my
constituents these are luxury beliefs
and the reality is that high and clearly
visible levels of illegal immigration
are a threat to ordinary people's safety
security identity and sense of fair play
believing in and upholding strong
borders and firm boundaries is not
uncompassionate or bigoted it is a
prerequisite for a fair safe and
cohesive Nation
ultimately when boundaries are not
upheld or laws are not enforced it's
always the vulnerable that suffer as
criminals exploit loopholes and drain
much needed finite resources away from
those in genuine leave now I'm not going
to get give way because I've been given
a five minute limit by the chair now we
all want those in genuine Asylum Seekers
to be able to find safety here in the UK
and as the minister has said this
country is surpassed by any three other
nations in our acceptance of refugees
from the unhcr schemes but the
exploitation of our borders and laws by
those who are not in genuine need and
worse by abhorrent International people
smuggling gangs is neither Fair nor
compassionate and it must end so a
strengthened illegal migration bill will
deter people from making the treacherous
journey in small boats and give us the
resources and focus to uh go after those
more safe legal routes that I think
everybody in this house agrees should be
there
on the bacon thank you Mr chair and I
Rise to speak against the government
Clauses before the house today and in
favor of several amendments seeking to
limit their horror and inhumanity the
changes made by Claudius 37-48 to the
legal and human rights of Asylum Seekers
breached the UK's human rights
obligations the proposed time scales and
tests combined with the lack of judicial
oversight building unfairness and
undermine access to Justice it's
difficult to see how a vulnerable and
traumatized person would be able to
engage with the process especially as
the provisions do not set out any right
to legal advice and representation this
is one of the many reasons why I'm
supporting new Clause 26 in the name of
the honorable member for streatham which
would require an in an inequality impact
assessment of how people with protected
characteristics under the equality act
2010 will be particularly impacted by
the bill indeed protections for
vulnerable people pregnant women and
children are being tossed side in favor
of new powers to indefinitely detain
people at greater risk of harm including
survivors of torture trafficking and
modern slavery the new and sweeping
powers of arbitrary detention are
nothing short of spine chilling this
bill will increase the number of people
detained whilst removing the bulk of the
essential safeguards put in place to
protect people and adding to the
inherent harm caused by indefinite
detention and this is despite the UK's
immigration detention system being
plagued by mismanagement profiteering of
private companies and incidents of
systemic and direct abuse and neglect
including scandals reported at
brookhouse immigration removal Center
manston short term holding facility
hermansworth IRC and many others and
what is the purpose of this sweeping and
illegitimate restriction of people's
Liberties and what is the crime that
such individuals have committed to be
treated in a manner worse than serious
criminals are dealt with and with less
rights well Mr chair that this
government is today proposing to punish
people for seeking Asylum but not
satisfied with this they are seeking to
ensure that they are not able to
challenge this Injustice
all in order to essentially deter anyone
else from coming to the UK to seek
Sanctuary they're literally planning to
persecute the already persecuted
denying access to Asylum and such basis
undermines the very purpose for which
the refugee convention was established
and actually the convention explicitly
recognizes that refugees may be
compelled to enter a country of Asylum
irregularly
now the United Nations Refugee agency
has said that and I quote most people
fleeing war and persecution are simply
unable to access the required passports
and visas and that there are no safe and
legal routes available to them
the reality is that the UK offers safety
to far fewer refugees per capita than
the average European country including
France and Germany and to far fewer than
the countries neighboring those from
which seventy percent of the refugees
from the global South flee
that's why I'm supporting new cross 10
which sets out a requirement to
introduce a safe passage Visa scheme
table by my honorable friend the member
of Sheffield Hallam who spoke eloquently
um speaking about the the stories behind
the numbers and statistics the stories
behind the numbers and statistics who
are people people with real lives hopes
and dreams like the government seriously
wanted to protect the lives at risk from
Small Boat Crossings they would back
having more generous family
reunification rights and support safe
functioning routes
instead the bill before the house
tonight is the latest in a long line of
measures that form its hostile
environment and toxic racist and
xenophobic narrative that is taking hold
in many parts of the world based on fear
and the manipulation of that fear it's
immoral deeply cruel and divisive it
breaks international law crushes human
rights and it is shameful
thank you very much Tom Hunt thank you
very much Mr Mr Mr Evans I think if I um
I think I've waited a very long time to
speak on this bill I'm a second reading
I think I waited for four hours and
didn't get didn't get caught I've waited
a good amount of time here
um today
um
um so it's all it's done is maybe more
determined to get my points across
um and I have to I didn't sign any of
the Amendments for Lauren friend of us
today I had some sympathy with many of
the Amendments uh particularly
um particularly one three one Amendment
one three one my honorable friend and
member for devises and also my
um on my right honorable friend a member
for Middlesbrough and South East
Cleveland
um which is amendment one three two and
of course my
very senior colleague
um you're a good member for stone one
three three and one three four and
um and actually and actually something
might surprise some people but I Had A
Little Bit of Sympathy with um my
honorable friend remember for uh East
worth of insurance actually yeah there's
a moment 72 73 74 and 75 however I don't
think now is the right time to pursue
such a Amendment until we've sorted out
the scourge of illegal immigration and
currently impacts this country
General sense it wouldn't surprise
people to know that I welcome the
illegal migration bill I think it having
a situation where we have 45
000 people a year illegally entering the
country mostly men mostly young men
statistically proven many from safe
countries safe origin countries and of
course every single one of them has gone
through France and multiple other safe
European countries where they've refused
to claim Asylum and they've decided to
shop between different safe European
countries and they've come here and you
know we're actually having a dream of
moving to the the UK because of job
opportunities and and wanting to be you
know an economic migrant is a very Noble
um dream but of course my advice to them
would be to engage with our legal
migration Point space system and we will
make a determination and whether your
dream and our needs meet because of
course we are the party that believes in
controlling our borders we are a party
that believes the strong border controls
the labor party incredibly sensitive
When anybody suggests that they they
believe in open borders but of course
you know I simply say to them show me
the evidence show me the evidence that
you believe in controlled immigration
show me the evidence that you don't
believe in open borders because when I
look at your record every single thing
you vote on is against precisely those
things so I don't think it is
unreasonable for me and colleagues to
come to the conclusion that you're in
fact opposed to all border controls
right as I say show me the evidence when
I look at the when I look at the
amendment one three one of course a lot
of us will uh remember when we ran the
policy was first first introduced when
it was first introduced and a lot of us
supported it because we saw what
happened in Australia and we saw that
they had a massive problem with illegal
immigration I mean they they went down a
route of offshore processing and today
they don't have a massive problem for
legal immigration it is quite simple a
few people opposite say oh Australia
didn't work well actually we looked into
it in detail the Met Australian
officials did work and actually we think
that going ahead with a random policy
would clearly if it was given chance to
work provide a significant deterrent it
would save lives and see and it would
enable us to have a compassionate
controlled disciple system which most of
us want I think virtually all of us in
this place
um one so it was incredibly frustrating
when we saw that despite the brexit
referendum where we had a majority of
people in this country expressing a wish
to Take Back Control of our borders we
had an elected prime minister looking to
move forward a policy to do precisely
there but at the very last moment even
though our own courts located we had a
foreign judge in another land
crossing the whole thing and going up in
the courts now for almost getting
towards a year and the damage to that on
our democracy
um Michael institutions can see that
yeah it is deeply damaging and it is
unsustainable State of Affairs for us as
a sovereign country to be in a situation
where that is allowed to happen and of
course we were promised that the
nationality and bonus Bill what became a
national anthem borders act would
resolve all of these issues the reality
is we're still standing here and we
still have tens of thousands of people a
year entering this country illegally and
that and that foreign judge has been
able to essentially mean that there were
flights to around again get going and
how many Crossings have come about as a
result of that we also a situation of a
high court took six months to come to a
conclusion hopefully hopefully next
month we could have the appeal court
giving it the green light the Supreme
Court don't call it in and we could
actually have flights going off next
month and then we'll see whether the
approach works or not I think that it
will
um in terms of the support there is um
for this because we've heard lots of
different we've had lots of different uh
honorable friends a little members talk
about whether there's public support
well it's quite clear from what I've
seen But there is public support for
this building a country in fact I think
the support from this minimum country is
overwhelming
um and there's a and I also think and
I've we all engage with our constituents
and I've engaged with mine and actually
the support for around the policy is
also overwhelming
um and the anger that has come about I
won't talk to me amendment to this place
tomorrow with regards to Hotel
accommodation I won't talk to that but I
will briefly
um and this really strong opposition
there was to the use of a hotel at a
time where many of my constrictions are
struggling constituents are struggling
to get by struggling to pay their energy
bills and they can see people who have
illegally entered our country mainly
young men in a four-star hotel 28 28 of
my constituency worked from that hotel
being pressured to resign and a wider
economic impact in terms of a lack of
bed space in the town and they're
appalled by it of course you know others
take different views obviously last
weekend we had a number of Labor local
councilors and the labor MP candidate
um supporting the use of a hotel by
those who um enter our country illegally
um which is which is which is quite an
interesting View and one that I'd
actually advise them probably to change
bearing in mind that the surveys are
just starting to show that there's many
people who still intend to vote labor I
don't know why but who actually have
really hard line views immigration so I
suspect there's a risk that actually the
the conflict there might be exposed of
course I'll be playing role to do that
but in terms of the um
in terms of the the issue to do with
safe and legal groups because we often
hear from the labor party the labor
party say well no the problem is you
know if you have safe and legal routes
all of these problems will go away but
of course what was fascinating was for
the first time we had a we had a shallow
Minister saying actually they do believe
in a cap it's the first time I've heard
the labor party say that they would
support a cap on safe safe illegal Roots
um but actually what that cap is of
course we don't know what the cap would
be we don't know what the cat would be
we also don't know we also don't know
because we know that if there were these
safe and legal routes but actually many
people would fail through that route and
they'd probably still try and enter our
country illegally buy a small boat so
what would relate party do with those
individuals in those circumstances of
course they don't know
the key the key thing here and of course
we come to safer legal routes but I and
I do think you know I do think the
approach of my honorable friend
um my normal friend earlier in terms of
legal rights which I do think it's a
place we need to get to it's a place we
need to get to but I think we have to
take the public with us we have to take
the public with us and right now
understandably
the majority of the country are Furious
about illegal migration they are Furious
about people jumping the queue so we
need to deal with that and once we deal
with that we can move to that place of
talking about safe and legal routes but
I think right now would be too soon and
and I also talked to the fact that if we
if there isn't there are there are
hundreds of millions of people in the
world who would like to move to our
country and who of course there's
hundreds of millions who would like to
move to our country who could
conceivably get Refugee status so if we
talk about a cap to say from legal
routes we then need to talk about
prioritization we need to talk about
prioritization and the question which is
is it right that we prioritize young
single men from Albania over for example
some of the refugees I met two weekends
ago where was I two weekends ago I was
at the rohingya camp in Bangladesh it
was the third time I've been there and
you know who I spoke to overwhelmingly
women and children who had fled directly
for Myanmar some of the women have been
raped so their dads have been killed
their brothers have been killed and when
I asked them what they wanted all they
said is they want to go home safely
they don't have a choice about shopping
between different European countries
about where they go they don't have that
choice and the reality is I want us to
have compassion as a country I want us
to have a cap I want us to have safe and
legal groups and you know what once we
get control of the system I might be
happy with that cat being quite high and
actually I might want us to play a role
but the reality is right now for every
person who comes in illegally from
Summer such as Albania realistically
because of limited resources that's one
less person from somebody like rohingya
cab that we can support they are working
directly against your interests of some
of the most vulnerable in the world that
is a fact so the idea but but yeah so
I'm incredibly Pro genuine refugees
and and this argument another argument
we heard earlier which is that
I think once once we get the small boat
situations sorted out once we tackle
illegal migration we can put in place
a cap
driven by compassion
and and if that cap if if there's an
unforeseen disaster somewhere and
there's a there's a huge earthquake in
another country but I'm sure we'll be
able to come back to this place to ask
for this place we are electric chamber
to extend that cap bearing him and you
know what I think most people in the
country would support that
but to get where do we want to get to we
want to get to a place where we take a
large number of some of the world's most
desperate people but to get there we've
got to get control of the system we've
got to go over people's smokeless and I
know that this bill seems tough
but it is the only way it is the only
plan so I'm proud to speak I'm proud to
speak in favor of the Amendments
particularly from my honorable friend
Amendment one three one we've taught
Winston Churchill has been brought up by
of your position the idea that if he was
around today he would support a
situation where our Democratic chamber
was fraughted by Foreign judges
undermining a law brought forward by our
elected government is for the birds
would not be the case and I rest what
I've said thank you very much liquidly
very much Mr chairman uh I Rise to speak
in support of the new Clause 10 table
and name of my own friend a member for
Sheffield uh Helen but before I do I
just want to reflect on the unusual
circumstances in which we once again
find ourselves this is the second time
in only a few weeks that we've assembled
to scrutinize a bill in the committee of
the whole house both this and the
minimum several of the bills are truly
extraordinary pieces of legislation that
threatens to break with international
law and long-standing human rights
conventions which this nation once took
great pride in champaigning as the Home
Secretary itself admits on the face of
of this bill indeed the bill before is a
day is perhaps unprecedented in the
scale and ferocity of the criticism that
has attracted not just in the UK but for
the wide and International Community as
well the unhcr itself as Seth that the
effect on this bill undermines the very
purpose for which the 1951 Refugee
convention was established and yet the
government has given members just 12
hours to consider the bill at this stage
without any opportunity to take evidence
over the kind of detailed and forensic
scrutiny that would normally be found in
committee by contrast the 2016
Immigration Act which my party rightly
opposed but which represented a far less
dramatic departure from International
Norms than this bill went through 15
committee citizens and received 55
pieces of written evidence
as the Director of the institute for for
governments has rightly observed the
committee of the whole house is a useful
mechanism to legislate on the most
sensitive of matters particularly those
related to the Northern Ireland
executive but in the hands of disrupt
prime minister it has become a tool to
steamroll through legislation
legislation and stifle dissent which I
fear will be approve to be disastrous
consequences
members of this house of rice at the
right to be afforded at the time that we
need to properly scrutinize legislation
but that right count for a little when
we compare to the rights of refugees
fleeing unimaginable Horrors in the
pursuit of safety and I would not wish
to give the house the impression that I
believe that this bill is anyway
reformable far from us this is an
utterly hateful piece of legislation the
Central purpose of which is to
criminalize and demonize distant men
women and children fleeing conflict and
persecution as the bishop of York has
rightly said these proposals represent
Cruelty Without purpose
we are answering the end game of the
dying government that's devoid of any
plan for the future of our country and
which long ago lost the trust of the
British people and which now believes
that its only hope of claiming into
power is by stocking a stalking division
fear and zenfo vacated and laying the
blame for its own failings on innocent
refugees
I understand the honorable member for
Sheffield Helen does not wish to pay to
push in a member to a vote I have no
doubt that she like me wishes to see
this bill concerned to the scrappy in
its entirety but she has raised an
incredible important point about the
necessity of a style of establishing
safe and legal boots for those once who
claim Asylum what without the promise of
safe passage to the UK for those seeking
Sanctuary the plans that have been put
to the house today are destinied to fail
and ministers know this all too well
they understand that this bill is little
more than an attempt to stay Division
and to compound the misery of refugees
for the cheap political game
but more importantly still and I should
make this clear that it will never
support the principle of differentiating
between refugees based on how they
arrive in this country which is a clear
violation of their convention rights
establishing safe routes to Britain is
the only way we can guarantee that no
one is ever again forced to risk their
lives and the lives of loved ones on one
small boat in the channel
finally I want to remind our house that
last year more than 230 000 visas have
been issued to European unions now I
have said many times before that we
should in fact be doing far more to
assist old fling the war in Ukraine but
today's not a single Ukrainian has been
forced to resort to Small Boat Crossings
or people Smugglers
to reach the UK amazingly not a single
Ukrainian life has been lost in the
channel we have a model that already
works it's time to ensure that
everyone's seeking Refuge as the ability
to get here safely it's time to extend
safety routes for all
thank you very much
thank you very much and I Rise to
support the the Clauses in my name and
the over 50 Clauses uh and that of my
honorable colleagues we do not believe
this bill uh is fixable we believe this
bill is pretty important really in terms
of ripping up people's human rights and
contrary to what a member suggested
earlier on human net rights are not a
luxury belief human rights are for
everybody everywhere all at once and we
should not be trying to remove them for
anybody and particularly for people who
have suffered uh serious cases of trauma
and we made amendments to this bill in a
number of different ways to try and
point out the the many and various
deficiencies within this and IP tribute
to my honorable friend from Cameroon who
has been incredibly diligent in going
through the bill and seeing what we
could take out and try and reverse some
of the more harmful uh bits of this and
first to turn to Clause 37
and part seven of that in the Third
Country which aims to set tighter rules
of which kind of countries we might want
to return people to because not all
other third countries out there are
particularly safe for people and we
think we should be a lot tighter about
where we want to send people back a
point I will return to tomorrow in point
I in close 40 at 0.4 e of 1.4 B I want
to just highlight particularly and the
assurances that the government claims
it's going to um is going to take and
considering a serious harm suspensive
claim it says secretary state must take
into account the following factors any
assurances given by the government of
the territory specified in the removal
notice uh so I guess the government just
takes on trust that they say that
they're not going to do any harm to
somebody who has perhaps been a Critic
of that government and they'll say oh no
it'll be fine you return that person
they'll be fine we'll look after them
just fine until they don't
uh we won't find that out that person
won't find that out until they are
returned at point B it says that any
support and services including in
particular Medical Services provided by
that government and again I have had
cases where the person has um is
receiving HIV AIDS treatment in this
country which has got their condition
under control they cannot guarantee that
if they are returned to another country
that they will be able to continue that
treatment and in some cases that is
tantamount to a death sentence returning
with that condition or returning to a
country where that condition cannot be
managed and I have a constituent at the
moment who is waiting for a decision on
her case who is in renal failure and
cannot make progress on her treatment
because the home office will not get its
finger out and give her a decision to
allow her to continue with that case so
it is a very pressing issue and he he
Squints at him if he actually return to
any of the uh the cases that I raised
with him we'd actually make some
progress we also um I want to amend some
of the claim periods that are outlined
in the legislation they're incredibly
short and absolutely unrealistic I mean
this government doesn't do anything in
four days or eight days so to suggest
that they're going to make any decisions
in that is entirely unrealistic but in a
practical sense it means it's going to
make it very very difficult for people
in those situations to make their claim
it's going to make it difficult for them
to access a solicitor yeah and an app in
another very different practical sense
it makes it very difficult for those
people uh to actually make a claim
because for many people
who come to this country in situations
where they are seeking Asylum they can't
do things in the time scale that the
government's wishes because they have
experienced considerable trauma and
anybody who understands uh dealing with
considerable trauma will appreciate that
you will not be able to extract from
that person all the things that might in
the government's view be compelling
evidence in a time scale of just a
couple of days victims of torture
victims of trafficking victims of people
who have been forcibly recruited people
who have been asked to rape members of
their family or in some cases their
neighbors cannot disclose all of those
things just like that
they will need time to work through this
they will need specialist expertise and
support to to make those cases and those
claims and
they will not ever be able to make their
best case uh in the pressure of a few
days and the government I suspect knows
this because they're going to make it as
difficult as possible for people to make
those claims that's the very purpose of
why they are short-circuiting uh this
process and experts who would have given
evidence had the government given us
time to hear proper evidence such as
those from freedom from torture those
inequality and Human Rights Commission
who have said and their submission
to uh to all of us in this bill they see
a claim for suspension of removal must
be made within the seven days of a
notice of removal which may present
challenges for people who are
traumatized or otherwise invulnerable
situations do not speak English or lack
adequate
legal advice they're trying to prevent
people from making claims by making it
so short it is quite a deliberate
strategy and last week I had the the
privilege of meeting the the rainbow
sisters
part of the women for Refugee women
group and they told me in great detail
how difficult it was for them
as lesbians to describe to a home office
official why they were making that claim
because in the countries that they had
come from countries which I will return
again to
tomorrow outlined at the back of this
bill such as Ghana such as Kenya such as
Nigeria they were not allowed in those
countries
to describe the feelings that they held
because they could be prosecuted they
could be in prison they could be
equipped
for being gay so to expect those people
to come here when they don't have the
language to describe their experiences
they don't have any evidence to see to
describe their sexuality that they have
to do that in order to make a claim with
compelling evidence that sending them
back to those countries would put them
at risk it is really quite impossible in
those circumstances for those women to
describe their situations and yet the
home office expects this to happen and
I've sat in an immigration tribunal
where a constituent of mine was asked to
provide half a dozen people to testify
to our sexuality she had been here for
several years and even at that it was
difficult and traumatic for her to do
that so imagine just arriving and being
asked to try and provide that evidence
it would be incredibly difficult for
anybody to do under any circumstances
but particularly asking women to do it
in this circumstance and the government
again I suspect lose this
I I want to turn now to it was a
49.3 I believe uh right to the end here
uh page 52 and it says here that the
secretary States me out of state to the
list which they've described above that
in if only if satisfied that there is in
general in that state no serious risk of
persecution of Nationals of that
statement this is a list to which the
the Secretary of State can add whenever
she so feels and that she wants to I
would say that in general is doing a lot
of heavy lifting in that particular
Clause because in general there may be
no risk specifically there might be a
significant risk to that person to
somebody of that sexuality to somebody
with a particular protected
characteristic and again it overlooks
really in this bill the the protections
that the government
ought to be giving to people who are
coming here to seek Asylum
moving to the cap on the numbers uh that
has been described and many members over
there have been quite excitable about
the idea of a cap and there's no cap
number in this bill
it's for the Secretary of the State to
decide at some other point the Secretary
of State could set that cap at zero if
she wanted to because it's to be set
it's to be set as he well knows in
regulations which this Parliament cannot
amend so it is not for the parliament
it's for the Secretary of State as he
well knows he knows how statutory
instruments work in this place as do we
and he knows that it's not something
this house could have meant he is
absolutely being a bit expedient with
the truth if he's suggesting that those
cameraman it can't he knows that but it
says but what we are looking to do in
our Amendment 179 and the amendments in
the honor in the name of my honorable
friend from Glasgow North is to expand
those that should be consulted on this
and to set a Target not a cap
because it is not enough to sit a cat
and we know that there are circumstances
imagine you are the um either the 100
plus one person to be set by this cap it
could separate a family it could
separate uh siblings it could separate a
husband and wife who don't meet the
threshold who just follow the wrong side
of this threshold of this cap so the
government needs to do a whole lot more
in my view to make sure that we are
actively doing our bit in the world and
setting a cat is nowhere near doing our
bit in the world and I don't want to
keep the house much longer because I'll
be speaking again tomorrow but I want
just to mention the issue around
documents because it's been raised by
several members it was raised by The
Honorable member for South Holland in
the deepings whose uh not currently in a
place about documents now when
Afghanistan failed
um Dean Rosie and Afghanistan fail I was
contacted by constituents who were
terrified for their family members in
Afghanistan I had in the region of 80
families in my constituency who had
relatives in Afghanistan and I'm only
aware of two families who've been able
to get get reunited with their families
of that 80. that gov that is the
government not doing enough by people
who have family here who could be safe
who could be out of Afghanistan and they
are not
but and where it relates to documents is
that people in Afghanistan had documents
which if the Taliban found those
documents on them would prove that they
had worked for British forces and it
would be their death sentence so people
in Afghanistan burned those documents
that's why people will turn up here with
no documents because those documents
would have been their death sentence had
they been found in their possession and
members on the other side who seem to
think that not having documents is some
kind of a mission of guilt of some kind
feel to understand the very real
pressures that Asylum Seekers face when
they make these dangerous Journeys when
they try to seek Sanctuary here to
regain relationships with people that
they know they will run and they will
run and they will keep running until
they find safety and that is the reality
and that's what this building lies
people yeah yeah yeah Yasmin Qureshi
thank you Dane Rosie I wish I could say
that it was a pleasure to speak in this
debate as I normally do but I'm actually
incredibly sad about having to speak in
this debate this bill I think is one of
the most repugnant pieces of legislation
this government is trying to pass
through are there a number of reasons
for that firstly this government and the
Home Secretary knows that she is
breaching human rights laws and also
they know that this legislation actually
will not work either but the reason they
want to go ahead with it is because it
is to to a red meat to some of their
voter base some of the very hard
right-wing voters in our country this is
what this appeal is appealing to and
they are the people who will be voting
for this party when they see this
legislation come through now I don't
make these allegations likely I've been
hearing debates since the beginning
today
and some of the justification that the
member opposite have given Lefty lawyers
somehow this is a term of abuse
I'm a barrister I spend many years
studying to be one I find this repugnant
and yet you might want to call me a
lefty lawyer well I spend 14 years
Prosecuting nothing else but Prosecuting
work for the cpf
criminals rapists murderers
drug dealers all sorts of really
obnoxious people so then people like me
if we're not supporting this bill to be
called Lefty liberals or Lefty lawyers
or Rogue as a former for insult well I
think those who have to resort to those
type of terminology are really scraping
the bottom of the Bells and they had no
argument left because if they had any
proper argument that's what they would
be making we've had much discussion
about the European conventional human
rights and it's surprising everybody
says oh the European Court did this to
us hang on wake up we actually signed to
the convention on human rights we signed
to the refugee convention we are
signature to the NATO why when your
signature to this conventions you are
supposed to be abiding by them within
the European Convention of Human Rights
the European court is part of that
process so then just pick and choose
what you don't like from it is
absolutely out outrageous now we are one
of the members who spoke earlier so
denigrating the European Court of Human
Rights and I asked him directly I said
in the 70s a conservative government had
a legislation about requirement of
virginity tests for young women who were
applying to come into this country and
it was the European Court in human right
who actually declared that to be
unlawful but when I asked him does he
disagree with the European court on
human rights and guess what he does he
sidestepped and says well I can't defend
the heat government but that wasn't my
question whether you're defending heat
government my questions are fairly
unsquely about do you disagree with that
particular decision of the European
convention on human rights and the
reason he awarded it because he knows
that that convention a decision by the
court was absolutely correct and can I
just advise this court about the
European Court of Human Rights or the
European convention which as we know was
incorporated into the British human
rights act in 1998. now that particular
X says in section 18 that every single
legislation that comes before our
Parliament has to have a declaration on
it to say it is compatible with human
rights law the secretary of state knows
full well is not going to be which is
why on the face of the bill she states
oh well we're not sure whether it's
compatible with human rights law but
when she'd gone on the television she
said oh yes it is compatible with the
human rights well I would like her to
tell us which one does she think it is
because I can tell her that this is
incompatible with any Human Rights
Convention as well as our own Human
Rights Act passed by this government so
I really think that honorable members
out there really should use a better
arguments and then what could what
argument do they use I mean one of the
things I found sickening about not just
this bit but this whole debate on
migration and Asylum and everything for
the last number of years it's not just
the politicians here so we have the home
insect to say we're being swarmed and
invaded others saying that we've got 100
million people coming or sometimes they
say 800 a billion people well come off
it everybody knows there's not a billion
people trying to come in this country no
100 million refugees because 84 of the
refugees normally go to the country
nearest to them and most of the people
who've been coming on the boat recently
70 over 75 percent were successful in
their Asylum claims so this narrative
that we have the government and the
media like the daily meal the Express
and the sun running this narrative that
somehow these are all bogus Asylum
Seekers that's not of rubbish as well
now especially the media to talk rubbish
I expected them to lie but you know what
it really pains me when honorable
members members of parliament who've
been elected talking that kind of
divisive language and it is because of
that so divisive disgusting language
that we've had internal people being
assaulted where people are living in a
Asylum hostels where people are kind of
attacking them swearing at them
protesting against them is because of
the language that is used and is being
used in the country and in discourse on
immigration and I have to say to every
member here especially on the opposition
benches and the media if they're
listening please for God's sake just
temper your language and don't pedal
untruth and the untruth and that's what
they are what we have a situation is a
lot of these people are coming in verse
because there's no other alternative now
the shadow Minister when he started his
debate said and mentioned about at least
five constructive proposals which would
deal with the issue of the boat crisis
but guess what this government isn't
doing that the reason being is because
ever since we've had from 2010
conservative prime minister everything
will conservative prime minister every
single conservative for a home secretary
has said oh we're going to until
migration oh we're going to reduce
Asylum seeking we're going to do this
but guess what 13 years down the road
they've been in charge they're done zilt
nothing the number of people they've
been able to return are abysmal when we
left office 18 000 people were on the
asylum application but now it is 160
000. 13 years of your government being
controlled whatever you done nothing
it's all rhetoric it's all talks
sorry
it just needs to be quite careful with
her language when she's talking about
your government I.E yes thank you Dane
Rosie for reminding me of the fact that
uh you know this government had a
control for the last 13 years a
conservative government and yet they've
not been able to deal with it the reason
is because unless you take some
constructive proper proposals and not
running to what's the best headline in
the daily mail or that should I say the
daily hate right
um you know they don't think that that's
worth it so this piece of legislation
it absolutely horrendous and I'm really
sad that we're here again because few
years ago we had the nationality and
borders Bill we had all these bills
every time we had those bills it was
said we're going to control migration
illegal migration guess what nothing
happened it's all hot air it's all
smokes and mirrors it is trying to fool
the people of this country that you're
trying to do with something when you
know that you're not doing and if your
best attacks
[Music]
and I just want to
um just finally end
many members today have spoken about
various safe routes
there have been a lot of suggestions
made about how to deal with this issue
of the small boat there have been
colleagues who've spoken about legal
side of it
I have to say that if there's any
Humanity in this government they should
think about withdrawing this bill and
actually deal with the issue of small
boat and can they please stop trying to
appease to populist sentiments
and Rosie I Rise to speak to the liberal
Democrats amendment's new Clause 3
nucleus four and nucleus six
Madam chair I struggled to put into
words my dismay about this bill I've
been listening to this debate since the
very beginning and listening to the
members opposite accepting a few members
who have spoken with real insight
members officers cannot hide their
frustration at three years on from
brexit and we still don't control our
borders in fact we are further away from
it than ever and it shows up a
fundamental misunderstanding namely that
Britain is only ever part of a global
Community we don't rule it and we only
get through what we want through
cooperation we will only succeed in
stopping illegal immigration by
cooperation and not by breaking
International agreements
nobody can be opposed to stopping people
traffickers who are exploiting desperate
men women and children but this bill is
no way to go about it and it will not be
successful in stopping the boats from
coming all it will achieve is to punish
those who least deserve it will the
government finally listen to what we
have said from the opposition benches
for such a long time and that is we must
create safe and legal and effective
effective fruits to immigration if we
are serious about a compassionate and
fair system of immigration new Coral six
would facilitate to facilitate a safe
passage pilot scheme new Clause 4 would
require the Home Secretary to set up a
humanitarian travel scheme it would
allow people from specified countries or
territories to enter the UK to make an
asylum claim on their arrival the only
way to make sure that refugees do not
risk their lives in the channel is to
make safe and effective legal routes
available my inbox Madame chair has been
full of constituents outraged at the
government's plans to abandon some of
the most vulnerable people in the world
in bath we have welcome Trump refugees
from Syria Afghanistan and Ukraine and
stand ready to do more while this
government is intent on ending our
country's long and proud history as a
refuge for those fleeing war and
persecution
the Home Secretary has been unable to
confirm that this bill is compatible
with the European conventional human
rights Clause 49 allows the Secretary of
State to make Provisions about interim
measures issued by the European Court of
Human Rights and the Law Society
has showed it has said has raised its
concerns that this shows an intent to
disregard the Court's measures and break
international law the government's
promise is that people fleeing worn
prosecution could find a home in the UK
through a safe and legal route must be
something that is actually true and real
and does what it do that wants to do
rather than promising something that
does not happen now is the time to put
action behind words so far this bill
does not even Define what a safe and
legal route is and I agree
um with the honorable lady from Wilson
let me name one example why it is so
important that we have safe and legal
roots and that is Afghanistan just 20
two Afghan citizens who were eligible
for the UK resettlement scheme have
arised in the UK and the minister have
said oh we have taken thousands before
the invasion of Kabul we are talking
about resettlement scheme that was set
up in
1929 2022 a year ago and only 22 have
been resettled through that scheme that
the government has set up a year ago
that is the question we are not talking
about what happened in 2015 or what when
it happened and before the invasion of
Kabul we are talking about the safe and
legal roots that this government has set
up 22 of Afghan citizens have been
resettled under that scheme that is the
reality and the minister cannot walk
away from that
that is a shameful record women and
girls especially who were promised
safety have been left without a specific
route to apply we cannot leave them to
their faith every day we hear about the
cruel uh uh the way that the Taliban
treats women and girls who are excluded
from education who are excluded from
jobs who have to do what they want to do
in hiding and who are not safe the
government has promised them safety they
cannot come you must ensure that new
promises of safe and legal roots cannot
be broken Section 8 of the bill sets out
a cup on the number of refugees entering
via safe routes but it does not use a
specific figure there's also no
obligation for the government to
facilitate that number of people
arriving the government's current record
does not Inspire confidence the UK
grants less Asylum application than the
EU average in 2022 only 1185
refugees were settled to the UK this is
nearly 80 percent lower than in 2019.
this is why the government should
support new clause 3. it requires to get
Secretary of State to set a resettlement
target of at least 10 000 people each
year refugees make dangerous Journeys
because they are in danger if we are
serious about stopping illegal people
trafficking we must provide safe routes
for refugees first not punish refugees
who have the right to be here first the
bill as it stands criminalizes desperate
people making perilous Journeys to seek
safety refugees who are coming here
because they believe they will find
Sanctuary we must show them compassion
we must not show them our backs thank
you yeah yeah
and I want to thank the the uh the
minister uh for the secretary dedicating
her kind of being here at the beginning
of the of the beer and for the minister
have been here now to hear our
contributions
this is a something that has proven
incredibly contentious either in this
chamber or on social media we have heard
the views of so many Sometimes some more
distaste from and others I have to say I
say that very respectfully the principle
is still the same that I believe we do
have a a very clear responsibility to
protect those who are most vulnerable in
the in in their societies but we kind of
say that the invitation can be extended
to everyone with no questions asked to
discuss the steps we can take to perfect
our Asylum system
I want to speak if I can to nucleus six
uh uh it's a relation to CF passage and
also the new Clause 24 and 25 which
refers to Northern Ireland The Joint
Committee and human rights have raised
significant concerns in this bill in
relation to parallels between
trafficking slavery and Asylum this bill
will have an unintended but nevertheless
devastating impact on victims of modern
slippery they have stated that illegal
immigration is often used as a weapon to
exploit people for profit and and
criminal gangs are often the ones in
learning vulnerable people on the boots
into the UK there were 5144
modern scribby offenses recorded by the
police in England and Wales in the year
ending march 2019 an increase of 51 from
the previous year in addition to Poverty
lack of Education unstable social and
political conditions economic imbalances
climate change and War are key issues
that contribute to someone's
vulnerability and becoming a victim of
modern slavery slavery
we cannot close the door on genuine
victims of trafficking and celebrity and
we cannot allow you to build to
undermine the security of victims
according to the recent home office
statistics nearly 550 people were
potentially trafficked in north northern
I want to give an ordinary perspective
to this debate if I can volunteer an
increase of 54 50 percent from 2021 when
the figure was 363. in the last four
years the number of people referred
through the national referral mechanism
in Northern increased by one thousand
percent so we have an issue maybe not
the numerical numbers that are here in
the UK
Miner they are key issues
new Clause 19 which refers to the
extension to Wales Scotland and Northern
Ireland I I wish to refer to as well and
also 24 25 which which also refers uh to
uh Northern Ireland and takes on the
three particular ones
um and Provisions relating to Northern
Ireland for trafficking for exploitation
and I believe it's important that we
have the same
um opportunity to respond in a way that
can help
there is no doubt of the impact of
detention due to send them are going to
have an incredible impact on some
migrants we're often too quick to assign
Asylum Seekers under the same level but
forget that a large proportion of women
and young children who come here legally
do come from war-torn countries where
they've been ripped away from their
families into space with no other option
but they get out and make the best of a
potential life somewhere else there are
real gen Yang cases out there that there
are families that do need legitimate
help and it's a big-hearted company I
believe that we have a duty to do this
under this um new legislation the
homeowners will be given new powers to
provide accommodation for unaccompanied
children but these Provisions only
applied to England and it's only been
considered and I would ask if this is
extended to other areas of the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland in terms of the tension there's
no data we do have to compare
circumstances there's a difference
between those that I just mentioned
those people uh women and children who
are displaced and those who come with
nurture and no family and are usually
young they have the ability to build a
new life uh elsewhere as possible but
because they are healthy whereas for
women and children who have been forced
out detention policies do need to be
different to conclude modern Deputy
chair
to keep us in the time limit that others
have adhered to I'm in support of some
of the aspects of this need a bill I
respect this context contents on on the
efforts by the minister to try to come
up with a solution that gets a bounce
but I think we all need some assurances
in relation to how IT addresses the
issue of modern slavery
and trafficking potentials too many
people are forced into this each each
year I have no doubt this idea State and
the minister here tonight and her
department will do all they count to
ensure this is dealt with but given the
sheer volumes of how this is impacting
on our country and our great nation the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland I would urge this is
dealt with as a matter of National
Security I was a modern emergency and
the credit we get assorted the better
and this ensure that those people who
are genuine Asylum Seekers are given the
opportunity to come to this company and
I would wish to see that happening as
well thank you very much
Mary California
thank you Dean Rosie let me be clear
this bill is inhumane it's not an
illegal migration bill it's an
anti-refugee Bill and an extension of
the field hostile environment policy
introduced by the party opposite and the
Andy Refugee MPS have been emboldened by
the Home secretaries rhetoric
the homes can I just can't know oh I'm
not going to give away at this point
I've waited since half past five
[Laughter]
sorry Bob
anti-refugees have been emboldened in
here today by the Home secretary's
rhetoric of hate as we can see by the
Amendments and the Clauses and by what
we've heard by many of the members
opposite and unbelievably the bill now
has the potential to be even worse than
when it came to the house on the second
reading and let's not forget Jay that
the day after an immigration facility
was literally attacked it was fire
bombed the Home Secretary spoke of an
invasion of Southern England in fact
it's been reported today that the Home
Secretary has even fueled a rebellion
against her own bill in order to
introduce tougher amendments
and I want to put on record share that
no migrant or Refugee is responsible for
the state our country is in right now
the crisis in our education system
in-house and in our NHS has been caused
by the part the opposite and 13 years of
Tory failure not those fleeing from
conflict and climate change and they
deserve our compassion not our contempt
thankfully my honorable friends the the
members who are popular and popular and
Lighthouse Sheffield Hallam and stretton
proposed a number of new amendments and
Clauses that can drastically improve
this bill and they deserve the full
support of this house new Clause 10
tabled by the member for Sheffield
Hallam sets out a requirement to
introduce a safe passage Visa which
would give entry clearance to those
already in Europe wishing to come to
Britain to make an asylum claim
critically this can end the crisis in
the English Channel by providing
refugees with safe passages and safe
routes in its current form the bill
relies on the idea of deterrence to stop
small boat protons but as we've seen
time and time again deterrence doesn't
work there's no robust evidence to
support this idea
dangerous Crossings have continued even
since the nationality and borders built
Act and the the Rwanda Asylum plan
a chair there's also an issue of
parliamentary scrutiny this bill may
have significant implications for
British Britain's Asylum system the
European convention on human rights and
or International legal obligations but
we only have two days in which to debate
it which isn't acceptable for a major
piece of legislation detailed scrutiny
is invaluable at picking up potential
problems of which this bill has many
and the members opposite have no right
to speak about parliamentary sovereignty
when the Russian this the piece of
complicated legislation through with
minimal scrutiny
modern chair I think about those 27
people who tragically died in November
2021 crossing the channel as well as
those who've lost their lives crossing
the Mediterranean seeking Refuge their
deaths could have been avoided if they'd
been safe passages a humanitarian
Corridor in place we've had the
opportunity this evening to do that to
introduce an amendment that can provide
safe passage for our fellow human beings
and reject the potentially fatal
elements of this bill and
Minister Robert
yeah well thank you Dame Rosie and this
has been an excellent debate covering
the provisions of the bill relating to
legal proceedings the cap on the number
of refugees to be admitted through new
safe and legal routes and safe countries
of origin let me deal very briefly uh
Dame Rosie with the substantive
government amendments in this group
first we have brought forward up if I
could just finish this point I'll
happily come to the uh The Honorable
gentleman a moment uh first of all a new
Clause 11 7 enables the senior president
of tribunals to request first-tier
tribunal judges including employment
tribunal judges to sit as judges of the
upper tribunal this amendment extends
existing deployment Powers which are an
important tool for the Judiciary to
manage the fluctuations in demand in our
courts making best use of their time
we're also Dame brosie bring forward new
Clause 12 which enables appeals under
the bill to be heard by the special
immigration appeals commission rather
than the upper tribunal inappropriate
cases and this Dame Rosie is necessary
to safeguard the sensitive material
which would cause harm to the public or
individuals if it were revealed in open
court and the test for certifying
suspensive claims will require that the
Home Secretary certified the decision
being taken relies partly or wholly on
information which in her opinion should
not be made public so I hope that these
government amendments will receive the
sport of the whole house and I'll
happily give way to The Honorable
gentleman I thank the minister very much
for giving way he'll recall that at the
beginning of this debate I raised a
point of order about the um fact that he
on the 19th of December said that when
labor left office in 2010 the backlog
was 450 000 uh the Asylum backlog his
words
um I have received a letter from the UK
statistics Authority completely
debunking that claim saying that in fact
the backlog was 19 000 and the backlog
now is 166 000. as he's at the dispatch
box I thought it would be a perfect
opportunity for him to apologize to the
house and to correct the record as per
his duties under the ministerial code
grateful to The Honorable gentleman for
looking out for me and it's
it's understandable that there would be
confusion on this point because as I
think my right or friend the former
prime minister said in the second
reading debate the situation that we
inherited in 2010 was a complete
shambles uh indeed the former labor Home
Secretary described the department as
not fit for purpose now what we were
referring to what we were referring to
was John Vine John Vine was the Chief
Inspector of borders and immigration and
he conducted a report into the shambolic
handling of the immigration system by
the last Labor government and he said
that in 2007 the UK border agency
created the euphemistically titled case
resolution directorate to conclude
approximately 400 to 450
000 unresolved Legacy records and he
said such was the inefficiency of this
operation that at one point over 150
boxes of posts including correspondence
from applicants from members of
parliament and their legal
Representatives lay unopened in a room
in Liverpool
that room I'm told was colloquially
known as the room of Doom well Dame
Rosie we're fixing the system and I'm
pleased to say no I'm not going to give
away again he's had his moment I've he's
had his moment I'm pleased to say that
as a result of the work that the Home
Secretary the Prime Minister and I have
already done the Legacy backlog is
falling rapidly and we intend to meet
our commitment to clear it over the
course of the year I won't give way to
the The Honorable lady
um now I don't want to detain the house
for too long so let me turn to the key
points that have been raised tonight
firstly with respect to I thought the
very powerful speeches from my honorable
friends the members for devises for
Middlesbrough South
for stone for South Holland and the
deepings and others relating to the
important question of injunctive relief
rule 39 how we as a sovereign Parliament
handle ourselves and ensure that we
secure our borders I thank Marvel
friends for their contributions and I
recognize the positive active intention
of the Amendments that they have tabled
I am certainly Keen to give them an
undertaking to engage with them and
other colleagues who are interested in
these points ahead of report stage of
the bill
we are united in our determination that
this bill will be a robust bill that it
will be able to survive the kind of
egregious and vexatious legal challenges
that we've seen in the past and that it
will enable us to do the job and to
remove illegal immigrants to save third
countries like Rwanda
I would add that the bill has been
carefully drafted in collaboration with
some of the finest legal Minds who and
we do believe that it enables us to do
the job whilst complying with our
international law obligations but we are
going to we are going to engage closely
with colleagues and ensure that the
final bill meets the requirements of all
on our side of the house
your way to The Honorable gentleman um
let me also speak briefly about the
point made by a number of colleagues
about rule 39 in particular
and the events of last summer and I'll
only say this that we in government
share the frustration of those certainly
on this side of the house
about what happened with the Rwanda
flight in June where a case was
conducted late at night at the last
minute with no chance for us to make our
case or appeal its decision that was
deeply flawed and I thought that The
Honorable lady for Edinburgh Southwest
was right when she said in a thoughtful
contribution that that does raise
concerning issues I think that raises
issues of natural Justice and they're
ones that my rightful friend the
attorney general and others within
government are taking up with the court
and we want to find a more satisfactory
way for the court to behave in such
circumstances in the future
I will turn briefly to the swathe of
amendments uh brought forward by the SMP
at the at this rate
there are going to be more amendments to
this bill brought forward by the s p
then there are refugees that the SMP
accommodate in Scotland
instead of pruning the already
uh excessive Forest of legal challenges
that we find The Honorable lady is
proposing a kafka-esque array of new
ones what she wants to do is turn the
robust scheme that is within this bill
into a sieve we can't allow that to
happen because the Mandate of the
British public is clear they want us to
stop the boats that's what this bill
does that's what we intend to achieve
now if I could
friends the
for Worthing East and Shoreham
and I want to thank the honorable John
for his contribution and we have
listened very carefully to his arguments
as the Prime Minister has said it is
precisely because we want to help
genuine refugees though we need to take
full control of our borders
safe and legal routes like those that we
have brought forward in recent years the
safe and legal routes that have enabled
almost half a million people to come
into our country for humanitarian
purposes since 2015 are exactly how we
will achieve that and I can commit to
engage with him and other colleagues
ahead of report stage in setting up safe
and legal routes if necessary bringing
forward further amendments to ensure
that there are new routes in addition to
the existing schemes and accelerating
the point at which they become
operational With Our intention to open
them next year and in addition I can
confirm that we'll accelerate the
process of launching the local Authority
consultation on safe and legal routes at
the same time as commencement of the
bill and I hope that satisfies The
Honorable member
I would add as a former local government
secretary that one provision in the bill
mentioned by a number of colleagues on
this side of the house but curiously not
mentioned by those opposite is extremely
important which is that we will not make
promises on this side of the house in
this place at the expense of local
authorities and our constituents and so
for the first time not only will we
bring forward more safer legal routes
but we will consult with local
communities and with local authorities
first so that those routes are not
virtue signaling but are wedded in the
genuine capacity of our communities the
ability to House people the ability to
find GP surgery appointments the ability
to find school places and the ability
for our communities
to sustainably bring those individuals
into the country and ensure that
Community tensions are not unnecessarily
raised I won't give way to The Honorable
gentleman and this is a critical
distinction this is a critical
distinction well I will give way to
Andrea because in his remarks at one
point he said he was for the cap then he
said he was against the cap so perhaps
he couldn't explain no I I just he's
making some very good points on local
Authority consultation will he therefore
be supporting our new Clause 27 tomorrow
which makes it a legal requirement for
the home office to consult with local
authorities before deciding on hotels
read the bill I mean I thought we've
been debating it for the last five and a
half hours but he doesn't seem to have
read it the bill says for the very first
time that before we create a safe and
legal route we'll consult with local
authorities and I think that we all
should see that as a good step forward
because the public are sick of their
hotels being filled with illegal
immigrants and they don't want to see
the well-being of illegal immigrants put
above those of the British public and
that's a crucial change that we're
making so
uh Mr chairman I shall close at that
point with the by making a simple point
that the choice ahead of us today is
this
is it for the British Parliament to
decide who enters this country or is it
for the people smuggling gangs on this
side of the house we believe that
without border board controls National
Security is compromised the fabric of
communities begins to fray and public
services come under intolerable pressure
we believe that whilst we should always
be generous to those in need there are
limits on how much support we can
provide we believe that we should
prioritize our finite resources as in a
powerful speech my honorable friend the
member for Ipswich said
directly on those in Conflict zones not
those who are fit enough aware enough
and Wealthy enough to get to a safe
country like France and then cross the
channel
it is remembers on this side of the
house who are on the right side of the
moral argument
a what of the party opposite led by the
member for Holborn and Saint Pancras he
campaigned to close removal centers he
wants to scrap our Rwanda partnership
he's the human rights lawyer who sided
with foreign National offenders over the
law-abiding British public he's the
prosecutor
who votes against tougher sentences for
the people smuggling gangs it's clear
for all to see
can't rely on the labor party to stop
the boats they don't have a plan because
they don't think there's a problem
they're too naive to understand what
this country is up against and what's at
stake and they're too weak to take the
tough but necessary measures to deter
The Crossings and fix our broken Asylum
system
that's why we brought forward this bill
that is the determination and the
commitment of my right or friend the
Prime Minister the Home Secretary and I
we will stop the votes this bill begins
that
McDonald's
for allowing me to speak again Mr chair
because what we've had today has been an
absolute disgrace of a debate the
timetabling of this really important
bill has been absolutely shocking
whichever side of this debate you are on
we must understand that this is of
incredible what constitutional
significance there are questions here
about whether or not we are breaking
some absolutely fundamental treaty
obligations and yet we've been treated
to nothing more than a few slogans and
not a single effort to address any of
the Amendments that we put down in good
faith those amendments were put down not
just off my own back but in consultation
with the Law Society I lost a Scotland
immigration law practitioners lots of
respected organizations who deserve and
are deserve to have their voice held
here and they deserve to be retreated
with respect by this government
so this whole process has been an
absolute embarrassment to Parliament
where is the impact assessment that we
should have had before this bill that is
just as disgraceful as a the lack of
respect for the Amendments that have
been table today so Mr chair what we've
had today is is not a serious debate
we've had slogans we've had dog whistle
rhetoric and we have our government that
has just shown that it's all slogans and
absolutely no respect for his Parliament
at all
foreign
I'm anticipating four divisions and I'll
try and assist the house as to when they
are likely to happen but firstly we go
to Sir William cash and is it your
pleasure that Amendment 133 be withdrawn
Mr Debbie speaker in the light of the
firm and clear Assurance given by my
right honorable friend in relation to my
amendments if I leave the house I
withdraw the amendment and meant by
leave withdrawn
now I think we come to the first of the
divisions and I've selected Amendment 76
for separate decision and I call Alison
thulis to move Amendment 76 formally the
question is that Amendment 76 be made is
free no
and Lobby
hours
the question is amendment 76 be made as
many of that opinion say aye country no
no tell us for the ice Peter Grant and
Marion fellows to us for the nose Julie
Martin and my quote
thank you
[Music]